CALL THE ASSEMBLY HUMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE HEARING TO
ORDER. OKAY LOOKS LIKE WE DON'T
HAVE A QUORUM- BUT I DO HAVE
SOME ANNOUNCEMENTS- WELCOME TO
THE JUNE THIRTIETH HEARING OF
THE ASSEMBLY SERVICES
COMMITTEE. A TO START I'D LIKE
TO THANK ALL OF THE STAFF THAT
HAVE MADE POSSIBLE OUR ABILITY
TO MAXIMIZE OPPORTUNITIES. FOR
SAFE PARTICIPATION IN OUR
HEARINGS. I ALSO LIKE TO
WELCOME. OUR NEWEST MEMBER
ASSEMBLY MEN I THINK BRIAN
WHO'S ON HIS WAY HERE. AND TO
THAT END ALL NOW SHARE A FEW
NOTES ABOUT THE LOGISTICS OF
OUR HEARING TODAY. REGARDING
THE PUBLIC'S ACCESS TO THE
DISCUSSION. TODAY WE ARE
CONDUCTING AN IN PERSON HEARING
IN ROOM FORTY TWO- TO. FACE
COVERINGS ARE REQUIRED FOR ALL
MEMBERS EMPLOYEES AND THE
PUBLIC IN ALL COMMON AREAS IN
SHARED SPACES INCLUDING THIS
HEARING ROOM REGARDLESS OF
VACCINATION STATUS. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY ON
THIS BILL ON THE BILL PLEASE
RAISE YOUR HAND AND I'LL ASK
YOU TO APPROACH THE MICROPHONE.
PLEASE DO NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. WE'LL BE USING A
MODERATED TELEPHONE SERVICE
THROUGH WHICH ANY WITNESS CAN
TESTIFY ON A BILL. THE CALLING
NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN. SIX NINE TWO
EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND THE
ACCESS CODE IS. ONE THREE ONE
FIVE FOUR TWO ZERO TWO YOU CAN
ALSO FIND THIS NUMBER ON THE
COMMITTEE'S WEBSITE AS WELL AS
ON YOUR TV SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE DO SO NOW THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE A
BELL. WHEN CALLING IN PLEASE
ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND NOISE
THIS INCLUDES MEETING YOUR
LIVESTREAM BROADCASTING YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. IN ADDITION
TO BEING ABLE TO TESTIFY FROM
INSIDE THE HEARING ROOM OR VIA
THE PHONE WE HAVE THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION AVAILABLE FOR
PRIMARY AND ME TO WITNESSES.
THESE STATIONS ARE LOCATED AT
THE NORTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
THOSE WITNESSES WILL APPEAR ON
THE SCREEN SO MEMBERS CAN WATCH
THE TESTIMONY LIVE FROM OUTSIDE
OF THE HEARING ROOM- AND ALSO
ASK THEM QUESTIONS. I WOULD
LIKE TO ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THE
ASSEMBLY HAS ENCOUNTERED
REPEATED DISRUPTIONS OF ITS
PROCEEDINGS IN RECENT YEARS.
AND THESE DISRUPTIONS HAVE
INCREASED THIS YEAR. RECENT
DISRUPTIONS OF GOVERNMENT
PROCEEDINGS HERE IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND AT THE US CAPITOL
NECESSITATE CONSISTENT
ENFORCEMENT OF LAWS AND RULES
AGAINST DISRUPTION. CONDUCT
THAT DISRUPTS AND DISTURBS AND
OTHERWISE IMPEDES THE ORDERLY
CONDUCT OF THIS HEARING IS
PROHIBITED. IF DISRUPTIVE
BEHAVIOR OCCURS TODAY YOU WILL
BE REMOVED FROM FROM THE
HEARING ROOM BY THE ASSEMBLY
SERGEANTS OR YOU WILL BE
REMOVED FROM THE CALL. OKAY I
DOES NOT LOOK LIKE WE HAVE A
QUORUM YET SO WE DO OKAY. ALL
RIGHT SO- LET'S GO AHEAD AND
ESTABLISH A QUORUM- WE HAVE
SIXTEEN BILLS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY AND SEVEN OF THESE BILLS
ARE ON CONSENT. OKAY CAN YOU
PLEASE. CALDERON PRESIDENT
DAVIS ARAMBULA. BRIAN CHOI HERE
STONE PHILIP COULD DO THAT. FOR
THANK YOU. OKAY SO- OKAY. NOW
WE'RE GONNA TAKE UP THE
MEASURES ON CONSENT OF THE
FOLLOWING MEASURES ARE ON
CONSENT FILE ITEM SIX SB SIX OH
NINE HER TADO. FILE ITEM SEVEN
SB FIVE FORTY NINE JONES FILE
ITEM EIGHT SB FIVE EIGHTY FOUR
JONES. FILE ITEM NINE S. B. TWO
FORTY SIX LEYVA FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SB FOUR NINETY SEVEN
LAMONT. FILE ITEM TWELVE SB
FIVE TWELVE MEN AND FILE ITEM
THIRTEEN SB SIX SEVENTY EIGHT
RUBIO. DRIVER MOTION ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR CALDERON. AYE
CALDERON AYE DAVIES. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BRIAN. BRIAN I CHOI
CHOICE LIFESTYLE FILIPPIDIS
RELATED TO OUR SITE LORD. LORD
I. RIGHT NOW. OKAY. WE'LL LEAVE
THE ROLE OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS TO ADD ON. OKAY SO.
OKAY I DON'T SEE ANY AUTHORS-
HERE AT THIS TIME. SO- IF STAFF
FOR LISTENING OUR PARTY COULD
HAVE YOUR SENATORS PLEASE COME
TO ROOM FORTY TWO- TAYLOR IF
THE BILL TO TAKE UP UP OKAY WE
HAVE SENATOR RAZA. GREAT.
ACTUALLY GREAT WE HAVE OUR OUR
FIRST PRESENTER SENATOR TORONTO
WELCOME SENATOR TORONTO. YES
SENATOR PLEASE GO HEAD WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY AND THREE FOR
THIRTY NINE SIX SB SIX THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MA'AM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE I WANT TO THANK
THE COMMITTEE VERY MUCH FOR
WORKING WITH US ON. THEIR
ANALYSIS AND THAT I ACCEPT THE
TECHNICAL AMENDMENT ON PAGE
TEN- SB SIX THIRTY NINE ENSURES
THAT WORKERS WITH DISABILITIES
CANNOT BE PAID LESS THAN
MINIMUM WAGE. SINCE THE THIRD
NINETEEN THIRTIES THE STATE HAS
BEEN ABLE TO PAY WORKERS WITH
DISABILITIES LESS THAN MINIMUM
WAGE THROUGH THE ISSUANCE OF
FOURTEEN C. CERTIFICATES. UNDER
THE FEDERAL FAIR LABOR
STANDARDS ACT. SO EVEN THIS
CALIFORNIA PRIDES ITSELF IN
LEADING THE COUNTRY WITH OUR
MINIMUM WAGE A WORKER
PROTECTIONS THOUSANDS OF
CALIFORNIANS WITH DISABILITIES
ARE STILL BEING- ARE STILL
WORKING IN SEGREGATED SETTINGS
OFTEN. FOR LESS THAN TWO
DOLLARS AN HOUR. SB SIX THIRTY
NINE PROHIBITS THE ISSUANCE OF
NEW. FORTY C. CERTIFICATES BY
JANUARY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY
TWO. AND DEVELOPED A PHASE OUT
PLAN FOR CURRENT EMPLOYERS TO
ENSURE A PATH TO COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT. I TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THIS BILL WILL END
THE PRACTICE OF SEGREGATED SOME
MINIMUM WAGE EMPLOYMENT
ENTIRELY. THIS PRACTICE IS AN
ARCHAIC RELIC OF THE NINETEEN
THIRTIES AND DATES BACK TO A
TIME WHEN CHILDREN WITH
DISABILITIES WERE DENIED AN
EDUCATION. AND BEFORE CIVIL
RIGHTS LEGISLATION SUCH AS THE
AMERICANS WITH DISABILITIES ACT
RECOGNIZE THE FULL HUMANITY OF
PERSONS WITH DISABILITIES. IF
ENACTED CALIFORNIA WILL JOIN
THE STATES OF ALASKA
CONNECTICUT MARYLAND NEW
HAMPSHIRE NEW YORK RHODE
ISLAND. TEXAS AND WASHINGTON IN
PROHIBITING SUB MINIMUM WAGE
EMPLOYMENT OR SHELTERED
WORKSHOPS I ALSO WANT TO ADD
THAT THE LEGISLATURE IS
INVESTING HEAVILY IN PROGRAMS
THAT WILL SUPPORT THE
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OF
INDIVIDUALS MOVING OUT. OF
SHELTERED WORKSHOPS WE ARE
PROVIDING FOR EXAMPLE AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE COORDINATORS WILL BE
ASSISTING INDIVIDUALS MOVING
OUT OF SHELTERED WORKSHOPS WE
ARE ALSO INVESTING IN
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. BY NEW INITIATIVES
SUCH AS DOUBLING THE INCENTIVE
PAYMENTS TO SERVICE PROVIDERS
REPLACING AN INDIVIDUAL INTO
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT IF THE INDIVIDUAL
MAINTAINS EMPLOYMENT FOR
SPECIFIED MILESTONES WE WANT
EVERY PERSON COMING OUT OF A
SHELTERED WORKSHOP. TO HAVE A
MEANINGFUL DAY AND THE
MEANINGFUL EXPERIENCES AND THIS
BUDGET INVESTS HEAVILY TO MAKE
THAT HAPPEN. I HAVE TWO
WITNESSES JOINING ME TODAY ERIN
CARUTHERS EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
WILL BE TESTIFYING IN PERSON
AND KEN BARNES PRESIDENT AND C.
E. O. OF OPTIONS FOR ALL.
TWENTY MANAGER. THANK YOU
CENTER TORONTO- L. YOUR FIRST
WITH FIRST WITNESS CAN GO AHEAD
AND BEGIN THAT PACKAGE AARON
THANK YOU FOR THE HARD WORK OF
EUROPE COMMITTEE AND HOLDS MY
PHONE IS STILL THE MAN CHRIS
WARD MY NAME IS KEN BARNES AND
I'M THE PRESIDENCY OF OPTIONS
FOR ALL WARY SAN DIEGO BASED
SERVICE PROVIDER WITH OFFICES
IN INLAND EMPIRE AND SILICON
VALLEY AND WE PROVIDE SUPPORT
SERVICES FOR OVER THIRTEEN
HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WITH
INTELLECTUAL. AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WE SUPPORT SB SIX
THIRTY NINE BECAUSE WE KNOW
IT'S POSSIBLE THE TRANSITION OR
DIVERSE PERSONS FROM SUB
MINIMUM WAGE- TO MARKET RATE
JOBS AND WHILE SOME FAMILY
MEMBERS SEE THESE JOBS VALUABLE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR TRAINING AND
SOCIAL ENGAGEMENT WHAT I
DISCOVERED AFTER BECOMING CEO
LAST YEAR THAT THESE FOURTEEN
C. CERTIFICATES OFTEN TOOLS FOR
EMPLOYERS TO LEGALLY EXPLOIT
THE LABOR OF PERSONS WITH
DISABILITIES SO I PAN FOURTEEN
C. CERTIFICATES AND THAT'S
SUPPORTABLE. FINDING
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT IS NOT EASY BUT
SINCE WE BAN FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFIED- FOURTEEN C. SUPPORT
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO PLACE OVER
ONE HUNDRED FIFTY PEOPLE IN THE
MARKET RATE JOBS AND IT'S
DURING A PANDEMIC. HOW INSTEAD
OF BACKING EMPLOYERS TO HIRE
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WE
TELL POTENTIAL EMPLOYERS ABOUT
THE BENEFITS OF HAVING A
PHENOMENAL EMPLOYEE AND THE
RESPONSE HAS BEEN EXCELLENT
OPPONENTS OF SB SIX THIRTY NINE
OFTEN CITE THE HIGH
UNEMPLOYMENT RATE OF THOSE WITH
DISABILITIES AS A REASON TO
MAINTAIN FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES HOWEVER EVEN WITH
THE ABOMINATION OF SUB MINIMUM
WAGE PAYMENTS. FALLING BELOW
TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR IN SOME
CASES UNEMPLOYMENT RATES
CONTINUE TO BE STRATOSPHERIC
THIS MEANS THE ISSUE IS
ACCEPTANCE AND INCLUSIVITY. AND
NOT ONE DRIVEN BY ECONOMICS. IN
CLOSING I THINK. MY AREAS IN
COLLEGE HUMAN RIGHTS AND THAT'S
WHY I GET A LITTLE EMOTIONAL
ABOUT THIS AND- I FELL STUDENT
OUT WHAT'S THAT'S A PROFESSOR.
HOW TO DEFINE A HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION AND HE SAYS I KNOW IT
WHEN I SEE IT. YEAH AND LAST
YEAR WHEN I LEARNED IT WAS
LEGAL IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THE PAY PEOPLE
VOTERS THREE OR FOUR DOLLARS AN
HOUR. I KNEW INSTANTLY IT WAS A
HUMAN RIGHTS VIOLATION I HOPE
YOU SEE THAT THE C. ABOUT WAYS
WELL AND ASK FOR YOUR VOTE OF
YES ON SB SIX THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR. THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR ERIN CARUTHERS
AND THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE STATE COUNCIL ON
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES WE
ARE AN INDEPENDENT STATE ENTITY
THAT IS HERE TO BE A GUIDING
FORCE FOR POSITIVE LASTING
CHANGES IN LIFE TO PEOPLE
DEVELOP DISABILITIES THEIR
FAMILIES WHICH IS WHY WE'RE ONE
OF THE CO SPONSORS OF THIS
LEGISLATION. ONE THIRD OF OUR
COUNCIL MEMBERS WERE ACTUALLY
PUT INTO SAID MINIMUM WAGE
SHELTERED WORKSHOPS. AND THEY
ALL QUIT- ONE IN PARTICULAR-
SAID THAT SHE WAS. PUT IN THERE
AND WHEN SHE FOUND IT WAS ABOUT
SHE LEFT AND SHE WENT TO A
COOKING CLASS WHICH IS REALLY
WHAT HER PASSION WAS. ANOTHER
ONE SAID THAT SHE REPORTS
ABUSES IS SHE EXPERIENCING THEM
NOT BEING ABLE TO USE THE
RESTROOM. IN THE END SHE JUST
SAID. IT'S NOT WORTH IT FOR THE
MONEY THEY'RE GIVING ME. AND
THEN A THIRD ACTUALLY STAGED A
LABOR WALK OUT TO TRY TO GET
BETTER RATES. GET BETTER WAGES.
THIS LEGISLATION WILL DO WHAT
THESEADVOCATES WE'RE NOT ABLE
TO DO ON THEIR OWN. WHICH IS TO
STOP AN UNFAIR EXPLOITATIVE
PRACTICE. THIS COMMUNITY AND
THIS COMMITTEE I'M SORRY IS THE
CHAMPION OF THE LANCER MAX AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT. AT ITS
CORE THE LANTERN ACT IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS BLUEPRINT IT'S FOR A
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. IN ALL
COMPASSION AT ONE POINT IN OUR
HISTORY SHELTERED WORKSHOPS SUB
MINIMUM WAGE THAT WAS SEEN AS
THE BEST MOST PROGRESSIVE THING
THAT YOU COULD DO FOR PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. BUT TIMES HAVE
CHANGED AND OUR VIEWS HAVE
CHANGED AND ACTUALLY OPTIONS
AVAILABLE TO PEOPLE HAVE
CHANGED MS OUR COUNCIL SO
DEEPLY GRATEFUL FOR HOW MUCH
CONCERN HAS BEEN PLACED ON WHAT
HAPPENS TO EACH INDIVIDUAL. IT
ONCE SHELTERED WORKSHOPS ARE
CLOSED. WANT TO POINT OUT THAT
FOR THE LAST FIVE YEARS THE
LEGISLATURE'S LAY THAT FRIEND
THAT THAT GROUP THAT FROM
GROUNDWORK- YOU'VE INVESTED
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR
FOR PROVIDERS TO. ADAPT
MODERNIZE TO CURRENT TIMES
ADDITIONALLY THE SENATOR JUST
POINTED OUT ADDITIONAL
INVESTMENTS THE LEGISLATURE IS
DOING. SO THAT PEOPLE WILL BE
ABLE TO MAKE THIS TRANSITION SO
THIS IS THE RIGHT POLICY AT THE
RIGHT TIME WITH THE RIGHT
SUPPORTS. TO CREATE SUCCESSFUL
PEOPLE DESERVE BETTER I'LL BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER THE QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
CROWTHER'S. AT THIS TIME DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- IN
THE HEARING ROOM. CAN REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SERVICE
EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL UNION
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT AND
THE REMOTE TESTIMONY. MMHM. NOW
OKAY DO WE HAVE OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE LINE. FOUR
COMMENT IN. OF SB SIX THREE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO.
AND SO FAR WE HAVE
APPROXIMATELY. FORTY PEOPLE
QUEUED UP TO GO PUBLIC. LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY YEAR MIKE IS
UP. HELLO MY NAME IT ANY LONGER.
OKAY COUNTY AND I SUPPORT SB.
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU FINALLY
ONE LINE. ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN. AND ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN. LINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
TWO. HELLO MY NAME IS NINA
DONKOR I AM HERE WITH SIX OTHER
INDIVIDUALS. I AM GINA AND I'M
A PERSON WITH A DISABILITY AND
I OPPOSE SB SIXTY NINE THANK
YOU. HI MY NAME IS TERRY I'M A
PERSON WITH DISABILITIES I
OPPOSE SB SIX THIRTY NINE. HI
MY NAME IS ANDREA I'M PERSON
WITH DISABILITIES I OPPOSE SB
SIX NINE. HI MY NAME IS JASON I
AM A PERSON WITH DISABILITIES
AND. A POST SB SIX THREE NINE
HI MY NAME IS VERY I'M A PERSON
WITH DISABILITIES AND I RECALLS
TO. SB.
SIX THREE NINE. YEAH
THANK YOU OPERATOR TO LIVE CALL.
ONE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY ONE. WHY
ARE HUNDRED GASTRO. HI MY NAME
IS MARGARET RECORDED THE CO.
AND I HAVE I HAVE. THE DAILY
I'VE OPPOSED. THANK YOU. THREE
NINE THANK YOU SIR OPERATOR
THIS IS FOR- PUBLIC TESTIMONY
IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE- PUBLIC
TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT OF SB. SIX
THREE NINE. AND ALIGNMENT. ONE
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS ROBERT AND I WORK AT MCI AND
IN FRONT OF ME I'M WE HAVE
ABOUT THIRTY INDIVIDUALS WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEY WILL TAKE
CARE. ALL MY NAME IS JAMES I'M
A PERSON WITH DISABILITIES AND
I OPPOSE SB. SIXTY NINE.
MAINLAND I DON'T A PERSON WITH
A DISABILITY AYE OPPOSED SB.
SIX THIRTY NINE. HI MY NAME IS
OFFERING I'M A PERSON WITH
DISABILITIES AYE OPPOSED. SB
SIX BRINGING. NINE HELLO MY
NAME IS MARTHA I WORK WITH
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES I
OPPOSE SB. SIX THREE NINE.
BAKER BERMAN AND KURTZ THANK.
VERY CLOSE. SB. SIX FIFTY NINE.
MY NAME IS MONICA COOK I AM A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY AYE
OPPOSED SB SIX THREE NINE. MY
NAME IS PAULA CAN FAIL I'M A
PERSON WITH DISABILITY AYE
OPPOSED SB. SIXTY NINE. MY LAN
WITH IDEA. X. P. SIX THREE NINE
FOUR- NURSING. MY NAME IS TERRY.
A PERSONALISED DISABILITY-
PHONE THE. YEAH- BEAT. THIRTY
NINE. YEAH. MY NAME IS KERRY
SMITH- WORK WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND I OPPOSE SB
SIX THREE NINE. BUT I'VE GOT TO
CUT THEM I AM PURSUING
DISABILITY I HAVE TWELVE SB SIX
THREE NINE. YOUR MIND BUDGET I.
BUT IF IT. EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT
SIX NINE. ALL MY VERY NICE
OPPOSE YEAH. THE BODY. FEE FREE.
THANK. THREE NINE. I AM OF THE
DISABILITY AYE OPPOSED SB THREE
SIX NINE. CHOI. I'M MORE VULGAR
MY NAME IS LAURIE I AM A PERSON
WHO WERE JUST GROW G. R. O. SB.
SIX THREE NINE. I THOUGHT. MY
NAME IS KAYLA WALKER I SUPPORT
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AYE
OPPOSED SB SIX THREE NINE. I'M
DANIEL KESSLER I SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND I OPPOSE SB. SIX THREE
NINE. HI MY NAME IS SHANNON
PARTNER I'M A PARENT OF A
PERSON WITH A DISABILITY AND I
OPPOSE SB SIXTY NINE. AND MINE
IS A BET NEGATIVE. SIX THREE
NINE. MY NAME IS COURTNEY ALL
FIRM I WORK WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND AYE OPPOSED.
SB SIX THREE NINE. MY NAME IS
VIOLET AND I WORK WITH PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES AND I WILL
CALL SB. SIX THREE NINE. OKAY
BYE BYE. THANK YOU OPERATOR IS
THERE ANYBODY ELSE ON THE IN
THE QUEUE. HIGH COURT WAIT. WE
CURRENTLY HAVE APPROXIMATELY
FORTY FORTY FIVE PEOPLE WHO
HAVE YOU WOULD UP- SPOKE TO BE
FOR SUPPORT BUT I THINK SOME OF
THEM MISTAKENLY QUEUED UP FOR
OPPOSITION OKAY- OKAY GO AHEAD
IN- OPEN THE LINE AGAIN THIS
IS- PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME
AFFILIATION. AND POSITION. LINE
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN SHE-
THANK YOU CHAIR NUMBERS MITCH
SNIDER WITH THE CALIFORNIA
LABOR FEDERATION IN SUPPORT.
WHY NOT ONE HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE.
CHANGE YOUR BURKE NEW. WE WILL
WORK STREAMLINED. SHOULD WILL
WILL SHOW PORTANTINO WITH IT WE.
WE THINK WE'RE GOING. LINE AT
ONE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. HI
KIDADA MEDINA SACRAMENTO COUNTY
I'M A PARENT OF A CHILD WITH A
DISABILITY IN SUPPORT OF SENATE
BILL SIX THIRTY NINE THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY NINE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS GREGORY KRAMER ON
BEHALF OF DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIA WE'RE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR SENATE BILL SIX THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT. HI MY
NAME IS HIGHLY I WORK WITH
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
INCLUDING MY FAMILY MEMBER AND
I OPPOSE SB. SIX THIRTY NINE.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY THREE.
HI MY NAME IS DAN WHAT THE
SENATE WORK WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND I OPPOSE SB.
SIX THIRTY NINE. TWO HUNDRED
FOUR. AND TWO HUNDRED FOUR YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. AND. ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. AND. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX. AND ONE HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
OF MY COULD OPEN. I APOLOGIZE
MADAM CHAIR ONE MOMENT PLEASE
THANK YOU. I AND ONE HUNDRED
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN. I GET
AFTERNOON REBEKAH GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FIFTY SIX. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME
UNDER. I'M SORRY GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS CHRISTINA PEREZ AND
I SUPPORT PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND AYE OPPOSED SB.
SIX THREE NINE. LINE TWO
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS TREAT
ANDERSON WITH THE R.
CALIFORNIA- WE APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S BONTA WORKING WITH
THAT AND HAVE MOVED- FROM
SUPPORT THEM AND TO SUPPORT.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED THREE. HI NOT
A COOK THE PROBLEM IS WITH THAT
BEEN A GREAT COMMUNICATOR
LAVERDA AMOUNTS OF FATHER OF
THE YOUNG MAN THE WORKFORCE IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX THIRTY
NINE. LINE A ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS ERIN
EVENT ON BEHALF OF THE SOUL BUT
ADMINISTRATORS OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT. LINE ONE
HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT. IS THAT
MY NUMBER I DON'T REMEMBER. YES
WE CAN AREA. OKAY MY NAME IS
JEANETTE ERICKSON I SUPPORT THE
BILL SB ONE SIX NINE- I USED TO
WORK AT A WORKSHOP DAY PROGRAM
AND I. LIKE IT AND I'M GLAD
THAT YOU GUYS ARE ONLY- IT'S SO
IMPORTANT THAT WE- GET
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE- OF
COURSE THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
LINE OF. ONE HUNDRED FIFTY
THREE. HI MY NAME IS FIVE
DESIGN YOU KNOW I AM A PROVIDER
THAT PROVIDES A COMPETITIVE
INTEGRATED EMPLOYMENT FOR
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT FOR S. B.
THANK YOU. ONE SIXTY FOUR. ON
THE OTHER SIDE NEVADA YEAH.
LINE SIXTY FOUR FOR THE STATE
OF. BLIND. TWO HUNDRED SIXTEEN.
OKAY WE CAN AREA OKAY SORRY
ABOUT THAT HELLO MY NAME IS
RACHEL AND LEGAL AID AT WORK WE
ARE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF SB SIX
THIRTY NINE WE THIS IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS AND HUMAN RIGHTS ISSUE-
AND- HONORED TO BE A PART OF
THIS BILL. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
WHY LINE. TWO HUNDRED NINE. HI
MY NAME IS MONEY IN NINE
SUPPORT SB SIX THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. BLIND. NINETY HELLO
MY NAME IS CAROL SHELTON I AM
THE PARENT UNCOVERED IN ADULT
WHAT THE INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES. I
SUPPORT SB SIX THIRTY NINE I'M
ASKING FOR YOU KNOW I THOUGHT
I'LL BE OPTIMIZED OTHER QUITE
THANK YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY NINE. HELLO MY NAME IS
DONNA HENSHAW AND THE PARENT OF
A CHILD WITH DISABILITIES AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX THIRTY
NINE THANK YOU. LINE ONE
HUNDRED THIRTY FOUR. HI THIS IS
JENNIFER ST FROM SAN DIEGO AND
I'M THE PARENT OF A CHILD WITH
DISABILITIES. REALLY STRONG
SUPPORT I THINK SIX THREE NOT.
THANK YOU. A LINE OF ONE
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS SAVANNAH
GROUPS I'M A MOM OF WITHOUT A
WITH YOU CAN DELINEATE AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB SIX THIRTY
NINE- I'M ALSO FROM THE
ORGANIZATION- I THINK THE THANK
YOU. LINE. TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR. LINE TWO HUNDRED TWENTY
FOUR YOU'RE MY COULD OPEN. LINE
ONE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN. HELLO MY
NAY I'M WITH ANOTHER PERSON SO
THEY'RE GOING TO SPEAK MY NAME
IS STILL UP I AM IN SOME-
WOODLAND HILLS CALIFORNIA AND A
MAN THAT GOD CHAIR OR CO CHAIR
OF THE SELF DETERMINATION
PROGRAM AND I STRONGLY STRONGLY
SUPPORT COMPETITIVE WAGES. AND
WITH THAT I SUPPORT SB SIX
THREE NINE. GO AHEAD AND HELLO
MY NAME IS KEN CURRIE I'M A
CASE WORKER WITH AT THE ISRAEL
CENTER IN LOS ANGELES. WORKING
WITH DISABLED INDIVIDUALS AND I
ALSO AM VERY VERY STRONG
SUPPORT OF SB SIX THIRTY NINE.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX. LINE ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY SIX YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. I. ONE HUNDRED SIXTY. AND
ONE HUNDRED SIXTY. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON HAPPY WEDNESDAY MY
NAME IS MAN YEAH AND I SUPPORT.
S. B. X. THIRTY NINE THANK YOU
HAVE A GOOD DAY. FIND. ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR. I'D ONE
HUNDRED NINETY FOUR. HELLO
HELLO WE CAN AREA. HI I'M GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS ELIZABETH
GOMEZ I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE
INTEGRATED COMMUNITY
COLLABORATIVE OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS THE ICC AND THE COMMUNITY
I'M ALSO THE MOTHER OF A PERSON
WITH A DISABILITY AND I AM IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX THIRTY
NINE. AND I CAN. BECAUSE TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS FOR THE
LATINO COMMUNITY AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU BLIND TWO
HUNDRED BY. TWO HUNDRED
FOURTEEN. HI THE THROUGH BALL
THOUGH WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
THOSE WITH OF AMERICA COACHELLA
VALLEY AND I AM STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AT B. SIX THIRTY
NINE. WELL I NINETY SIX.
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS KATHERINE
SANDERS AND ON BEHALF OF THEIR
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER AT THE
SPEAKING OF PEOPLE SUPPORTING
EMPLOYMENT FIRST WE ARE IN
STRONG STRONG SUPPORT AND THAT
THE SIX THREE NINE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN. AND ONE HUNDRED
THIRTY SEVEN. LINE. ONE HUNDRED
FORTY THREE. MY NAME ZERO AND.
DISABILITY THANK YOU THANK YOU.
LINE. ONE HUNDRED THIRTY THREE.
HELLO MY NAME IS THAT JOSEPH
MCCARTY AND EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR INTEGRATED RESOURCES
INSTITUTE BASED IN. ORANGE
COUNTY LOS ANGELES I'VE BEEN A
DIRECT SERVICE- PROVIDER FOR
FIVE DECADES AND I'M ALSO A
PARENT. UP FROM THE CIVIL
RIGHTS PERSPECTIVE WHEN YOU
LOOK AT SUB MINIMUM WAGE AND
THAT. SENATE DEMS ASSOCIATED
WITH THAT BOB IS UNDER BUT NEED
BELOW LOWER AND THEN MINIMALIST
LEAST SMALL LAST TIME YES SO.
WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT SB SIX
THIRTY NINE- TO ABOLISH THE
MINIMUM WAGE THANK YOU SIR
THANK YOU. WHY NO. ONE HUNDRED
NINETY ONE. HI MY NAME IS ROBIN
STAMMER AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT
SB SIX THIRTY NINE THANKS THANK
YOU. LINE ONE HUNDRED FORTY
SEVEN. HI MY NAME IS KHALID
RASHID I'M A COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING ADVOCATE OUT OF A
DISABILITY RESOURCES AGENCY FOR
INDEPENDENT LIVING AND WE- HELP
CONSUMERS IN SIX DIFFERENT
COUNTIES AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB SIX THREE NINE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU BYE TWO
HUNDRED SEVEN. YES HI. HELLO.
YES WE CAN HEAR YOU PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HI THIS IS MAUREEN
MCFADDEN I'M INCREDIBLE THE
CALIFORNIA AND I EMPHATICALLY
SUPPORT THE STATE BILL SIX
THREE NINE IT IS A HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATION TO PAY ANYONE LESS
THAN THE MINIMUM WAGE. THANK
YOU FOR YOUR TIME THANK YOU.
WHY. EIGHTY TWO. I AM. EIGHTY
TWO. HI MY NAME IS CHRISTIAN
RODRIGUEZ I WORK AT COMMERCIAL
SUPPORT SERVICES I AM A DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDER I SUPPORT
INDIVIDUALS WITH DISABILITIES
AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE SB SIX
THREE NINE. WE HAVE MANY MORE
THAT WOULD LIKE TO SPEAK AS
WELL. SO HI MY NAME IS GEORGE
AND I WORK FOR COMMERCIAL
SUPPORT SERVICES IN ANTIOCH AND
I'D STRONGLY OPPOSE. SIX THREE
NINE. HI MY NAME IS JENNIFER
RUSSELL I WORK WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES I OPPOSE S. B.
THIRTY NINE. I ALSO HAVE A
LETTER FROM A PARENT. WORKS
THAT YES ANY UP. AND STRONGLY
OPPOSES SB SIX THREE NINE THANK.
WE HAVE MORE. WELL. AND LIGHT.
ONE HUNDRED EIGHT. YES MY NAME
IS GLYCOLYTIC I'M A DIRECT
SUPPORT SERVICE WORKER AND I DO
BELIEVE THAT THIS IS A CIVIL
RIGHTS ISSUE WHICH IS WHY I AM
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB SIX
THREE NINE. TO THINK ABOUT SUB
MINIMUM LOOKS TO. LINE AT
SIXTY. HI MY NAME IS KIMBERLY
SELENE MY SON'S NAME IS JACOB
DURAN AND WE OPPOSE THIS BILL
IT'S INSANE THANK YOU MA'AM
THANK YOU FOR CALLING IN. LINE.
ONE HUNDRED THIRTY NINE. DANIEL
TO THE NOTIFICATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES DIRECTLY IN
BETWEEN- SPOT IT'S OF LITTLE
COMMENT ON THE ALLEGED PLOT.
OUR MALIGNANT IT SHOULD BE
COMMITTED TO CREATING A DIGITAL
PASSED THE PROFESSOR A PLAN TO.
BUDGET FROM PUBLIC COMPETITIVE
IN EMPLOYMENT SARDONICALLY
HEALTH ELITE IMPORTANT THE
THIRD ONE THAT. ARE YOU A
POSTER DO SUPPORT SIR. I AM
SORRY WE HAVE LOST THAT COLOR
LINE TWO HUNDRED SEVENTY. HI MY
NAME IS CLEAR I CAN HEAR ME YES
HELLO. YEAH HI MY NAME IS LEON
HARTMAN PATTERSON I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF MY BROTHER WHO IS
DEVELOPMENTALLY DISABLED AND WE
ARE STRONGLY OPPOSED TO SB SIX
THIRTY NINE THANK YOU. WHY TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY FOUR. HI MY NAME
IS KARINA LIMóN I WORK FOR
COMMERCIAL SUPPORT SERVICES IN
CONCORD I AM A PARENT A SISTER
AND DIRECT STAFF FOR PEOPLE
WITH DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
AND AYE OPPOSED SB SIX THREE
NINE THANK YOU. LINE. ONE
HUNDRED FIVE. FIND. ONE HUNDRED
FIVE. LINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SEVEN. HE CAN DOWN STONE
ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF OPTIONS
FOR ALL IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
WHAT LINE TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
MILES BORDER WITH OPTIONS FOR
ALL STRONG SUPPORT OF SB SIX
THIRTY NINE FIFTY. THANK YOU.
LINE. TWO HUNDRED NINETY TWO.
HELLO MY NAME IS NOT AS AN
ADULT- CARING ABOUT THE BOOK
WITHOUT THE CAMP AND I STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT SB SIX THIRTY NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN. HELLO
EVERYBODY HEAR ME YES WE CAN
HEAR YOU IR YEAH OKAY I HEAR
SOME BACKGROUND NOISE ON THE
OTHER END ANYWAY MY NAME IS
RICK HODGE KINS OUT WITH
CAPITAL PEOPLE FIRST I'M ALSO A
DISABILITY RIGHTS LEFT WING
EXTREMIST I SUPPORT THIS BILL
WE MAY BE SMALL BUT WE'RE NOT
STUPID THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. LINE TWO HUNDRED
NINETY FIVE. HI MY NAME IS DR
LARRY AND TIME TO PASS THIS IS
THIRTY NINE. THANK YOU THANK
YOU SIR. WHY TWO HUNDRED EIGHTY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
ROCKETING AND I'M A DIRECTOR OF
THE NONPROFIT ANYTHING GROWING
UP TO WORK WITH I DO SEE THAT
MY MOTHER WOULD HAVE WANTED
THEM I ELIEVE THAT THE DOLLARS
WHICH GREAT CALL ANDERSON ALL
RIGHT BY ANY CHANCE I PROMISE
FRONT SUPPORT. THE BIG NINETY
TWO AND. THAT MINIMUM WAGE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. ONE ONE.
FORTY SIX. ONE ONE HUNDRED
FORTY SIX. HELLO YES I CAN HEAR
YOU. HELLO WE CAN HEAR YOU. HI
FINE YOU WANT TO GET A LOT OF
FUN MY SON I AM A MOTHER OF A
YOUNG MAN HE PRACTICED SIX AND
I SUPPORT SB SIX THIRTY NINE HE
DESERVES TO MAKE EQUAL WAGES
EVERYBODY HELPED THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU. WELL I AM.
THREE HUNDRED THIRTEEN. WHY.
THREE HUNDRED THIRTEEN. WELL.
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. FIFTY ONE
MOMENT FOR NEXT COMMENT PLEASE.
WHAT IT LOOKS LIKE THERE ARE NO
MORE COMMENTS AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU ARE AT BOTH CAN GO
RIGHT AS THE CAPTAIN OF THE WTA
I DON'T PERSONALLY HAVE AN
ISSUE IS IT'S SOMETHING THAT IF
WE CHOOSE TO ASK ONE OF OUR
TEAM MEMBERS FOR EXAMPLE DON'T
MISS ALIBIED WERE BOTH
EXECUTIVE DIRECTORS WE'D ASK
SOMEONE ELSE ON OUR TEAM TO
PARTICIPATE GOING FORWARD
EITHER SOMETIMES WITH THAT OR
INSTEAD OF FIVE WOULD THEY ALSO
BE ABLE TO VIEW THIS FIGURE OF
A CONVERSATION. OR WOULD THAT
BE FOR YOUR INTERNAL. SO MA'AM
THIS IS STEP- THE OPPOSITION
PUBLIC PORTION FOR SB. SIX
THREE NINE. SIX OPERATOR I
THINK THAT MAYBE THAT THAT WAS.
HELLO THAT WAS PLACE IN THE
QUEUE MAN ACCIDENTALLY. THANK
YOU IT IT WAS. IT WAS A WITNESS
FOR A DIFFERENT BILL I OKAY ALL
RIGHT THANK YOU OKAY SO I THINK
THAT WE HAVE- HEARD ALL THE
PUBLIC TESTIMONY IN SUPPORT AND
OPPOSITION- AND WE JUST NEED TO
HEAR FROM THE PRIMARY-
OPPOSITION WITNESSES SO- AT
THIS TIME. THE SORRY THAT
ALLERGIES OFFICER WENT AHEAD
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF MY NAME IS CARL
LONDON I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE LIONS SUPPORTING PEOPLE
WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES WE ARE
STATEWIDE ORGANIZATION OF
COMMUNITY BASED NONPROFITS THAT
SERVE THIS POPULATION
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA AND
PROVIDE A RANGE OF SERVICES I
DO WANT TO CLEAR UP A COUPLE
THINGS ABOUT THIS LEGISLATION.
FIRST OF ALL THIS IS A THIS WAS
SAID A COUPLE TIMES IT APPLIES
ONLY TO SHELTERED WORKSHOPS
WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAMS IT IS
NOT THERE ARE PEOPLE THROUGHOUT
COMMUNITY INTEGRATED PROGRAMS
TODAY THEY CHOOSE TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF SUB MINIMUM WAGE
PROGRAMS ARE FOURTEEN C.
CERTIFICATES AND GAIN WORK
EXPERIENCE IN THE COMMUNITY- MY
SON IS- ONE OF THOSE MEMBERS
ALL TALK A BIT MORE ABOUT THAT-
THE OTHER THING IS THAT. IF YOU
LOOK AT THIS BILL THIS BILL
DOES NOT GET PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES WHO CURRENTLY MAKE
SUB MINIMUM WAGE MINIMUM WAGE
TO SIMPLY SAYS. NOBODY CAN BE
PAID LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE
ANYMORE. AND GETS RID OF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO USE A FEDERAL
LAW WHICH IS LEGAL IN EXIST
TODAY AND ALLOW SOME AND WE
SHOULD BE TO BE USED. THE ONLY
WAY A PERSON GETS TO A SUB
MINIMUM WAGE POSITION IN
CALIFORNIA JUST TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT THIS. IS IF THEY PROGRAM
REGISTERS FOLLOWS ALL OF THE
FEDERAL GUIDELINES AND A TEEN'S
A. FOURTEEN C. CERTIFICATE.
SECOND THE PERSON WHO- LIKE MY
SON WHO CHOOSES TO DO THIS HAS
TO ELECT THAT CHOICE THROUGH
THE INDIVIDUALIZED PROGRAM PLAN
PROCESS. THAT IS DONE BY THE
REGIONAL CENTER IN THE
CATCHMENT AREA IN WHICH THEY
LIVE IN OTHER WORDS THEY HAVE
TO DESIGNATE AND SAY THIS IS
WHAT I CHOOSE TO DO. THE LAST
THING I'D SAY HER AND I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT MY SON'S PERSONAL
EXPERIENCE. WHAT MISTER BARNES
SAYS I GET EMOTIONAL ABOUT THE
SOMETIMES BUT HE'S A GUY WHO'S
FUNCTIONALLY BLIND HAS BRAIN
DAMAGE FROM BIRTH AND CANNOT
FUNCTION AT LEAST THUS FAR AT A
RATE THAT WOULD ALLOW HIM TO
COMPETE IN THE REGULAR
WORKFORCE JUSTICE WAS IMAGINED
IN THE FEDERAL LEGISLATION. NOW
HE GOT A JOB A WHILE AGO AT
BEST BUY. HE WAS RESTOCKING
SHELVES HE WAS TAKING
EVERYTHING THAT'S RETURNED TO
THE STORE AND TAKING A BATH AND
PUTTING IT ON THE FLOOR TO BE
REPURCHASED. IT'S NOT AN
EXCITING JOB IT'S NOT WHAT I
WOULD CHOOSE TO DO AND BECAUSE
OF HIS PRODUCTIVITY RATE WHICH
UNDER THE FEDERAL LAW IS
REQUIRED TO BE REMEASURED EVERY
SIX MONTHS. HE WAS RATED ABOUT
25% PRODUCTIVITY. WORKING WITH
A JOB COACH HE WAS DOING HIS
JOB HE LOVED IT. HE WAS TALKING
TO STAFF THE BEST BUY. HE WAS
TALKING TO PEOPLE IN THE PUBLIC
EVERY DAY. AND I LOOKED AT HIM
I THOUGHT HE WAS CRAZY THIS
WOULD NOT BE A CHOICE THAT I
WOULD MAKE BUT THE FUNDAMENTAL
PRINCIPLE. OF THE STATE'S
LANHAM ACT WHICH IS OUR-
ESTEEMED GUIDANCE ON THIS AND
LAW THAT NO OTHER STATE REALLY
HAS. ALLOWS THE PERSON WITH THE
DISABILITY. TO MAKE THE CHOICE
OF WHAT SUITS THEM. THIS BILL.
PROPOSES TO GET RIGHT IN THE
WAY OF THAT AND CONFLICT WITH
THAT. AND LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT
WHAT THIS BILL SAYS. IT DOES
NOT GET THESE PEOPLE MINIMUM
WAGE WHAT IT SAYS IS. LET'S
HAVE A PLAN. CONDUCTED BY THE
DEPARTMENT. TO MAYBE SEE HOW WE
MIGHT GIVE IT TO US. WE HAVE NO
OBJECTION TO HAVING THAT
DISCUSSION WHAT WE OBJECT TO IS
PUTTING A TERMINATION DATE. IN
PLACE AT THE SAME TIME WITHOUT
HAVING THAT PLAN I THINK THAT
HAVING A FUNDING COMMITMENT.
THAT WILL IMPACT TWELVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE AND PUT THEM
OUT OF THEIR JOBS OF THEIR
CHOICE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU MISTER LONDON. K. WE
HAVE I WANT ONE MORE WITNESS IN
OPPOSITION WE HAVE- CRYSTAL
HERMAN. AND HER MOM MARCHERS.
THIS CALL THEN. CHAIRMAN THANK
YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO SPEAK MY
NAME IS MARGARET SHARES. AND
THAT'S WHAT MY DAUGHTER
HARRIMAN THAT COULD STILL
HAPPEN. YOU TELL ME HOW YOU
LIKE THE ROMAN CENTER AND WHAT
IT MEANS TO YOU. HELLO VERY
LUCKY HE- IT AND FRANCE AND
THEIR FAMILIES. TODAY  WOULD
LIKE TO TALK TO YOU ABOUT THE
SENATE BILL NUMBER ONE IT'S SIX
THIRTY NINE THE FAIR STANDARDS
ACT FROM ROOSEVELT START TO
SIGN THIS ACT INTO LAW IN
NINETEEN THIRTY NINE HIS INTENT
WAS FOR THIS LANDMARK LAW TO BE
DESIGNED TO PROTECT THE RIGHTS.
OF DISABLED WORKERS. VI<c.cyan></c>
ELIMINATING THE SPECIAL- WAY
CERTIFICATE THIS THE FOURTEENTH
SEE- WELL ELECTED WHICH ALLOWS
THEM I USED TO RECEIVE LESS
THIS VERY SPECIAL LABOR CODE
THAT BENEFITS DAUGHTER OF MY
DAUGHTER. AND OTHERS LIKE HER
ABOUT TWELVE THOUSAND
APPROXIMATELY IN CALIFORNIA
ALONE THIS ALLOWS HER TO WORK
AT HER OWN PACE WITHOUT THINGS
IT AND STRESS OTHER JOBS
PROVIDE. SHE HAS TRIED ALL THE
OTHER JOBS SHE'S BEEN IN OTHER
PROGRAMS. I WOULD LIKE TO SHARE
THAT THESE PROGRAMS ARE HIGHLY
REGULATED BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT. OF INDUSTRIAL
RELATIONS AND THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR. THE SENATE IS REQUIRED
TO DO FREQUENT THE STUDIES AND
REPORT THE STUDIES THAT BE.
STARTED ON THE KIDS IN THERE. I
SHOULD SAY PROTESTS OFFENSE AND
THEIR WORK. INTEGRATED EMPLOYEE
IS IDEAL FOR THOSE WHO COULD DO
IT. BUT WHAT ABOUT THE ONES WHO
CANNOT. WHAT ABOUT THE WITH THE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF THE
PROGRAM- SO MANY LEVELS TO
CRYSTALS PROGRAM. SHE CAN MAKE
HER OWN CHOICES AND CHOOSE TO
MOVE UP AND MOVE OUT IF SHE SHE
OR SHE IF SHE CHOOSES TO I'M
SORRY I'M A LITTLE NERVOUS.
OKAY THERE'S ONE OF MINE A
SUPPORT THERE'S COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS. THEIR SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT WITH COVERAGES AND
THERE'S EVEN PLATE PAID
INTERNSHIP ALL WITHIN HER
CENTER. FINALLY WHAT MAKES
THESE CENTERS ESSENTIAL IS THE
SUPPORT THE PROVIDE THE WORKERS.
IDINA MEDICAL ISSUES SUCH AS
SEIZURES WHICH HAPPENED DALY.
M. BEHAVIORS MELTDOWNS WHICH
ALSO COULD HAVE BEEN DALY THOSE
CAN'T BE AND NO NORMAL WORKSITE
WORKPLACE. WHAT ABOUT
PROTECTION AGAINST
INAPPROPRIATE SEXUAL ADVANCES
YOU ARE HEARD HOW MY DAUGHTER
SPOKE TO YOU HOW IS SHE
SUPPOSED TO GET HER POINT
ACROSS THAT SHE'S BEING
INFLUENCE ONE WAY OR ANOTHER AT
THE WORK SITE WHEN THERE'S NO
ONE THERE TO GUIDE HER. AND
HIGH SCHOOL CRYSTAL WAS AND
WILL FOLLOW IN A WORKABILITY
PROGRAM. SHE WAS TRAINED AND
SHE WAS ALSO CERTIFICATE AND
WORKING PROPER PROCEDURES AT
MILLENNIUM EMPLOYER SUCH AS PAT
MARC. DOLLAR TREE RASS. AMBER
FREY TYPER RESTAURANTS. EVERY
EMPLOYER EVERY EMPLOYER THAT
SHE HAD I TOLD HER THEY COULD
NOT HIRE HER BECAUSE OF HER
LIMITED SPEECH THEY WOULD TAKE
HER ON WITH A ONE ON ONE BUT
THEN WHERE IS THE LOVE LEAST
RESTRICTION MEANS MY DAUGHTER
WOULD HAVE TO GO TO WORK WITH
SOMEONE. TO SPEAK WITH HER
EVERY DAY THAT'S NOT LEAST
RESTRICTIVE. K. AS THEY TOLD
YOU THEY CAN HIRE BECAUSE OF
HER SPEECH AND THEY WANTED AN
INTERPRETER FOR. SECONDLY
CENTER PRODUCTIVE. PRODUCTIVE
READY- IS SLOWER THAN MOST. SHE
WAS ALWAYS BEING PRESSURED
WHICH WAS CAUSING A GREAT DEAL
OF ANXIETY AND STRESS. AT THE
TIME SHE DIDN'T WANT TO GO TO
WORK. SHE WOULD CALL AND TELL
ME THAT SHE WOULD WANT TO STAY
HOME. SIX YEARS AGO WE FOUND
THE ROMAN CENTER. SHE'S BEEN
THERE EVERY SENSE MISSING ONLY
DAYS WHEN SHE'S FORCED TO FOR
DOCTORS OR WHAT HAVE YOU. THIS
CENTER MIGHT BE KNOWN AS A
SHELTERED CENTER. AND IT IS
PLAIN LESS THAN MINIMUM WAGE TO
CRYSTAL AND MANY LIKE HER IT IS
SO MUCH MORE. IT IS THEIR LIFE
LIKE I SAID NOW SHE NEVER
MISSES A DAY WORK SHE NEVER
COMES HOME CRYING OR ANXIOUS OR
DEPRESSED. SHE GETS HER FANS
READY AT NIGHT MAKES OUR LIVES
EASIER FOR THE NEXT DAY SHE
COMES HOME WITH A SMILE OR
SMILE LARGER THAN THE GRAND
CANYON WHEN SHE HAD FACT
CHECKED. CRYSTAL DOES NOT
UNDERSTAND THE VALUE OF MONEY.
BUT SHE DOES UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT TECHNIQUE. THANK YOU SO
MUCH INTO THE COMMUNITY. AND WE
SPEND THAT CHECKED AND SHE'S
CERTAINLY KNOWS HOW TO SPEND
HER MONEY THAT SHE HAS EARNED.
AS A PARENT I CANNOT EXPRESS.
HOW MUCH IS THIS WARMS MY HEART.
WHEN KRISTA WAS BORN THE
DOCTORS TOLD ME SHE MUST BE
INSTITUTIONALIZED THAT IS THE
BEST PLACE FOR HER. THAT IS NOT
THE BEST PLACE FOR SHE'S
WORKING IN OUR COMMUNITY IT
MIGHT BE A SHELTERED COMMUNITY.
I MIGHT BE PAYING A LITTLE BIT
LESS. BUT IT'S HER COMMUNITY
AND HAS HER JOB THAT SHE WAKES
UP FOR EVERY MORNING. TODAY I
ASK YOU TO CONSIDER THE CIVIL
RIGHTS NOT ONLY OF MY DAUGHTER
BUT THE OTHER TWELVE THOUSAND
OTHER PARTICIPANTS OR IN
WORKSHOPS LIKE HER. TO ALLOW
THEM TO CONTINUE TO WORK AND
THRIVE IN A PALE PLACE THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS AND ALLOWS THEM
TO BE A PERFECT ACTIVE MEMBER
OF OUR SOCIETY. IF YOU TAKE
THIS AWAY I ASSURE YOU THE
IMPACT WOULD BE VERY MUCH LIKE
THE CLOVER IN QUARANTINE.
DEPRESSION SETTIN QUICK. SHE
DIDN'T WANT TO LEAVE HER ROOM
SHE WAS SAD ALL THE TIME AND
SHE PUT ON A LOT OF WEIGHT
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING TO
TESTIFY CRYSTAL AND VISITORS WE
REALLY APPRECIATE YOUR
TESTIMONY. OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE MEMBERS-
MISTER WORK. THANK YOU AND I
ARE ONE THINGS ARE DRUGS- FOR
AUTHORING THIS BILL I REALLY
ALARMING THAT THIS HAS BEEN
GOING ON REALLY RIGHT UNDER US-
I KNOW WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
TO SPEND THEN THE OUT LABOR
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE ON BUT I
EIGHT I DO- AT AT THE IN THE
SEAT IN THE SEAT OF MY HEART
REALLY BELIEVE THIS IS A MORAL
OBLIGATION THAT WE CORRECTLY
TALK ABOUT WORKING WITH THE
VALUE OF WORK IS AND REGARDLESS
OF SOMEBODY HAS A- INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY A CHALLENGE OR NOT-
PEOPLE DESERVE TO BE. PAID UP
TO HER WELFARE WAGE- AND FOR
THOSE IT JUST REALLY SUCKS
WRONGLY WITH ME THAT YOU KNOW
WE HEAR THE VOICES THAT- PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO FEAR THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE THEIR JOB. B. WE
ARE TRYING TO GET THEM UP TO A
STANDARD THAT WE WANT TO SEE
FOR ALL CALIFORNIANS. AND WE
PICKED THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO
ARE ALREADY PROBABLY STRESS
WITH A LOT OF THINGS IN THEIR
LIVES. WITH THE- NOTION OR THE
FEAR. THAT SOMETHING LIKE THIS
WHICH IS MEANT TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THEM. ADDITIONAL INCOME
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE THAT OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY. THAT SOMEHOW THEY'RE
GOING TO LOSE SOMETHING FROM
THAT- THAT THAT ARGUMENT IS
THAT WEALTHY ON ON SEVERAL
LEVELS. AND I HOPE THIS IS THE
KIND OF WORK ALSO THAT
CATALYZES SOME INTEREST AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL. TO BE ABLE TO
READ IS THIS AS WELL AS THE
OTHER STATES ARE STARTING TO.
GO IN THIS DIRECTION I THINK
THAT'S IMPORTANT- AND- YOU KNOW
I KNOW THAT YOU ARE SETTING THE
CLOCK TODAY- OR THAT HIS PASSES
AND BECOMES LAW. NOT THAT WE
NEED TO GET THIS RIGHT WITHIN
THREE YEARS I KNOW THAT'S%
AGGRESSIVE BUT ATTAINABLE AND
SO WE SHOULD BE HEADING DOWN
THIS PATH WE SHOULD MAKE SURE
BECAUSE THE WORK HAS TO GET
DONE WHETHER. YOU'RE STOCKING
SHELVES- SOMEBODY'S GOING TO
HAVE TO BE ABLE TO DO THAT WORK
AND THEY OUGHT TO BE ABLE TO BE
PAID. A FAIR WAGE AT LEAST A
MINIMUM WAGE- AND SO OVER THE
COURSE OF THE NEXT THREE YEARS
I IMAGINE WE WILL BE.
CONTINUING TO MONITOR THIS VERY
CLOSELY TO MAKE SURE THE
PROTECTIONS ARE THERE. SO THAT
INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FEARFUL
THAT THEIR EMPLOYER MIGHT BE
USING THIS OPPORTUNITY AGAINST
THEM. THAT THAT WE ARE THERE TO
STAND UP FOR THEM TO. THAT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LOSE THEIR
JOB WE WILL WELL I THINK WE
NEED TO STAY CLOSE ON THIS
ISSUE AND CONTINUE TO MONITOR
IT SO THAT THERE ARE NO.
ADVERSE IMPACT THAT THAT WE'RE
MEETING THAT- IMPORTANT GOALS
THAT WE SEEK FOR ALL
CALIFORNIANS SO THANK YOU FOR.
DOING THIS BILL I'M HAPPY TO
MAKE A MOTION TO SUPPORT THE
BILL- AND WILL BE GOING FOR
TODAY. I SOMEONE. THANK YOU TO
AND- ON THE SENATE TO SO ON
THIS THAT YOU INTENT OF THE P.
FOR THE L. P. OVER THE DISEASE
SO TO GET THAT PAID EQUAL
AMOUNT THAT THAT IS THE MINIMUM
AMOUNT. EVEN THOUGH YOUR INTENT
IS UNDERSTANDABLE BUT I'M
AFRAID THE ESTá NOT ON THE-
JEOPARDIZING IT MAY BE- YOU YOU
WE CAN COME UP WITH A CERTAIN
MANAGER SO FOR THOSE WHO ARE
ALREADY UP AND PER LEAD TO A
DEAL CURRENT JOB MAY BE
PROTECTED DAHLE BUT WHAT ABOUT
THE- FUTURE- IN OPPORTUNITIES
OF FOR THOSE SO WHO- WITH THE-
DISABILITIES- BECAUSE-
EMPLOYERS SO- WHEN THE HIGHER
THE HIGH YEAR- WITH KIA KIND
THE MIND TO HELP THEM AND OFFER
THEM TO STAND ON THEIR FEET AND
THOSE SOCIAL REASONS SO. I EVEN
THOUGHT OF COULD BE SELF
STANDARD PAY- I HAVE BEEN
EXPERIENCE- A MYSELF FOR AT THE
STATE OF IRVINE WE HIRED THE
QUITE A FEW PEOPLE WITH A
DISABILITY ASM BUT THE I
NOTICES. THAT THE WE HAVE TO
PROVIDE A FOURTH TIME- STAFF-
TO SUPERVISE THEM EVERY MOVE-
EVERY DIRECTION THEY GO- SO IT
DOES COST EXTRA MONEY- TO
SUPERVISE THEM BECAUSE THAT
DEPENDING UPON THE SEVERITY OF
WHAT THEY ARE DISABILITY SOME
MAY NEED OR DEDUCTIBLES WE SENT
SOME MAY NOT THOUGH- SO
ETCETERA. SO FOR THE FUTURE- A
POTENTIAL EMPLOYER SO- WHO
WOULD HAVE THOUGHT ABOUT THE
HOUSE GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY SO
FOR THOSE KIND OF PEOPLE WITH A
DISABILITY IS BUT- THE- IF WE
STOP DEMANDING. ARE YOU GOING
TO PAY OKAY THEN KNOW WHAT
INCENTIVE WHAT WHAT WHAT WHAT
MY SHOULD DIE. ACOSTA WHEN I
CAN HIRE SOMEBODY WITH THE
NORTH DISABILITIES HONDA- CAN
PRODUCE SO- EXPECTED INSTEAD OF
STANDARD THE WALK POLITY SO-
EVEN SO INTENT IS ARE HELPING
THEM. OUT WITH A MORE PAID BUT
THE FOR THE LONG RUN THIS MAY
BE DUE SERVICES TO THEM BECAUSE
OF SUCH A JOB OPPORTUNITY MAY
BE DIMINISHED. WHEN I THINK
ABOUT THAT. WELL I'M- TIMES
THAT ONLY WAY SOMEBODY COULD
GET AT LEAST. THE MINIMUM WAGE
THE OR CAN'T GET MINIMUM WAGE
IS BECAUSE BECAUSE OF THEIR-
DISABILITY I'M SADDENED BY THAT
I THINK THAT WE AS A SOCIETY
NEED TO CHANGE OUR ATTITUDES
TOWARDS THOSE WHO ARE DIFFERENT
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT POTENTIAL
THEY HAVE DIFFERENT SKILLS THEY
ARE A DIFFERENT HUMAN BEING
JUST LIKE YOU AND ME WE DON'T
HAVE THE SAME WE DON'T HAVE THE
SAME SKILLS WE DON'T HAVE THE
SAME LIFE EXPERIENCES BUT WE
EXPECT TO BE TREATED IN SOME
FUNDAMENTAL WAYS THE SAME. AND
SO WHAT I'M TRYING TODO HERE
IS SAY THAT ALL THESE
INDIVIDUALS WE NEED TO GIVE
THEM THE OPPORTUNITY AND BREAK
DOWN THESE ATTITUDINAL BARRIERS
THAT WE FACE THAT THEY FACE I'M
SADDENED TO HEAR OF THE YOUNG
WOMAN AND ALL THE PRESSURE AND
THE STRESS AND THE ATTITUDES
AGAINST HER IN HER WORKPLACE
BUT THE WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT
IS NOT BY PAYING THEM LESS. THE
WAY TO DEAL WITH THAT IS BY
MAKING SURE THAT THE RESPECT
FOR CIVIL RIGHTS ARE WE ARE
THAT OUR CIVIL RIGHTS ARE
RESPECTED THAT'S THE WAY TO
DEAL WITH THAT SO I DON'T THINK
THAT WE SHOULD MEASURE A PERSON
AND SAY WELL THEY'RE DISTANT
DISABLE SO THEREFORE THEY DON'T
DESERVE EVEN THE MINIMUM WAGE
THAT'S NOT CORRECT THAT'S NOT
RIGHT AND I THINK WE AS A CUT
OF THE STATE STAND FOR. LIFTING
EVERYONE UP AND WE HAVE WE ARE
PUTTING THE RESOURCES ON THE
PRACTICAL SIDE WE ARE PUTTING
TENS OF MILLIONS OF THE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
INTO THE RESOURCES BOTH FOR
EMPLOYERS AND FOR ALL THE
SERVICES THAT ARE SISTERS THE
BROTHERS WERE DISABLED NEED AND
DESERVE SO- I JUST DON'T THINK
THIS IS THIS IS ABOUT TREATING
PEOPLE ON THE ON THE ISSUE OF A
JOB. THEY SHOULD GET PAID JUST
LIKE EVERYBODY ELSE. YEAH I
HEAR YOU KNOW YOU ARE
APPROACHING FROM THE HUMAN
EMOTION ON HUMANOS SYMPATHY
ASPECT HOWEVER. NOT ALL THE
BUSINESS PEOPLE WOULD LOOK AT
IT THAT WAY BECAUSE THAT THEY
WOULD LOOK AT STUFF. IN A
COMBINATION OF- THAT ASPECT AT
THAT YOU ARE DESCRIBING BUT AT
THE SAME TIME FROM OUR-
STANDPOINT OVER HIS- HIS A
BUSINESS. YOU HEARD THE MANY
MANY. PARENTS AND INDIVIDUALS
WITH A DISABILITY SO THEY ARE
THE DIRECT VOICE US THAT THEY
DO NOT AGREE WITH YOUR SUPPORT
AND THAT THEY ALL POLL STUFF.
SO ARE YOU TRYING TO TELL THE
PROTECT. OUR LOST A TRACK OF
THAT THE ROUGHLY HALF AND HALF
OR MAYBE A LITTLE LESS US ALL.
WHAT A FEW. INDIVIDUALS WITH A
DISABILITY SO DON'T AGREE WITH
YOU. SO THAT THAT THIS IS SO
NOT THE MORAL ISSUE YEAH AND
MOTION ARE USED TO YES THEY DO
SO MORAL. IF WE CAN BUT THE
REALITY GOT TALKING ABOUT THAT
THE PRACTICAL SIDE. OF
PRACTICAL BUSINESS TO WORRY
DON'T WANT NOT TO SEAT US YOU.
SEE THANK GOODNESS MY STATE.
ASSEMBLY WOMAN DAVIES THANK YOU
BETTER CHAIR I'M IF I COULD I
HAVE A- FOR. THE WITNESS OF MR.
THANK YOU MISTER LIMON I HAVE A
QUESTION- IF THIS OF MINIMUM
WAGE IS BANNED IN CALIFORNIA
FOR PEOPLE WITH THEM I D. D.
EVEN THOUGH IT'S STILL LOUD AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL. WHAT DO YOU
THINK WILL HAPPEN WITH MOST OF
THE PEOPLE WORKING IN SUCH
PROGRAMS TODAY I HEAR A LOT OF
OPPOSITION AND I'M AND I
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND. THE
INTENTIONS THE GOOD INTENTIONS
MY CONCERN THAT IT OULD DO
MORE HARM THAN GOOD AND I'M
TRYING TO GET A BETTER- YOU
KNOW IDEA OF WHAT WILL HAPPEN.
THANK YOU. I MEAN. IT HURT
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR- SO. IN
WATCHING WHAT'S BEEN HAPPENING
THE PRESSURE ON SOME OF THESE
SITUATIONS TO CLOSE AND GO OUT
OF BUSINESS IS PRETTY PRETTY
GREAT SO WE'RE SEEING. LESS AND
LESS OF THESE OPPORTUNITIES
AROUND THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
THESE DAYS. BUT THERE ARE STILL
WE BELIEVE AROUND TWELVE
THOUSAND PEOPLE WHO STILL
TODAY. TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THIS
OPPORTUNITY. AND WHAT WE'RE
SEEING IS THAT WHEN THEY LEAVE
THE WORKFORCE. THEY TYPICALLY
AREN'T FINDING A MINIMUM WAGE
OR HIGHER JOB. UNLESS THAT'S
OUR GOAL AND WE GET INTO THAT
AND THEY MOVE AND SOME PEOPLE
DO TRANSITION SUCCESSFULLY THAT
WAY. NOT MANY BECAUSE MANY
TIMES TO TALK ABOUT PEOPLE AT
THE LOWER END OF THE
PRODUCTIVITY SCALE. IN THOSE
PEOPLE TYPICALLY END UP IN A
DAY PROGRAM. WHICH COSTS THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA ODDLY
ENOUGH. ABOUT THREE TIMES AS
MUCH MONEY IN TERMS OF THE
PAYMENTS OF WHAT. THE STATE
PAYS RATE WISE. THAN THEY DO TO
A WORK ACTIVITY PROGRAM THE
COMPARISON IS ABOUT EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS TO THIRTY DOLLARS A
DAY. PER PERSON SO IF YOU DID
THE LITERAL MATH. AND SAID YOU
KNOW ALL TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
IN INTO A DAY PROGRAM. INSTEAD
OF WORKING YOU'D BE TALKING
ABOUT A HUNDRED FIFTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS. OUR CONCERN ON
THIS OVERALL IS THAT WE LOVE
THE IDEA OF HER BY MOVING TO
MINIMUM WAGE. AND THIS BILL
CREATES A PROCESS TO HAVE THAT
CONVERSATION. BUT IT HAS THAT
SLEDGEHAMMER TERMINATION DATE
IN IT. WITHOUT HAVING A
SUCCESSFUL PROGRAM IDENTIFIED
WE WOULD RATHER SEE. THEM COME
BACK TO YOU. WITH AN OUTLINE OF
A PROGRAM TELL YOU HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO FUND IT. AND THEN YOU
DECIDE UPPER NOW WITH THAT
MAKES SENSE TO YOU AS A- AS A
PROGRAM BEFORE YOU KILL OFF
THESE JOBS. SO THAT THAT'S A-
LONGER ANSWER MOST PEOPLE IF
THEY DON'T. HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
WE DON'T SUBSIDIZE OR WE DON'T
DO SOMETHING DIFFERENT. THEY'RE
GONNA MOVE INTO SOME OTHER
PROGRAMS LIKE A DAY PROGRAM IT
WILL NOT BE EMPLOYMENT. ALMOST.
CERTAINLY THANK YOU THANK.
MADAM CHAIR. OR STAY HOME
THAT'S THE ALTERED THEY JUST
HOME CORRECT. IF I MAY- HAVE A
QUESTION THROUGH THE CHAIR FOR
THE CENTER YES THANK YOU.
THAT'S SENATOR THAT'S THAT'S MY
QUESTION IS IN REGARDS TO
FUNDING BECAUSE IF YOU HAVE A
BUSINESS AND YOU WANT YOU WANT
TO BRING IN THESE EMPLOYEES BUT
THEY'RE GIVING ABOUT 25%
PRODUCTIVITY OBVIOUSLY YOU NEED
TO EMPLOY MORE TO BE ABLE TO
GET. WHAT YOU NEED DONE WHERE
IS THE FUNDING FOR THE
BUSINESS- OWNER TO COMPENSATE-
WITH THE FACT THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO NEED TO BRING IN MORE
EMPLOYEES TO- YOU KNOW YOU. TO
REACH THE PRODUCTIVITY THAT
THEY NEED. WELL JUST THIS
LEGISLATURE ALONE IS ALREADY
INVESTING AND ADDING TO. THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY- TO MAKEA
SUCCESSFUL TRANSITION OF
INDIVIDUALS WILL BE OUT OF
THESE SHELTERED WORKSHOPS AS I
SAID EARLIER. THERE IS AN
ADDITIONAL SIXTY ONE MILLION
DOLLARS FOR REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICE COORDINATORS. WHO ARE
GOING TO ASSIST INDIVIDUALS
MOVING OUT OF THE WORKSHOPS. WE
HAVE WE'RE INVESTING IN THESE
COMPETITIVE INTEGRATED
EMPLOYMENT. DOUBLING THE
INCENTIVE PAYMENTS TO SERVICE
PROVIDERS. I MEAN THERE THOSE
ARE JUST TWO EXAMPLES OF THE
STATE LEVEL AND THERE'S ALSO
FEDERAL FUNDS AVAILABLE. SO
THAT THE FUNDING IS THERE THE
QUESTION IS HOW WILL IT BE
USED. AND I ABSOLUTELY HAVE
ENORMOUS RESPECT AND ADMIRATION
FOR ALL THE MEN AND WOMEN WHO
CALLED IN. WHO ARE UP P A
DISABLED HAVE A DISABILITY- AND
AS YOU HEARD. THERE ARE THOSE
WHO SAY THEY SUPPORT AND THERE
ARE THOSE WHO SAY THEY DON'T
SUPPORT. I HOPE. THAT YOU KNOW
THIS IS NOT- IS NOT THIS IT'S
NOT BECAUSE SHOULDN'T BE FACING
THIS FEAR. THAT AN EMPLOYER IS
GOING TO DISCRIMINATE AGAINST
THEM. THAT SHOULD NOT EXIST WE
SHOULD NOT ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN
IN CALIFORNIA. THAT SOMEBODY
DOESN'T GET HIRED BECAUSE
THEY'RE BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST. THAT'S WHAT ALL OF
OUR- CIVIL RIGHTS LAWS HAVE
BEEN ABOUT THAT SOMEBODY
DOESN'T GET DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST BECAUSE OF WHO THEY
ARE. AND THAT'S WHAT WE OUGHT
OF MAKE SURE HAPPENS- AS THEY
GET INTEGRATED. INTO DIFFERENT-
WORKPLACES. THANK YOU I JUST
JUST WANNA MAKE A COMMENT
COMPLETELY UNDERSTAND THAT I
THINK MY CONCERN IS THAT WE
HAVE THE FUNDING. BUT IT HASN'T
BEEN DESIGNATED AND
UNFORTUNATELY WE WATCH THIS
BEFORE WHERE WE HAVE THE
FUNDING BUT IT'S NOT GOING
WHERE THE FUNDING IS. WE PUT
THE CART BEFORE THE HORSE WHERE
IS I'D LIKE TO SEE WHERE THE
FUND IS GOING WORDS THERE IN
WRITING SAYING THIS IS WHAT'S
GOING TO THE BUSINESS THIS IS
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE. SO THAT I
KNOW THAT WHEN I VOTE ON
SOMETHING LIKE THIS I KNOW THAT
THEY'RE GOING TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY- THEY HANDLE THIS BILL
IS GOING TO BE UP IN PROTECTIVE
BAIL. AND IT'S GOING TO BENEFIT
EVERYONE IT'S SO THAT'S MY
CONCERN RIGHT NOW IS JUST
BECAUSE WE HAVE THE MONEY AND
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S IN THE PAST
DOESN'T MEAN IT'S GOING TO GO
WHERE IT NEEDS TO GO. SO I DO
APPRECIATE THIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS FOR. OF
OKAY M. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PUT UP
IN ASSAM AND STONE. TO THE
CHAIR- I CONCUR WITH YOU CENTER
THAT WE MUST WE HAVE TO TREAT
EVERYONE. I CONCUR FARE UP THE
WITH THIS BILL. AND I HOPE YOU
CAN ANSWER THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN
NEGATIVE CONSEQUENCES ON
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE. LITERALLY
TRYING TO DO. THE BEST. FOR DO
YOU HAVE ANY ANY ANY CONCERNS
WITH THAT. WELL I WOULDN'T BE
DOING THIS BILL IF IT WAS GOING
TO LEAVE PEOPLE THOUSANDS OF
PEOPLE OVERNIGHT WITHOUT JOBS
THAT'S NOT WHAT THIS IS ABOUT
AND THIS IS- BUT I'D LIKE
MAYBE. ONE OR TWO OF MY
WITNESSES WHO HAVE THE DAY TO
DAY EXPERIENCE WITH THAT WHO
COULD ANSWER THAT QUESTION
MAYBE- MISTER CARRUTHERS YES.
THANK YOU SENATOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ERIN CARUTHERS IN THE
STATE COUNCIL ON EVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES WE SHARE THAT SAME
CONCERN. THERE'S AN INTERESTING
CONNECTION MADE OF ALL PEOPLE
IN THE THIS PROGRAM MOVE INTO
EMPLOYMENT I THINK THAT MAY BE
AN UNFAIR PARALLEL. THE
QUESTION REALLY IS WILL PLE
IN THIS PROGRAM AND I'M NOT
GOING TO CALL ANYTHING TO PAY
SEVENTY TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR A
JOB I'M NOT GONNA DO THAT. WELL
IN THIS PROGRAM WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO GET IS CONSTRUCTED A
MEANINGFUL DAY AND WHAT'S
MEANINGFUL TO THEM IS GOING TO
BE INDIVIDUAL AND SPECIFIC TO
EACH PERSON SO IT MAY BE
EMPLOYMENT IT MAY BE A
COMPETITOR GREAT EMPLOYMENT OR
MAYBE OTHER PROGRAMS THAT ARE
OFFERED TO THE REGIONAL CENTER
SO THE GOAL I THINK IS NOT JOB
TO JOB OR THIS PROGRAM SEVEN
WHICH TO ANOTHER JOB IT'S FROM
THIS PROGRAM INTO. A MEANINGFUL
DAY FOR THEM. SO IF YOU DON'T
MIND ME ASKING OF THE QUESTION
IS. SO THE FOURTEENTH SEED CODE
THAT THAT. THE OTHER FOLKS WERE
TALKING ABOUT- THAT'S GONNA GET
ELIMINATED OKAY I MEAN. WILL
THEY STILL BE ABLE TO PICK.
WHERE THEY WANT TO GO WHERE
THEY WANT TO WORK. I MEAN YOU
KNOW THERE'S A LOT OF
BUSINESSES THAT ARE. FOR PROFIT
THAT CAN PROBABLY OBSERVE
ABSORB THIS. WITH THERE'S A LOT
OF NONPROFITS DO THAT WILL MAKE
A DECISION SAYING. YOU MAY WE
HAVE TO CUT BACK AND I JUST
DON'T WANT. TO LOSE JOBS YOU
KNOW I MEAN I AM AN UNCLE. IT
HAS BEEN WE THAT THAT AT MY
NEPHEW'S DISABLED. I HAVE STAFF
THAT WAS WORKING IN OUR
DISTRICT. TO GET FOLKS THAT
THAT SHOULD BE DISABLED GO
THROUGH DISABILITY. AND I I'M
I'M CONSTANTLY FIGHTING TO. IT
IS A TOUGH FIGHT. YEAH I BUT I
DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH WHERE
WE ARE GOING TO LOSE JOBS YOU
KNOW THAT INDIVIDUALS ARE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO PICK AND CHOOSE.
I CONCUR WITH WITH THE SENATE
THAT THIS HAS TO BE FAIR. BUT I
DON'T WANT TO GO A YEAR DOWN
THE LINE AND SAY AND- TWELVE
THOUSAND JOBS THAT NOW WE'RE
DOWN TO NINE THOUSAND JOBS. AND
THEN ONE MORE QUESTION I HAVE-
YOU GUYS MENTIONED THAT OTHER
STATES ARE DOING THIS. YOU KNOW
I LIKE TO HEAR AND HOW. HOW IS
THAT COMING UP FOR THE STATE'S
YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN ANYONE
FROM THE OTHER SIDE IF THEY CAN
ALSO- ANSWER THAT. YEAH WHAT
ARE YOUR FROM BOTH SIDES
BECAUSE- WHATEVER TODAY WAS. A
LOT OF PEOPLE AGAINST THIS. AND
I'M I'M I'M SHOCKED I'M
BOTHERED ABOUT. THANK YOU SIR
FOR YOUR YOUR COMPASSION YOUR
INVESTMENT IN THE ISSUE IN YOUR
INVESTMENTS AND REALLY AN ACT
OF LOVE FOR PEOPLE TO HAVE OF
MEANINGFUL IMPORTANT LIVES.
REGARDING OTHER STATES PART OF
THE STATUTE THE BILL HAS BEEN
PROPOSED SAYS LOOK AT THOSE
LESSONS FROM THOSE OTHER STATES
AND MAKE SURE WE KNOW WHAT
THOSE ARE. NOW REGARDING THE
EMPLOYMENT WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN
ALL ALL SEE THE MICROPHONE TO A
CHICKEN HERE IS THAT. SOME HAVE
ACTUALLY TRANSITIONED INTO
OTHER EMPLOYMENT SO PEOPLE THE
SECRETARY OR FAMILIAR WITH
PRIDE INDUSTRIES- WELL KNOWN IN
THIS AREA AND THEY DECIDE TO
STOP DOING FOURTEEN SEES. AND
THEY MOVED INTO EMPLOYMENT
INFORMATION OR STANDING NO WAS
LAID OFF BUT PEOPLE ARE NOT
BEING PAID MINIMUM WAGE I'M
PEOPLE DEVELOPING A DISABILITY
SO. THE STATE INVESTS IN
ENTITIES IN THESE PROGRAMS TO
MAKE THAT TRANSITION THERE'S A
FIFTEEN MILLION DOLLAR POT
THAT'S BEEN AVAILABLE FOR EVERY
YEAR FOR THE PAST FIVE YEARS
AND WILL BE AVAILABLE NEXT
YEAR. WHERE THESE PROGRAMS CAN
COME FORWARD AND BID FOR MONEY
FROM THE STATE TO SAY HOW CAN I
CHANGE HOW CAN I MODERNIZE BUT-
CAN BEHIND ME CAN SPEAK MORE
DIRECTLY BECAUSE HE IS A
PROVIDER WHO MADE THE
TRANSITION. THANK YOU SIR ONE
OF THE SPECIFIC QUESTIONS THAT
YOU ASKED WERE IN PARTICULAR
FELT LIKE NON PROFITS VERSUS
FOR PROFIT ENTITIES- I'LL GIVE
YOU A COUPLE SPECIFIC EXAMPLE
SO SOMETIMES PEOPLE TALK ABOUT
LIKE OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH THE
SAN DIEGO ZOO OBVIOUSLY THAT'S
A LARGE ENTITY WHAT WE MORE OF
OUR PARTNERSHIPS ARE LIKE
OPERABLE PHARMACY IT SLUR TWO
PEOPLE WORKING THERE AND
THEY'VE HIRED A PERSON FROM OUR
POPULATION. A VERY- RECENT
EXAMPLE OF SAN DIEGO PRIDE
WHICH IS A NONPROFIT WHO HAVE
HAD A TERRIBLE FISCAL YEAR
BECAUSE OF THE PANDEMIC THEY
RECENTLY HIRED THREE PEOPLE
FROM OUR PROGRAM TO PERFORM
SOME WORK FOR THEM AS THEY GET
READY FOR- THERE AT THE PRIDE
FESTIVAL IN JULY A USES EXAMPLE
BECAUSE WHETHER IT'S A NN
PROFIT- LIKE MYSELF OR LIKE
CYNICAL PRIDE OR A LARGE FOR
PROFIT LIKE THE SAN DIEGO ZOO
OR SMALL MOM AND POP BUSINESS
LIKE THE PHARMACY. IT STILL
COMES DOWN TO A CHOICE OF HEY
DO YOU WANT TO ALLOW US TO COME
IN SUPPORT YOU TO SUPPORT
OTHERS SENT MISSILE WE DO SO
IT'S REALLY JUST ABOUT BILL
SUPPORTS BUT NOT AROUND AND YOU
CAN TRAIN A BUSINESSES AND
TRAIN THEIR MANAGERS AND THEIR
EMPLOYEES TO WORK WITH THE
POPULATION THAT WE SUPPORT I
WAS. TO THAT ANSWER YOUR
QUESTION OR- YEAH IF YOU COULD.
HOW HOW ARE THE OTHER STATES
DOING. SO I THAT IS MORE OF A
FOR ERIN CROTHERS I CAN JUST
TELL YOU WHAT WE DO HERE- IN
ACROSS THE STATE WE OPERATE NOT
JUST IN SAN DIEGO BUT THE
INLAND EMPIRE IN THE SILICON
VALLEY SO WE'RE OPERATING A
VERY HIGH COST AREAS AS WELL AS
LOWER COST AREAS. AND I GUESS
WE CAN THAT WE'RE NOT HAVING
PUSHED BACK TO PEOPLE EMPLOYING
OUR FOLKS WE JUST ARTICULATE TO
THEM WHY THIS IS VALUABLE TO
THEM WE NEVER TALK ABOUT IT
FROM A PERSPECTIVE OF WOULD YOU
PLEASE HIRE SOMEONE. YEAH IT
MEANS THANK YOU FOR SPEAKING UP
TONY I MIGHT MY CONCERN IS THIS
IS THAT I DON'T WANT TO LOSE
HAVE FOLKS WITHOUT A JOB. YOU
KNOW- IT WAS MENTIONED HERE
THAT YOU KNOW THEY'RE
RESPONDING. RIGHT AND THERE'S
GONNA BE FUNNY IN THE STATE
ALWAYS SEEMS TO LEAD BUT- I
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT FUNDING
IS GOING INTO NOT TAKEN AWAY.
HASN'T TO ME IS NOT ABOUT THE
FIFTEEN DOLLAR. OR THE REYES I
THINK THEY SHOULD DESERVE IT.
BUT I JUST DON'T WANT THEM
WITHOUT A JOB. IF THEY HAVE A
JOB WE HAD TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE PROTECTING THAT JOB THEY
HAVE. NOT TAKEN AWAY SO THANK
YOU SIR. VENTURA IF I COULD
TAKE A CRACK AT THAT- I WANT TO
GIVE YOU JUST A COUPLE PIECES
OF FACTUAL INFORMATION AND
FACTS ARE STUBBORN THINGS RIGHT.
THIS STATE SEVEN YEARS AGO WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHESBRO WAS IN
YOUR SAME SEAT- BASICALLY IN
THE LEGISLATURE. HE PASSED A
BILL THAT COMMITTED THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA TO BE CALLED AN
EMPLOYMENT FOR STATE. FOR
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENT DISABILITIES. I WAS
TWO THOUSAND THIRTEEN WHEN IN
FACT JANUARY FIRST. TWO
THOUSAND FOURTEEN. HERE WE ARE
SEVEN YEARS LATER. AND THE
EMPLOYMENT RATE OF OUR
POPULATIONS OF PEOPLE WITH
INTELLECTUAL DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES IS EXACTLY THE
SAME. WE SAT A MADE IN THE
STATE THE TOP PRIORITY FOR ALL
PEOPLE WITH INTELLECTUAL
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
EMPLOYMENT FIRST THAT'S THE
FIRST THING WE SHOULD DO FOR
THEM AND YET OUR EMPLOYMENT
RATE IS STILL AT 14% THE SAME
AS IT WAS SEVEN YEARS AGO. AND
NINE POINTS BELOW THE NATIONAL
AVERAGE. THE NATIONAL AVERAGE
FOR THIS POPULATION IS TWENTY
THREE PERCENT. CALIFORNIA'S AT
FOURTEEN. NOW IT AND WE HAVE NO
DISCOMFORT WITH ANYTHING IN
THIS BILL. IN TERMS OF THE
PROCESS TO COME UP WITH A GREAT
PLAN. BUT HAVING THE
TERMINATION DATE SET OUT THERE
AS PART OF THAT WITHOUT THE
PLAN. IS THE PROBLEM. AND SO
WHAT YOU'RE SUGGESTING I THINK
IS RIGHT PROTECT THE PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN THEIR JOBS TODAY DEVELOP
A GREAT PLAN. AND THEN WHEN YOU
GET THAT PLAN COME BACK AND
TELL US WHAT IT IS AND HOW
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND IT. IF YOU
GUYS WANT TO MAKE THE LEAP THEN
YOU SHOULD DO IT. BUT I HAVE
SEEN THIS MOVIE FOR MANY YEARS
AND WE'RE JUST NOT DOING A
GREAT JOB. WHATEVER MONEY WE
PUT INTO THOSE OF EMPLOYING
THIS POPULATION. THIS BILL
LITERALLY WOULD KNOCK IN THREE
YEARS. TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE
OUT OF POSITIONS THAT THEY HAVE
CHOSEN TO BE IN TODAY. THERE'S
NO GETTING AROUND THAT YOUR
CHOICE THEN IS THEY WILL EITHER
BE. GIVEN MINIMUM WAGE TO STAY
IN THAT OR ANOTHER JOB. SOMEHOW
THERE'S NOTHING THAT SPECIFIES
HOW THAT'S GONNA WORK YOU COULD
SUBSIDIZES. THE STATE COULD SAY
WE'RE GONNA COME FOR THE POT OF
MONEY AND FILL THE GAP BETWEEN
THE PERSONS FOURTEEN SEE WAGE.
AND THE WAY TO THE EMPLOYERS
GOING TO PAYING WHICH IS
MINIMAL WE COULD DO THAT.
THEY'RE BENT TO BILLS IN THE
PAST THAT OFFERED A TAX CREDIT
TO EMPLOYERS. ON THAT SPREAD
WHICH WOULD MAKE IT EASIER FOR
EMPLOYERS TO SWALLOW SOMEBODY
WHO'S AT A LOWER PRODUCTIVITY
LEVEL BUT WE KILL BOTH OF THOSE
BILLS. BECAUSE WE DON'T WANT TO
LOWER THE PROP NINETY EIGHT
BASE IN THE STATE. SO THERE ARE
IDEAS AND WAYS TO GET OF THIS
WE'RE TOTALLY OPEN TO BEING A
PART OF THAT. I WILL TELL YOU
THAT I AM PLEASED. THAT CENTER
DORADO ADDED SOME OF THE PEOPLE
WHO DO FOURTEEN C. PROGRAMS
TODAY TO THE BILL IN TERMS OF
STAKEHOLDERS WHO WILL
PARTICIPATE IN THAT PROCESS. I
AM JUST OUR ORGANIZATION IS
ABSOLUTELY UNCOMFORTABLE
KILLING OFF THOSE JOBS UNTIL WE
HAVE THE PLAN. YOU COULD
GRANDFATHER MEN THAT BE ANOTHER
WAY TO DO IT GRANDFATHER THOSE
PEOPLE IN TODAY LET HIM KEEP
THEIR JOB AND MOVE INTO
SOMETHING NEW IF IT DEVELOPS.
THOSE ARE JUST SOME IDEAS. SIR
I AM ARE YOU GET A SOMEONE OKAY
A SOMEONE'S STYLE. THANK YOU I
THINK WE HEAR THE EMOTION ON
THIS ISSUE REALLY ON BOTH SIDES.
AND TO THE WAY ADVOCACY GOES IS
SOMETIMES WE GET FOLKS WHO.
WORKED UP ABOUT AN ISSUE.
PARTIAL INFORMATION AND I
ALWAYS FIND THAT TO BE. SAD AND
POTENTIALLY USE. THEM BEEN
TALKING TO A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
ACROSS THE BOARD. ON THIS ISSUE
AND I JUST WANTED TO MAKE THAT
STATEMENT THAT I THINK WE HAVE
TO BE CAREFUL. ABOUT THE
EMOTIONS AND FOR US WE NEED TO
STEP BACK AND TAKE A LOOK AT
THE BIGGER PICTURE HERE. AND
WHAT'S BEING PRESENTED AND
TALKED ABOUT LOOKS LIKE ZERO
SON AND IT'S NOT ZERO SO.
THERE'S A LOT THAT CAN BE DONE
HERE. AND FOR MOST OF PEOPLE
I'VE INTERACTED WITH WITH
DISABILITIES THAT JOB THAT
ABILITY TO WORK. EVEN AT NOT
EXPECTED PRODUCTIVITY LEVEL.
WHICH AGAIN IS A POTENTIAL PATH
TO A FALSE CHOICE. THE PRICE
THEY GET FOR DOING THAT WORK
THE DIGNITY GET FOR DOING THAT
WORK AND ENGAGEMENT IS WHAT IS
MOST SIGNIFICANT. AND IF WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO SAY IS THE
STANDARD. FOR SOMEONE
DISABILITIES IS THE SAME AS
SOMEONE WITHOUT DISABILITIES WE
END UP WITH THOSE FOLKS CHOICES.
SO WE HAVE TO COME TO AN ERROR
IT SOME OF THE THESE LAWS GO
BACK TO IT AS WE HAVE BEEN
SATED FDR. AND YES WESTLEY JUST
BROKE. THE LAW SEVEN YEARS AGO
THAT DIDN'T SEEM TO MOVE THE
NEEDLE UNEMPLOYMENT SO
SOMETHING HAS TO CHANGE IT THIS
IS A GOOD STEP AND A GOOD
RECOGNITION. OF WHAT THAT
CHANGE REALLY NEEDS TO BE A
PROVIDING SOME ADDITIONAL
DIGNITY BECAUSE I CANNOT
BELIEVE THAT SOMEBODY WHO IS
DOING WORK IN AN ORGANIZATION.
THAT IS BEING PAID. SUB MINIMUM
WAGE AND REMEMBER WE'RE
ACTUALLY NOT TALKING ABOUT SUB
MINIMUM CALIFORNIA WAY. FEDERAL
WAGE WHICH IS STILL SEVEN
DOLLARS AND FIFTY CENTS ABOUT.
A LOT OF THESE FOLKS PERFORMING
THESE JOBS. ARE GETTING SUB.
MINIMUM WAGE WELL BELOW WHAT WE
WERE TALKING ABOUT THIS
LEGISLATURE WE WANT TO GIVE GET
PEOPLE AWAY. AND IN ANY
ORGANIZATION THERE ARE
DIFFERENT LEVELS OF
PRODUCTIVITY. SO WE CAN'T BE
SAYING BECAUSE WE DON'T VALUE
YOU YOU'RE ALLOWED TO HAVE SOME
MINIMUM WAGE AND THAT'S
ULTIMATELY WHAT'S GOING ON HERE.
BUT TAKE A DEEP BREATH. TAKE A
STEP BACK. AND APPRECIATE WHAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I KNOW CENTER
YOU'RE WORKING WITH THE CHAIR
AND WITH THIS COMMITTEE BECAUSE
WHAT WE- OUR PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY IN THIS AREA
THANK. IS TO ACKNOWLEDGE THE
TRANSITION WE ARE WHERE WE ARE.
GIVEN THE HISTORY OF FEDERAL
LAWS AND STATE LAWS IN IT AND
OTHER ATTEMPTS. WHERE WE WANT
TO BE I THINK IT'S VERY CLEAR
AND I AGREE WITH YOU THAT A LOT
OF YOUR TIME TWO YEARS. BECAUSE
GIVING PEOPLE. DIGNITY IS THE
WORK. BUT IS ALSO RECOGNITION
WITHIN OUR CURRENT STRUCTURE OF
HOW WE VALUE THE WORK THAT'S
THE MINIMUM WAGE AND WE HAVE
DONE THAT. THE CROSS THE BORDER
WE HAVE RATCHETED THAT UP
APPROPRIATELY. RECOGNIZING WHAT
IT COSTS TO LIVE AND TO WORK IN
CALIFORNIA SO WHAT I'M HOPING
AND I KNOW WE DON'T HAVE.
AMENDMENTS HERE BUT I'VE BEEN
TALKING TO COMMITTEE BEHIND
INTO. THAT SOME OF YOUR
SUPPORTERS SAID AND YOUR
SPONSORS A NUMBER OF FOLKS
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND THIS AND
THERE'S A POTENTIAL I KNOW
YOU'RE TALKING TO THEM ABOUT IT
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M ASKING IS
WE HAVE TO BE RESPONSIBLE. TO
THAT TRANSITION AND I GET
WORRIED WHEN THERE ARE CLIFFS
THAT GET BUILT IN. WITHOUT ANY
ANSWER WE'RE STILL WAITING THIS
COMMITTEE WITH THEY'RE BUILT ON
A NUMBER OF YEARS AGO IN THE
CONTINUE OF CARE REFORM
DIFFERENT SUBJECT BUT STILL
WITHIN JURISDICTIONS COMMITTEE.
GETTING DEPARTMENT TO DO GAP
ANALYSIS. THAT WAS DUE BY A
CERTAIN DAY WE STILL DON'T HAVE
IT REXY TAKING. ACTION ON SOME
OF THOSE GAPS WITHOUT THE HELP
THAT HELPS HAVE BEEN DONE FINE
WORK WE ARE MAKING PROGRESS AND
I WANNA SEE IS MAKING PROGRESS
HERE. SO I THINK WE HAVE TO. UV
BEYOND WHAT APPEARS TO BE. A
ZERO SUM. IT ULTIMATELY FALLS
CHOICES. AND REALLY SET UP.
SUCCESS HERE. IN A WAY THAT
GETS EVERYBODY COMFORTABLE I
WOULD RATHER SEE THE PLAN.
BEFORE FINAL ACTION GETS TAKEN.
SO ALL I'M ASKING IS THAT
YOU'RE WORKING WITH COMMITTEE
STAFF HERE AND I'M HOPING THIS
BILL MOVES OUT AND THAT'S FINE.
BECAUSE WE HAVE OTHER
OPPORTUNITIES IN APPROACH FROM
THE FLOOR. TO GET THIS RIGHT
BECAUSE IF WE DON'T. SET UP
THAT TRANSITION PROCESS AND
APPROPRIATE WAY. IT'S HARD TO
KNOW WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN.
AND I DON'T BUY INTO THE FEAR
ABOUT THE CLIFF BECAUSE A LOT
OF THESE JOBS B. 14% YEARS AGO
14% NOW SHOWS THINGS REALLY
AREN'T. WORKING THE WAY WE
WOULD HAVE INTENDED SO LET'S
MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE WHO ARE
WORKING GET THE BENEFIT OF THAT
WORK. AT THE WAGES WE EXPECT
THEM TO GET. THAT'S FAIR THAT'S
EQUITABLE THAT'S JUST. BUT
BECAUSE WE ARE TRANSITIONING
FROM ONE STEP TO THE NEXT I'M
JUST ASKING THAT YOU WORK WITH
THE CMMITTEE AND MAKE SURE
THAT THAT WE UNDERSTAND WHAT
THAT TRANSITION IS. AND THAT WE
DON'T. TO PERPETUATE THE- THE
CURRENT NARRATIVE OF THIS TWO
ZERO SUM. ENVIRONMENT BECAUSE
IT'S REALLY NOT THAT SIMPLE YES
IT'S COMPLICATED. BUT WE NEED
AND THAT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE ARE COGNIZANT OF WHAT
THAT TRANSITION IS. AND THAT
WE'RE BRINGING EVERYONE ALONG.
TO HELP MANAGE THE- THESE
PEOPLE WHO ARE VALUABLE TO US
IN OUR COMMUNITY THE WORK THAT
THEY DO. THE LIFE EXPERIENCE
THAT THEY GET IN THE BENEFIT
THAT THE GET FROM ANY VARIOUS
LEVELS OF EMPLOYMENT OR
INTERNSHIPS OR- ANY OF THESE
POSSIBILITIES SO THAT'S- WHAT I
WANT TO MAKE SURE OF- I'M
SUPPORTING IT TODAY ABSOLUTELY
AND I AGREE WITH WHAT YOU'RE
WITH WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO.
I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE WE'RE
TRANSITIONING APPROPRIATE. OKAY
THANK YOU SOMEONE AND SOMEONE
BRENT DID YOU THE QUESTION. I'M
SORRY SIX SEVEN CALLS MY FIRST
DAY COMMITTEE. I APPRECIATE ALL
OF THE TESTIMONY TODAY I HAVE
FOUR SIBLINGS OF SPECIAL NEEDS
INCLUDING A LITTLE BROTHER WITH
CEREBRAL PALSY- AND I THINK
THERE ARE A LOT OF IMPORTANT
VALUES AT STAKE IN THIS BILL.
ONE OF THEM IS THAT WE DON'T
DISCRIMINATE ON IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS WE DON'T PAY
MEN LAST BECAUSE WOMEN ARE MORE
PRODUCTIVE. MY WE DON'T PAY
WHITE FOLKS LESS BECAUSE PEOPLE
OF COLOR MORE PRODUCTIVE. WE
DON'T DISCRIMINATE ON IMMUTABLE
CHARACTERISTICS AND THAT'S AN
IMPORTANT VALUE TO HOLD I
THINK. MY COLLEAGUE ALSO
MENTION THAT WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT PAYING BELOW THE FEDERAL
MINIMUM WAGE. WHICH IS LESS
THAN HALF OF WHAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT IS THE STATE MINIMUM WAGE
CURRENTLY. ABOUT WORKERS
RIGHTS. AND IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT. WHEN I APPRECIATE
WHAT I APPRECIATE ABOUT THIS
BILL AND LIKE TO THINK THAT
AUTHORS IT IT'S ABOUT
DEVELOPING A PLAN. IT'S ABOUT
SITTING WITH STAKEHOLDERS ABOUT
A MULTI YEAR PHASE OUT IT'S
ABOUT PROTECTING THE TWELVE
THOUSAND FOLKS IN THESE JOBS
AND DOING IT IN A THOUGHTFUL-
INSINCERE WAY- BUT NOT AT THE
EXPENSE OF NOT SETTING A HARD
RULE THAT BY TWENTY TWENTY FIVE
WE'VE GOT TO PAY PEOPLE FAIR.
AND SO I WOULD LIKE TO BE A
PART OF THAT PLANNING A PART OF
THINKING THAT THE WRITING THIS
ENTIRE COMMITTEE SHOULD BE
<c.red>NVOLVED IN THAT PLANNING I</c>
THINK. ALL OF THE STAKEHOLDERS
IN THIS ROOM NEED TO BE A PART
OF THAT PLAN BECAUSE WE ALL
WANT TO MAKE SURE. THAT THE
TWELVE THOUSAND PEOPLE WITH
THESE JOBS KEEP. THESE JOBS AND
THAT WE EXPAND THESE JOBS
BECAUSE OF THE RATE HASN'T
CHANGED. IN SEVEN YEARS THAT'S
AN INCREDIBLY. ABYSMAL
PERFORMANCE FOR THE STATEMENT
ALSO MEANS THAT PAYING PEOPLE A
SUB MINIMUM WAGE LIKE TWO
DOLLARS AN HOUR STILL. NOT
ENOUGH INCENTIVE FOR EMPLOYERS
TO JUST DO THE RIGHT THING- AND
SO WE'VE GOT TO DO MORE AS A
STATE AND SO ON. THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS TO THE FLOOR
TODAY AND YOU HAVE MY PHONE.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER RYAN-
IT'S COME TO MY ATTENTION THAT
WE DID HAVE TWO WITNESSES THAT
WERE HERE JUST TO OFFER PUBLIC
COMMENT JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR THANK YOU TO THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE VERY
JUTTING WITH THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY SERVICES
ASSOCIATION. NOT A FORMAL
POSITION BUT CONCERNED AROUND
THE TIMELINE ALTERNATIVES AND
FUNDING THANK YOU THANK YOU SIR.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAMEIS
VANESSA DE SAC AND THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE ROMAN
CENTER WERE CRYSTAL WORKS. AND
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU- BECAUSE-
SENATOR REID SO- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD TODAY- ELIMINATING
SOME AND MINIMUM WAGE FOR
EMPLOYEES WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. IS CRUCIAL TO
MAKING SURE THAT THIS
POPULATIONS NOT EXPLOITED AND
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES AND HAVE
MY COLLEAGUE MENTIONED- YOU
KNOW IT IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ENSURE THAT THE TRANSITION TO
ELIMINATING FOURTEEN T.
LICENSEES IS WELL THOUGHT OUT
AND A GOOD PLAN IS IMPLEMENTED
AND I KNOW THAT THE CONCERNS OF
THE IDT COMMUNITY AT THE TOP OF
MIND FOR YOU- AND CAN I ALSO
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS. TO
LISTEN TO OUR CONCERNS AND THE
CONCERNS OF THE IDT COMMUNITY-
I KNOW YOUR HEART IS IN THE
RIGHT PLACE TO CALL ME LAST
NIGHT BECAUSE THIS IS VERY
IMPORTANT TO YOU AND THIS
COMMUNITY IS IMPORTANT TO YOU-
AND I ALSO KNOW THAT YOU'LL BE
COMMITTED TO ADDRESSING THE
CONCERNS MY COLLEAGUES
MENTIONED- ABOUT THE BILL AND
THE DEVELOPMENT OF THE PLAN.
AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF ITS
RELEASE AND I'M IN
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE I
SHOULD THE BILL PASS OUT OF THE
COMMITTEE SO AGAIN THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR OSLO AND FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS BILL AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU ON THIS. I CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE DOWN.
WELL I APPRECIATE EVERY SINGLE
COMMENT THAT WAS MADE BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT. WE ALL. LOVE AND
SUPPORT AND ADMIRE OUR ALL OF
OUR BIG SECTORS OF OUR
COMMUNITY. ALL OF OUR FAMILIES.
I SPECIALLY ADMIRE AND RESPECT
THE FAMILIES OF THOSE WHO HAVE-
DISABLED MEMBERS- I DON'T KNOW
PERSONALLY WHAT'S THAT WHAT
THAT'S LIKE I HAVE. EXTENDED
FAMILY. THAT ARE DISABLED I
KNOW THE DIFFICULTIES. BUT I
ALSO KNOW THAT THERE ARE MANY
WAYS. FOR THEM AND THEY DO
ENJOY LIFE. THAT IS NOT JUST A
JOB BUT IF THEY HAVE A JOB.
THEY SHOULD BE TREATED THE SAME
AS EVERYBODY ELSE SO THANK YOU
ALL- FROM THE BOTTOM OF MY
HEART ALL OF YOUR CONSTRUCTIVE.
SUGGESTIONS AND CRITICISMS AND-
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR BIBLE
THANK YOU MANAGER. THANK YOU SO
MUCH SENATOR- PEOPLE ON THE
LINES THAT DIDN'T GET TO. DO
THEY ARE YOU A SUPPORTER
OPPOSITION IS OPERATOR IS THAT
TRUE. PRESENTLY WE HAVE NO
WARNING Q. IF YOU WANT TO SHE
WAS WRITING AND- NOW I THINK I
THINK WE'RE GOOD THANK YOU SO
MUCH OPERATOR I'M THINKING
ABOUT YOU SENATOR. AND. MR
FRAZIER DID YOU WANT. TO MAKE A
COMMENT. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR-
JIM FRAZIER THE CITY OF
FAIRFIELD I'M NOT HERE AS A
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE OF SEPT
ELEVENTH ASSEMBLY DISTRICT BUT
I'M HERE AS THE PROPONENT FOR
THE DISABLED POPULATION THE IDT
POPULATION I'VE BEEN A
VOLUNTEER AT THE SPECIAL
OLYMPICS FOR SIXTEEN YEARS AND
TOWARD THE STATE ALL OVER IN
WORK PROGRAMS. AND INTEGRATED
WORK PROGRAMS AND APPLAUD
WESLEY CHESBRO FOR HIS
WONDERFUL LEGISLATION WITH THE
GREAT INTENT. BUT IT FALLS FAR
SHORT OF THE EXPECTATIONS. FAR
SHORT NOW WHEN YOU LOOK AT THIS
OPPORTUNITY AND I APPLAUD THE
AUTHOR FOR HER OWN HER HUMANITY
ABSOLUTELY SOME OF THE MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE WHO HAVE SET
STATED THE SAME. THIS IS ABOUT
CIVIL RIGHTS. IT IS TO A POINT.
AND THE POINT IS THAT WHEN THAT
INDIVIDUAL HAS THE CAPABILITY
NOW THEY ARE GOING TO DETERMINE
IF THEY HAVE THE CAPABILITY
ALSO IF THEY ARE TO COMPETE ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT I'D LIKE TO
ALSO SHARE WITH YOU. IS THAT.
WHEN IT'S PHASED IN IN THIS
MANNER AND IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
THAT THERE ARE TWELVE THOUSAND
PEOPLE THAT WILL BE AFFECTED BY
THIS. THAT THE PROBABILITY OF A
LOT OF THEM IN THE INTERIM WILL
GO TO THE ADULT DAY PROGRAMS.
AT A COST OF EIGHTY FIVE
DOLLARS A DAY. NOW IF YOU TIMES
THAT BY TWELVE THOUSAND THAT'S
A HUNDRED AND FIFTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS A DAY IMPACT. TO THE
CAME TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
ARE WE WILLING TO DO THAT NOW
AS MR- STONE IT ALLUDED TO. YES
WE SHOULD HAVE A LONGER PHASE
IN BECAUSE WE DON'T KNOW WITH
THIS NEW BUDGET FINANCING IF WE
CANNOT GET THE JOB COACHES. IF
WE CAN GET THE ABILITY TO MOVE
IN UPLIFT THESE INDIVIDUALS TO
THIS LEVEL FUNDING. THAT IS THE
PURPOSE YES IT ALWAYS HAS BEEN
WITH FORTS FOURTEEN C. TO BE
ABLE TO UP LIFT PEOPLE AS HAS
BEEN MENTIONED EVERY SIX MONTHS
THIRD. OF ASSESSED WHAT POINT
OF ORDER MADAM CHAIR. HI I
APPRECIATE WHAT THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IS SAYING HOWEVER AS
HE'S SPEAKING. AS A MEMBER OF
THE PUBLIC NOW AND WE HAVE
CLOSED PUBLIC COMMENTS I'M
WORRIED ABOUT HOW THIS WORKS
WITH THIS COMMITTEE AND OTHER
COMMITTEES. IF WE BREAK SO
SIGNIFICANTLY FROM FROM OUR
PROCESS THAT THERE ARE OTHER
WAYS FOR LEGISLATORS TO WEIGH
IN ON LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS. NO
OFFENSE BECAUSE I VALUE THE
WORK THAT YOU'RE DOING. BUT I
WORRY ABOUT THE IMPLICATIONS
FOR OUR PROCESSES IN COMMITTEE
WORK- AND I AM ADDRESS SIR MR
STONE AS EIGHTY. PERCENT OF THE
FAIR CITY OF FAIRFIELD AS A
RESIDENT NOT AS A LEGISLATOR.
AND I'M JUST SORT OF MY TRAVELS
IN MY EXPERIENCE YOU KNOW WE'VE
HAD SOME COMMENTS THANK YOU
WELL AGAIN I WOULD HOPE THAT
YOU CAN ADDRESS AND- MISTER
STONE'S LONG. ISSUE ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT THIS IS A WELL
THOUGHT OUT PLAN AND MOVE-FORWARD. WITH CAPABILITY AND
POSSIBILITY I THANK YOU FRAZIER.
TO HAVE A MOTION. FIVE SECONDS
OKAY MR WARD MAKES MOTION SIR
BRIAN SECOND. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES. DAVIES NOW ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BRIAN I AND II CHOI.
CHINA VOTING STONE STONE I'VE
BEEN THE PADUCAH PHILIPPINES I
WARD MORE HI. FIFTY THE VOTE
SIX TO ONE THE MEASURE PASSES
THANK YOU MATTER TO ROUTE
THROUGH FOR YOUR PATIENCE AND
HARD WORK. WE HAVE CENTER COURT
CASE HERE HE WAS HERE AREA.
THANK YOU SENATOR CORTESE FOR
YOUR PATIENCE AND WE'RE READY
FOR YOU SIR. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS- TODAY I'M
HERE TO PRESENT. SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. THE UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME TRANSITION AGE
FOSTER YOUTH THAT. RICK
RESEARCH TELLS US. ZERO THREE.
I THINK YOU GOT A MOTION AND A
SECOND WITH THE BILL. HAVING
CONTINUE SIR OKAY. RESEARCH
TELLS US THAT FOSTER YOU FACE
SIGNIFICANT DISADVANTAGES
NEARLY EVERY FACET OF LIFE
COMPARED TO THEIR NON FOSTER
YOUTH PEERS. FORTY THAT MORNING
I COULD HAVE FAVORABLE I'M
SORRY UNFAVORABLE EMPLOYMENT
OUTCOMES AS WE KNOW PHYSICAL
MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES. CONTACT
WITH THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM THERE WILL RATES OF
SECONDARY AND POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION. TO NO SURPRISE THE
KOBE NINETEEN PANDEMIC IS ONLY
EXACERBATED THESE HARDSHIPS.
ONE FORTY THREE TWO H. TWENTY
ONE THE AGE OUT OF CARE
BECOMING ELIGIBLE FOR THE
MONTHLY CASH BENEFITS THEY RELY
UPON TO MEET THEIR BASIC NEEDS.
AS A RESULT ONE FOR YOUTH
EXPERIENCE HOMELESSNESS AFTER
AGING OUT OF THE EXTENDED
FOSTER CARE PROGRAM. SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE ESTABLISHES A
STATEWIDE PILOT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE APPROXIMATE TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED FOSTER YOUTH AGING OUT
OF EXTENDED CARE. WITH DIRECT
UNCONDITIONAL CASH ASSISTANCE
OF ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH FOR THREE YEARS. THIS
PROPOSAL CLOSELY MIRRORS
SUCCESSFUL SANTA CLARA COUNTY
TRANSITION AGE YOUTH FBI
PROGRAM. WHICH IS CURRENTLY
SUPPORTING SEVENTY TWO FOSTER
YOUTH IT WHICH IS EXTENDED BY
THE WAY BY THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AFTER ITS FIRST
YEAR. RECIPIENTS OF THAT
PROGRAM OF REPORTED THAT THE
INCOME IS ARE GOING TO COVER
THE BASIC EXPENSES ESTABLISH
SAVINGS IMPROVE THEIR CREDIT
SCORES AND MORE. YOU WILL HERE
SHORTLY OF FROM ONE OF THOSE
PARTICIPANTS WILL SURE. HOW THE
BASIC INCOME IS AFFECTED HER
LIFE. IT IS CLEAR. THAT OUR
CURRENT SYSTEMS ARE NOT MEETING
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF A FOSTER
YOUTH. SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE HAS
THE POTENTIAL TO CHANGE THE
TRAJECTORY. OF THE LIVES OF
TRANSITION AGE FOSTER YOUTH BY
PROVIDING THEM WITH FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THEY REQUIRE TO
SUCCESSFULLY TRANSITION OF CARE
INTO ADULTHOOD THE WITH THAT I
WOULD EXPRESS IT RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. IN ONE OF A-
ADD THAT DETAILS FINE FOODS
THESE- JESSE AGUILAR DIRECTOR
OF BEYOND FOSTER CARE JOURNEY
HOUSE IT'LL BE TO SMITH A
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH. THE
CURRENT PARTICIPANT IN THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY PILOT
PROGRAM- I WOULD ASK THAT YOUR-
TO ALLOW- IF YOU WILL ONLY TO
SMITH TO TESTIFY FIRST BECAUSE
OF TIME CONSTRAINTS. ARE THAT
SHE'S FACING. AT THIS TIME
THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME
SENATOR AND YES THEM OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR LEADERS SPENT. WELL YES WE
CAN HEAR YOU MISS SMITH. OKAY
GREAT THANK YOU- HELLO
EVERYONE- MY INFLUENCE MET
AGAIN A FORMER FOSTER YOUTH AND
CREPITUS OPINION SANTA CLARA
COUNTY IDBI PILOT PROGRAM. AND
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU- SINCE
I'VE BEEN RECEIVING THE
PAYMENTS LAST YEAR- I'VE BEEN
ABLE TO PAY DOWN ON SOME OF MY
SCHOOL DEBT WHICH IS CURRENTLY
AT SIXTY THOUSAND- AND THEN USE
WHATEVER I CAN TO STATE TO
CREATE A CUSHION FOR WHEN I
COMPLETELY EXIT- AFTER CARE
SERVICES. IN OCTOBER OF THIS
YEAR- AND I AM IN STRONG. A
PASS A THIS BILL BECAUSE
SHOPPING A BIRTHDAY. DOESN'T
MEAN YOU NO LONGER NEED SUPPORT-
I HAVE BEEN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM SINCE NINETEEN NINETY
SIX. AND SINCE THEN- I'VE DONE
ALL THAT I COULD- TO GIVE
MYSELF A CHANCE- BUT WHAT I
FOUND IN THE TWENTY FIVE YEARS
IS THAT NO MATTER IF YOU LEAVE
THE SYSTEM AT. EIGHTEEN TWENTY
ONE TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE.
YOU STILL FALL VICTIM TO
ADDRESS THEIR- TYPES THAT
SURROUND FOSTER YOU- AND THE
MOST GEHRY ONE FOR ME AND
HOMELESSNESS ESPECIALLY BECAUSE
THEY LIVE IN A TO THE
CONCHOLOGY. AND EVEN THOUGH I
WILL NOT QUALIFY FOR THE
STATEWIDE PILOT PROGRAM. I KNOW
THAT THERE ARE. OTHER PARTS YOU
INTO MY POSITION THAT MYSELF-
NEED TO SUPPORT BECAUSE WE
DON'T HAVE ANYONE ELSE. AND SO
I STRONGLY. SUPPORT THIS BILL
AND I HOPE THAT YOU WOULD
CONSIDER PASSING. SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE AND FUTURE BILLS
JUST LIKE IT THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE A
NEXT WITNESS ON THE LINE JESSE
I WORK. WE DO YES GET THE AG
WIRE LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU
THANK YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON
CARE- AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE- I AM HERE ON BEHALF
OF JENNY HOUSE THE NONPROFIT
THAT PROVIDES DIRECT SERVICES
AN ADVOCATE TO HELP ON THE
FAUCET YOU. BITE THE BULLET IN
THEIR LIVES. BUT I'M ALSO HERE
SOMEONE WITH EXPERIENCE FOSTER
CARE. ACTUAL LITERAL MEYER YOUR
BILL YEARS DUE TO THE LACK OF
FINANCIAL STABILITY. THIRTY
YEARS OLD RECENTLY COMPLETED MY
80 DEGREES THE- A FEW WEEKS
AGO. IN THE POPULAR CRESSMAN
COOPER UNIVERSITY. I ENROLLED
IN MY FIRST SEMESTER AT EAST
LOS ANGELES COLLEGE IN THE
SPRING OF TWO THOUSAND AND. IT
TOOK ME ELEVEN YEARS CAN CROSS
THIS MILESTONE STRICTLY BECAUSE
I'D NEVER HAD THE LUXURY OF
HAVING MY EDUCATION B. MY ONLY
PRIORITY. I NEVER FORGET THE
FEELING OF READING PAID THE-
BECAUSE THE OVERDRAFT FEES ON
MY BANK STATEMENTS WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE UP THE LAST FIFTY
DOLLARS THAT I WAS SUPPOSED TO
HAVE LEFT. AFTER PAYING MY
BILLS. THE NEED TO PAY FOR ALL
MY OWN LIVING EXPENSES. DELAYED
MY EDUCATION. HOW TO RECEIVE
THE BENEFITS OF A UNIVERSAL
BASIC INCOME PROGRAM I WOULD
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO WORK LESS
HOURS AND BROUGHT BY WERE TIED
MY SCHOOL WE- I WOULD HAVE
COMPLETED MY DEGREE YEARS AGO.
IN MY PROFESSIONAL CAPACITY I
HAVE HEARD SOME COLLEAGUES
CONCERNED WITH THE NOTION OF
GIVING POSSE YOU BRING MONEY
WHICH BAFFLES MY MIND ON SO
MANY LEVELS. AND IS WORKING
SUPPORTING FORMER BOSS YOU WILL
NOT A LOT OF US ARE ARE ARE
SINGLE PARENTS WERE JUGGLING
WAY TOO MANY RESPONSIBILITY.
THAT IS WHY I'M HERE TODAY
URGING YOUR SUPPORT ON SB SEVEN
THIRTY NINE. PROVIDING
TRANSITION LATE TRANSITION IF
YOU TALK TO YOU WITH FINANCIAL
RESOURCES IT'S NOT ABOUT FREE
MONEY. IT'S ABOUT EQUITY. NO
MATTER HOW MANY RESOURCES WE
THROW AT THE ISSUES WITH PAIN
COOPER THE REALITY OF NOT
HAVING A FAMILY FOUNDATION WILL
ALWAYS PLACE ALSO YOU IN A
DISADVANTAGED POSITION. A
UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME PROGRAM
IS A CRITICAL STEP FORWARD IN
BALANCING THE PLAINFIELD. OR
FORMER BOSS USED TO HAVE A FAIR
SHOT AT THE DEATH AND LYFT. AND
FOR THESE REASONS I URGE YOUR
SUPPORT ON SB SEVEN THREE NINE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER GORE. DO WE HAVE ANY
INPUT ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. CASEY NINE I DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
SUPPORT IN THE REMOTE TESTIMONY
STATION. AND WHEN YOU. OKAY WE
DOWN OKAY DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT I'M
SORRY WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM GO AHEAD.
KIMBERLY ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE
OPERATOR CAN BE OPEN THE LINES
FOR PUBLIC SUPPORT- AGAIN THIS
IS JUST PUBLIC SUPPORT- PLEASE
STATE THE NAME ORGANIZATION AND
POSITION. FOUR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT OF S. B. SEVEN THREE
NINE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
ZERO. AND LINE FOUR HUNDRED
THIRTY FIVE YEAR MIKE IS OPEN.
HELLO THIS IS KEVIN INFO
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON
LEGISLATION CALIFORNIA IS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. LINE. ONE HUNDRED NINETY
NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON KEN LEWIS
REPRESENTING THREE CLIENTS
TODAY CHILDREN NOW THE
CALIFORNIA COALITION FOR YOUTH
AND THAT'S NOT AND THE COURT.
THANK YOU. WHITE. ONE HUNDRED
FOURTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON ALL OF
YES BECAUSE WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY SIX. CAN YOU
BRING A FORTE FROM THE ALLIANCE
FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
LINE TWO HUNDRED ELEVEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE. TWO
HUNDRED EIGHTY. HELLO THIS IS
JORDAN TELLS- A FORMER FOX YOU
THANK CALLING ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA YOUTH CONNECTION
CALLING IN AND STRONG SUPPORT
FOR SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. LINE OF. FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY THREE. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED FORTY THREE YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. I AM NOT SURE JACKSON
ZERO NINE. IT IS HERE WE CAN
HEAR YOU PLEASE GO AHEAD. OKAY
HI CHATTY DANIELS A FORMER FOXY
IS ALSO- I'M CALLING FROM THE
WIFEY IN STRONG SUPPORTER- THE
A UNIVERSAL BASIC INCOME.
BRANCH THANK YOU. ALIVE. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. LINE. FOUR HUNDRED FORTY
ONE. BOB MICHAEL RAT AGAIN ON
BEHALF SANTA CLARA COUNTY BOARD
OF SUPERVISORS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
THANK YOU. N. MADAM CHAIR THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR. IT'S
MY UNDERSTANDING THAT THERE'S
NO PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES- IS THERE ANY A
PUBLIC OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM.
THE NINE. DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION TO THE REMOTE
TESTIMONY STATION. OKAY OR DO
WE HAVE ANY- PUBLIC OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO SB
SEVEN THREE NINE PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN. ONE SEVEN ZERO. LINE
FOUR HUNDRED NINE YEAR MIKE IS
OPEN. WHY FOUR HUNDRED NINE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI MY NAME IS
TJ INTERNATIONAL MILITARY THE
CUTS CONGESTION. AND I SUPPORT-
I THE FOUR S. B. S. THREE NINE
AND I ALSO LEARNED THAT DELAY-
I AIN'T HER I AM LISTENING A
LOT OF STORIES AND THERE'S A
LOT OF THE MOTION PICTURE THANK
YOU MA'AM ANALYSTS ARE CALLING
FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THAT TIME.
THANK YOU OPERATOR DO YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
SOMEONE BRENT- MY FIRST HOME
AFTER BEING BORN WAS A FOSTER
HOME AND THEN IT WAS ADOPTED BY
A FAMILY THAT DID FOSTER CARE
FOR TWENTY SIX YEARS HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF THESE GOING UP
AND I JUST WANT TO COMMEND THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IF YOU ARE LOOKING FOR
CO AUTHORS I WOULD BE HAPPY TO
JOIN I THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT PRIORITY FOR
CALIFORNIA AND I'M PROUD TO BE
SITTING ON THIS COMMITTEE TODAY
LOOKING AT THIS BILL SO THANK.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD BE
HONORED TO HAVE YOU ON BOARD AS
CO AUTHOR. THANK YOU. HER
QUESTION GO AHEAD. THE SENATE
TO PUT THIS ON I WONDER I VSO
UNIVERSE ONLINE BUSY OF ALL
ONCE A DOLLAR SO IT WOULD BE-
GIVEN ALL THE FOR THOSE SO. A
CATEGORY REGARDLESS OF THEIR-
INCOME AT THAT TIME. IT CAN YOU
REPEAT THAT THE QUESTION. OKAY
ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS WILL BE
GIVEN OUT TO OR THE FOSTER
CHILDREN- THERE ARE- YEAH IN
THE EXTENDED THE FOSTER CARE
PROGRAM REGARDLESS OF WHAT
THEIR INCOME. YES THIS IS AND
RIGHT THIS IS THIS IS
ESSENTIALLY- AZAR EMANCIPATED
THE ROLE LONGER THEY NO LONGER
QUALIFY FOR EXTENDED FOSTER
CARE- AND AT THAT POINT.
THEY'RE BASICALLY ON THEIR OWN
WITHOUT FAMILY SUPPORT- LIKE A
LOT OF NON FOSTER NON CHILD
WELFARE- CHILDREN HAVE A BILL
DO NOT ALL BUT MANY DO- BUT IT
IS REGARDLESS OF INCOME. AND
IT'S PERSON PURPOSELY NOT
PRESCRIPTIVE IN THAT REGARD WE
HAVE FOSTER YOUTH WHO HAVE
LITTLE OR NO INCOME BUT OUR
STUDENTS- PERHAPS- THEY ARE
STUDENTS IN NEED. TO MAKE A
DECISION TO USE. THE DOLLAR
SLUMPED TO SUPPORT THEIR
EDUCATION IN SOME MANNER OF
BOOKS. COULD BE THAT THERE ARE-
THEY DON'T NEED HELP WITHOUT
THE NEED HELP WITH HOUSING THE
ROOM TO RENT A ROOM. OF MONEY
TO RENT A ROOM COULD BE THAT
THEY HAVE A ROOM- AND THEY
HAVE. OTHER EDUCATION GOING
ALONG FINE ON A SCHOLARSHIP OR
SOME OTHER WAY BUT THE- THEY'RE
HAVING. ANXIETY AROUND FOOD AND
NUTRITION ISSUES AND THEY NEED
THE MONEY FOR THAT SO IT'S
PURPOSELY- AN AUGMENTATION
OBVIOUSLY NOT A LOT OF MONEY
WITH AN AUGMENTATION- TO THEIR
BASIC INCOME- TO VOTE FOR THEM
TO NOT ONLY BE EMPOWERED. TO
MAKE DECISIONS ABOUT BUT ALSO
TO GIVE THEM THE LATITUDE- IN A
NON PRESCRIPTIVE WAY- TO NOT
ONLY MAKE THE DECISION THAT
THEY NEED TO MAKE BUT TO PUT
THE MONEY IN THE RIGHT. PLACE
BASED ON THEIR CIRCUMSTANCES.
THANK HAS. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I THINK IT MOMENT IN
THIS THIRD. THROUGH THE CHAIR
MAN. SENATOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH I THINK THAT'S MIKE IS A
I'VE BEEN BIG OF A FOR FOSTER
SYSTEM AND FOSTER CARE MY
CONCERN IS WITH- THE THOUSAND
DOLLARS MAKING SURE THAT YOU
KNOW WHAT IT'S USED FOR THE
RIGHT PURPOSE SO YOU TALK ABOUT
THAT YOU KNOW WHAT ABOUT
PERHAPS THINKING. GREAT YOU
NEVER GONNA GIVE THIS THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND YOU COULD PUT IT
TOWARDS YOUR HOUSING YOU COULD
PORTED TOWARDS YOUR BOOKS YOU
CAN PUT IT TOWARDS YOU KNOW
PAYING YOUR INSURANCE BUT
THERE'S A PLACE LIKE A CATEGORY
OR SOMETHING. BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THIS IS ACTUALLY GOING TO
BE UTILIZED WHERE WHERE IT
NEEDS TO BE AND YOU KNOW WITH
GOOD FAITH OF THE ASSUMING
GOING WHERE WE'RE GOING TO
EXPECT THESE PEOPLE TO KNOW.
YOU KNOW WHAT WHEN YOU'RE
GROWING UP EVEN WHEN YOU'RE IN
YOUR EARLY TWENTIES WHETHER
YOU'RE AT A FOSTER HOME YOU'RE
NOT. THEY'RE NOT TAUGHT THE
SKILLS SOMETIMES A REALLY
KNOWING WE IN A WIDE
COMMONSENSE WE REALLY SHOULD BE
PUTTING IN HERE TO A GIRL
LITTLE BIT OLDER WE REALIZE.
OKAY I SHOULD SAVE MY MONEY OR
PAY MY BILLS FIRST BEFORE I GO
IN I HAVE FUN. SO I THINK
THAT'S JUST IT I. IT'S NOT THE
MONEY. IT'S JUST MAKING IT SO
THAT YOU KNOW THEY HAVE OPTIONS%
AND GOOD CHOICES FOR DOUBTS OF
THE UNDERSTAND THAT'S HOW YOU
TRAIN THEM. GOING GREAT THIS IS
A GREAT PLACE I'M GONNA PUT IT.
TOWARDS A HOUSING ART. TO
TBILISI OR MAYBE IT'S A CAR.
YOU KNOW IN MAKING A PAYMENT
BUT IF WE GIVE THEM-
COMMONSENSE OPTIONS TO PUT THE
MONEY IN WE COULD SEE THE
MONEY'S BEING USED. YOU KNOW
RIGHT. I THINK THAT'S MY ONLY
CONCERN IS THAT IT'S REALLY UP
TO THEIR DISCRETION. AND THAT
WE COULD HELP THEM ALONG
EDUCATE THEM AS WELL. AND HOW
TO BE- YOU KNOW. WHEN IT COMES
FINANCES BEING GOOD YOU KNOW BE
LIKEGOOD IDEAS GOOD LEADERS
WHEN IT COMES FINANCES. WELL
ONE THING SETS. BACK IN. BILL
FINALLY RE. THINGS OF BUILT IN.
OF THE- IS OF. THE VSS WILL.
WILL WORK- WITHOUT PRESCRIBING
A TO WORK TO MAKE AVAILABLE. OF
CREDIT COUNSELING FINANCIAL
COUNSELING MENTORSHIP. OF
NUMBER PROGRAMS. PART OF THOSE
IDEAS CAME. YOU KNOW WERE
INCUBATED- AT THE COUNTY LEVEL
WHERE IT'S EASIER TO TEST THOSE
THINGS. WITHOUT REQUIRING IT.
BECAUSE THE THOUGHT HEARING
THERE IS A PHILOSOPHY IN A- I
WILL KNOWLEDGE SAID. SOME MAY
NOT BUY INTO IT OR NOT BUY INTO
IT YET- THAT WHAT WE HAVE DONE
FOR YEARS AND YEARS. IS TRIED
TO BE VERY VERY PRESCRIPTIVE.
WITH SOCIAL SERVICE- WITH
SOCIAL SERVICES- WITH THIS
POPULATION. AND WE FAIL- 50% OF
THEM ARE NOT GRADUATING. HIGH
SCHOOL SO NOW. THEY'RE
LAUNCHING INTO THIS. THIS ERA
OF EMANCIPATION WITHOUT EVEN. A
HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA OR THOSE
SKILLS THAT THEY NEED. WE THEN
SAY. LOOK WE DON'T WANT YOU
HOMELESS. SO WE'LL GIVE YOU A
HOUSING VOUCHER BUT THEY DON'T
ALL NEED A HOUSING VOUCHER SOME
DO AND SOME DON'T. IT'S OF THE
DANGER. EVEN THOUGH I
UNDERSTAND. YOU ARE SORT OF
SUGGESTING. A FAIRLY. LENGTHY
LIST. HI HERE YOU RIGHT AS TO.
WHAT SUITABLE. EXPENDITURES
ARE- AT SOME POINT YOU. RUN THE
RISK OF ESSENTIALLY. TOM UP AS
THESE AS A STAY IN THESE CHILL-
THE YOU KNOW AS SAYING WE KNOW
EXACTLY. WHAT ISGOING TO SORT
OF DELIVER YOU THROUGH
TRANSITION USE THE MONEY THIS
WAY AND NOT ANOTHER WAY. IN OF
COURSE WE DON'T REALLY DO THAT-
SUCCESSFULLY. YOU KNOW WITH
MUCH OF OUR- QUOTE WELFARE
SYSTEM OR SOCIAL SERVICE SYSTEM
WITH THAT. BY AND LARGE ARE
SICK OUR EFFORTS TO TRY TO
DICTATE TO PEOPLE HOW THEY
SHOULD LIVE THEIR LIVES. YOU
DON'T HAVE BEEN A FAILURE IN
THIS STATE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
SO THIS IS SOMETHING DIFFERENT
IT'S SAYING- YOU YOU MAKE YOUR
DECISIONS. BUT LIKE ADULTS WAS
GONNA WORK A 100% THE TIME WITH
EVERYONE WITHOUT MISTAKES NO
BUT- WE DON'T HAVE MUCH OF A
HIGH BAR RIGHT NOW- TO BEAT OR
TO- TO REACH IN IN TERMS OF
DOING BETTER THAN WE'RE ALREADY
DOING. IN IN THE BEST EVIDENCE
THAT WE HAVE RIGHT NOW IS THE
SANTA CLARA COUNTY MALL DIDN'T
DO ANYTHING TO SKEW THE RESULTS
SEVENTY TWO FOSTER YOUTH. I
THINK THAT ONE DROP OUT FOR
GOOD REASON THE REST OF THEM-
AFTER EUROPE ALL BEEN
EVALUATED. WITH INDICATORS-
PRESENT THAT THE BASED ON
PREVIOUS BASELINE POPULATIONS
OF STATE OUT OF INCARCERATION
OF MENTAL HEALTH ISSUES HAVE
NOT DROPPED OUT OF SCHOOL AND
ARE NOT HOMELESS SO. IT SEEMS
TO BE WORKING THIS IS A PILOT
TWO ONE EMPHASIZE THAT FOR
THOSE WHO ARE CONCERNED WHAT IF
IT DOESN'T WORK ON A STATEWIDE
LEVEL WELL. I THINK WILL BE
SUNSETTING- THE PROGRAM
NOBODY'S GONNA WANT TO RENEW
THE PROGRAM AT SUNSET AT THAT
POINT I THINK THAT'S THE REAL
SAFEGUARD. ULTIMATELY TO THE-
TO THE CONCERNS THAT YOU'RE
RAISING ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND I
DO APPRECIATE THE CONCERNS AND
I DO AND I UNDERSTAND IT'S A
THREE YEAR PILOT PROGRAM. IS
THERE ANY WAY OF JUST YOU KNOW
KEEPING TRACK BUT AFTER YEAR-
INSTEAD OF WAITING FOR THREE
YEARS AND IT REALLY YOU KNOW IT
IF THERE'S A PLACE OF SAYING
VERY WHERE DID YOU PUT YOU KNOW
BECAUSE THIS IS A GREAT STUDY
PROGRAM WHERE IS IT THAT YOU
DID. YOU KNOW PLACE YUR BODY
IT GET IF IT'S UP TO THEIR
DISCRETION THERE SHOULD BE A
PROBLEM LET US KNOW YOU KNOW
WHERE YOU'RE PUTTING IT. IN IN
THERE IS A VALUATION BUILT IN
IN THERE IS VALUATION AT THE
ONE YOUR POINT- YEAH AND
ALTHOUGH. WHAT I'M SAYING ABOUT
BEING NON PRESCRIPTIVE SOUNDS
LIKE MAYBE WE ARE GOING TO
EVALUATE THERE IS A DIFFERENCE
WE WILL EVALUATE. IS SO THE
IDEA OF NOT TELLING SOMEONE
SPECIFICALLY WHETHER TO BUY
SHOES OR BUY FOOD. IS WHAT WE
WANT. BUT IT'S STILL OKAY TO
ASKING AT THE END OF THE YEAR
DID YOU BUY SHOES OR DID YOU
BUY FOOD AND SO. WE'LL HAVE
THOSE DATA POINTS ONE THE
BEAUTIFUL THING ABOUT THIS
POPULATION. IF YOU WERE EVER
GOING TO DO. YOU BE I. WITH THE
POPULATION- IT WOULD BE THIS.
BECAUSE WE HAVE A LIFETIME. OF
AGGREGATED AND DISAGGREGATED
DATA ON THEM ALREADY IN OUR
COUNTY SYSTEMS. SO YOU. YOU YOU
WERE ABLE TO TAKE THIS ONE YOUR
POINT. ND HOPEFULLY A SECOND
THIRD YOUR POINT IF THE
PROGRAM- IS APPROVED FOR THREE
YEARS AND FUNDED FOR THREE
YEARS. AND REALLY- AND REALLY-
DO NOT ONLY AN EVALUATION BUT
IN ALL THE VALUATION RELATIVE
TO WHAT KIND OF RESULTS THE
SYSTEM IS PRODUCED IN THE PAST
ON ON THE SAME USE FOR THAT
MATTER. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
THEM. I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU. AND. WE HAVE A MOTION BY
ITS CINNAMON ARAMBULA AND A
SECOND BY ASSEMBLY MEMBRANE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON HI WALDRON
I'D DAVIES. DAVIES NOT VOTING
ARAMBULA RYAN I AND I ACTUALLY
CHOI AYE STONE STONE I'D LOVE
TO DO THAT THE DUBAI WARD. OKAY
RIDLEY. CAN WILL GET FIVE VOTES
FOR EVEN OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS. CENTRE HER TADO THANK
YOU FOR YOUR PATIENCE. YOU
READY TO PRESENT ON SBONE OH
EIGHT. YES I. ASSEMBLY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. OKAY WELL THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS
TODAY I'M HERE TO PRESENT SB
ONE ZERO EIGHT THE HUMAN RIGHT
TO FOOD ACT. COLLEAGUES WE ARE
ON THE ROAD. WE ARE ON THE
VERGE OF A FOOD CRISIS. A THIRD
OF GLOBAL PRODUCTION IS AT RISK
DUE TO CLIMATE CHANGE ALONE AND
ENERGY MAKES UP 19% OF THE
AMERICAN FOOD SUPPLY CHAIN.
WITH INCREASING PRICES AND
ENERGY WERE ALSO SEEN FOOD COST
INCREASE. IN CALIFORNIA WE'RE
FACING A DROUGHT THAT IS
ALREADY PUTTING FOOD OUT OF
PRODUCTION. I LET'S NOT FORGET
DISEASE CROP DISEASES NOT ONLY
A THREAT TO OUR FOOD. BUT IT'S
ALSO TO OUR OWN HEALTH. JUST
LIKE THE COVER NINETEEN
PANDEMIC WE ARE UNPREPARED FOR
A FOOD CRISIS WE NEED FOOD
RESILIENCE AND ADAPTIVE
CAPACITY BECAUSE FOOD IS HEALTH
AND FOOD IS LIFE. CALIFORNIA
NOT ONLY FEEDS THE STATE WE
FEED THE WORLD THE WORLD IS
RELYING ON CALIFORNIA TO KEEP
MANKIND FOOD SECURE. TODAY AS
AND TODAY IT IS IMPORTANT AS IT
IS AS IT WILL BE TOMORROW. AS
CALIFORNIA'S POPULATION GROWS
AS THE CLIMATE GETS WARMER AND
AS LAND USAGE CHANGES OUR
ABILITY TO KEEP PACE AND FEED
THE RESIDENTS OF THE STATE WILL
BE CHALLENGED. WE MUST PREPARE
FOR THESE CHALLENGES AND THAT'S
WHY I'M INTRODUCING SB ONE ZERO
EIGHT. SB ONE ZERO EIGHT
REQUIRE STATE AGENCIES TO
CONSIDER THE HUMAN RIGHT TO
FOOD AS A CREATE AMEND OR ADOPT
REGULATIONS BUT IT ALSO
REQUIRES A REPORT ON THE
CURRENT AND FUTURE STATUS OF
FOOD. FOOD PRODUCTION AND FOOD
ASSISTANCE SB ONE ZERO EIGHT
DECLARES IT THE ESTABLISHED
POLICY OF CALIFORNIA THAT EVERY
HUMAN BEING HAS THE RIGHT TO
ACCESS TO EFFICIENT HEALTHY AND
AFFORDABLE FOOD. WE MUST MAKE
SURE THAT PEOPLE IN OUR STATE
ARE FED NOW AND IN THE FUTURE.
AND S. B. ONE ZERO EIGHT WORKS
TOWARDS THAT END TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I HAVE.
DAVID GUEST FROM THE BRIDE OF
THE WORLD AND PAULA PS BECAUSE
FROM THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. THANK
YOU SENATOR OPERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR THE
WITNESSES. PLANTER OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. DID YOU DID YOU GET
DID YOU LIKE THE WORKERS YES
SIR. THANK YOU WELL AS
MISUNDERSTOOD I'M DAVID AND I'M
NOT SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
BREAKING THE WORLD'S THE WORLD
IS A NETWORK OF CHURCHES AND
PASTORS AND COMMUNITY LEADERS
AROUND THE COUNTRY AND HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE HAVE TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND MEMBERS WE WORK WITH
OVER THREE THOUSAND CHURCHES
UNITED IN CALLING FOR A RIGHT
TO IT AND TO WORK WITH ELECTED
LEADERS TO END HUNGER. SO WHAT
ARE YOU KNOW I MEAN HUNGER HAS
QUADRUPLED DURING THE PANDEMIC.
AND WHEN WE RECOGNIZE THAT THE
HELPFROM DEMOCRATS FOSTERED
EIGHT HUNDRED PANDEMIC. ONE WE
UNDERSTAND HUNGER AND FOOD
INSECURITY AS PUBLIC HEALTH
ISSUES. AND SECURING THE RIGHT
TO ACCESS TO EFFICIENT
AFFORDABLE AND HEALTHY FOOD
WITH DIGNITY. BECOMES A MORAL
AND ECONOMIC IMPERATIVE. SPREE
PANDEMIC HUNGER INCLUDED
SECURITY COSTS THE US ECONOMY
OVER A ONE HUNDRED AND SIXTY
BILLION DOLLARS IN POOR HEALTH
OUTCOMES AN ADDITIONAL
HEALTHCARE. AND I WAS PRETTY
CONDEMNING. CALIFORNIA LOST ONE
POINT FIVE MILLION JOBS THE
PANDEMIC AND HUNGER HAS SPIKED
IN MANY COMMUNITIES. FOR
EXAMPLE FOOD BANK IN ALAMEDA
SERVICE FIFTY TO SIXTY FAMILY
TODAY CREE PANDEMIC BUT REACHED
SEVEN HUNDRED AND FIFTY TO
EIGHT HUNDRED AND FIFTY
FAMILIES TODAY DURING LAST
SUMMER WHEN CONGRESS HIGHER
WITH KIDS NOT IN SCHOOL. WE
BRIEFLY GOING TO WHERE THE
FEDERAL. PROGRAM THAT INVEST IN
MOTHERS AND YOUNG CHILDREN
STUDY AFTER STUDY HAS SHOWN
WHAT IT COULD BE QUITE COST
EFFECTIVE BY INVESTING IN
IMPROVING. NUTRITION AND HEALTH
FOR LOW INCOME FAMILIES WHICH
LEADS TO BETTER PUBLIC HEALTH
AND HIGHER ACADEMIC ACHIEVEMENT
IN SCHOOLS. I BELIEVE SB ONE OH
EIGHT WILL PROVE AS COST
EFFECTIVE AS WELL. BY HELPING
HER STAY BECOME HEALTHIER AND
MORE ROBUST ECONOMICALLY IN THE
MONTHS AND YEARS TO COME AS WE
RECOVER FROM THE PANDEMIC. THE
BOTTOM LINE IS THAT. ARE
AFFECTS A GROWING NUMBER OF
CALIFORNIANS BEFORE TOO MANY OF
THEM ARE CHILDREN. CALIFORNIANS
NEED THE STATE TO SET A
STANDARD OF A RIGHT TO FOOD AND
S. B. ONE AWAITS. RIGHT TO SUE
THAT CAN BE THAT STANDARD.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MISTER
CHEST. WE HAVE MISS SMITH
ONLINE. HI WE HAVE GOT THE-
WHAT THE COUNTY OFFERED DIRECT
IS THAT OKAY IF I GO AHEAD AND
GO. YES IS METHYLATED SMITH.
I'M SORRY HI POLICY F. NORTH
SIDE OF THE POLICY AHEAD OF
AHEAD MY MISTAKE SORRY. NO
PROBLEM AT ALL THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ALL OF THE US GOES ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF SB ONE
AWAIT. THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
FOR CARRYING THIS BILL
DECLARING THAT EVERY HUMAN
BEING HAS THE RIGHT TO ACCESS
TO SUFFICIENT AND HEALTHY FOOD.
THE WTA HAS CONTINUOUSLY
ADVOCATED FOR POLICY AND
PRACTICE CHANGES THAT INCREASE
NEW ENTRANCE TO THE CALPERS
PROGRAM THE LARGEST FOOD
PROGRAM IN CALIFORNIA BY
REDUCING BARRIERS TO
PARTICIPATION AND REDUCING
PAPERWORK AND TURN IN THE
PROGRAM. ADDITIONALLY RECENT
BUDGET ACTIONS MAKE MAJOR
INVESTMENTS IN PROGRAMS THAT
WILL INCREASE SUIT SECURITY AND
ACCESS. THIS BILL IS A
CONTINUATION OF THOSE EFFORTS
AND IMPROVED INFORMATION
SHARING ON THE CURRENT AND
FUTURE STATUS OF FOOD FOOD
PRODUCTION. AND FOOD ASSISTANCE
ACROSS THE STATE. ALL
CALIFORNIANS. RELIABLE ACCESS
TO NUTRITIOUS FOOD. WE HOPE
YOU'LL JOIN US IN SUPPORT OF SB
ONE AWAIT. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. CAN REALLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. DO YOU HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT
AND RTS STATION. OKAY OPERATOR
DO YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINE. IT DOESN'T SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW
FOR US THE CLERK WILL GO FIRST
TO LINE FOR TWENTY FOUR PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS NICOLE
BORNEMANN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NEXT WE
HAVE ONE ONE TWENTY EIGHT. HI
THIS IS SERRA THE AS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. ONE FOUR
FIFTY EIGHT. NINE FOUR FIVE
EIGHT YOUR LINE IS OPEN. NEXT
WE HAVE LINE FOR SIXTY FOUR.
HELLO THIS IS JENNIFER POTS
WITH THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT WELL. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. AND HERE WE
HAVE NO FURTHER LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU OPERATOR. AND MY
UNDERSTAND WE HAVE ONE WITNESS-
IN OPPOSITION- JULIA JORDAN
WITH LEADERSHIP COUNCIL-
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
A LINE. FOR JULIE JORDAN. I
DON'T SHOW THE LINE CONNECTED
HERE FOR US MANAGER. OKAY THANK
YOU I DO WE HAVE ANY OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM. EIGHTY NINE. DO WE
HAVE ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION AND
RTS STATION. OKAY AN OPERATOR
JUST TO CONFIRM THAT THERE'S NO
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC OPPOSITION ON
THE LINE AND KILL. IF YOU LIKE
TO WISH OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US
ONCE AGAIN ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO
FOR OPPOSITION. WE KNOW LINE'S
GIVEN UP FOR SPENDING CHAIR
THANK YOU OPERATOR I DO WE HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS FOR SENATOR HER
TADO FROM THE COMMITTEE. OKAY
CENTER WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM CHARGES
RESPECTFUL ASTRONOMICAL THANK
YOU. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE CALDERON. I'M SORRY
WE DON'T HAVE A SECOND WE HAVE
A. THE MOTION BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PHILLIP- THAT. SECOND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIES THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
ASSEMBLY APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. CALDERON AYE
CALDERON AYE DAVIES DAVIES I
ARAMBULA. BRIAN BRIAN I CHOI.
CHOI AYE STONE DOWN I'D LOVE TO
DO A THE LEAD TO DO I'D WARD.
AT FIVE SEVEN ZERO ONE LEAVE IT
OPEN HOLDEN COUGH ABSENT
MEMBERS. SIX SIX ZERO I'M SORRY
OKAY CENTER HER TADO WHICH LIKE
TO PRESENT ON THREE NINETY
THREE. OF COURSE. SO THREE
NINETY THREE FOR FARMWORKERS
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE ACT-
CALIFORNIANS FARMWORKERS HAVE
BEEN ESSENTIAL TO KEEPING FOOD
ON THE TABLE AND BOTH
CALIFORNIA AND THE REST OF THE
NATION. HOWEVER HOWEVER MANY OF
THE SAME ESSENTIAL FARMWORKERS
SUFFER GREATLY FROM INEQUITABLE
TREATMENT DURING THE PANDEMIC
FACING HIGHER RATES OF EXPOSURE
TO COVER NINETEEN. AND A LACK
OF ACCESS TO FEDERAL AID I
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED HUNDREDS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FEDERAL
FUNDING DURING THE COVERAGE A
CRISIS THE FEDERAL FUNDS WERE
EARMARKED TO CREATE MORE
ACCESSIBLE CHILD CARE VOUCHER
SLOTS FOR CENTRAL WORKERS. SO
THAT THEY COULD CONTINUE THEIR
VITAL WORK WITHOUT WORRYING
ABOUT THEIR CHILDREN'S CARE.
DUE TO AN OUTDATED LAW
CALIFORNIA'S CRITICAL
FARMWORKERS LOST OUT ON ROUGHLY
FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND AN
ADDITIONAL. CHILDCARE VOUCHERS
FROM FAMILIES TO ACCESS. TO
CORRECT THIS SB THREE NINE
THREE ALIGN TO STATE ONLY
MIGRANT CHILD CARE PROGRAM
FUNDING STREAM. WHAT OTHER
VOUCHER BASED PROGRAMSTHIS
BILL ALSO ADDRESSES THE UNIQUE
OPERATIONAL COST OF THIS
PROGRAM SUCH AS THE NEED TO
MAINTAIN. FIVE ADDITIONAL
SATELLITE OFFICES FOR FIELD
WORKERS STRIKES US. AGRICULTURE
IS THE BACKBONE OF OUR
COMMUNITY. THOSE WHO OPERATE
THEIR LIVES TO PROVIDE THE FOOD
WE EAT MUST HAVE ADEQUATE
ACCESS TO CHILD CARE TO
CONTINUE TO FEED OUR NATION.
CALIFORNIA SHOULD DO WHAT IT
CAN TO SUPPORT THE NEEDS OF
OURS ARE CENTRAL FARMWORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. AND TODAY I
HAVE ONE WITNESS TWENTY
REMOTELY- TO PROVIDE. A
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE ON THE
BILL SUSANNA GEIGER PROGRAM
MANAGER FOR THE COMMUNITY
ACTION. PARTNERSHIP OF KERN
COUNTY. AND SHE'S OUR WITNESS I
AM MY APOLOGIES AND FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE FOR
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE. AT THE
NEED- MITCHELL LEVY COLBORNE
CEO OF THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE A PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU SENATOR.
SECOND OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR MISS MADONNA.
YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON CAN YOU
HEAR ME YES. MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS TO
EXAMINE HANYA AND I AM THE
PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR FOR THE
MIKE AND ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT
PROGRAM WITH COMMUNITY ACTION
PARTNERSHIP OF CURRENT. OKAY L.
A. B. PROGRAM WAS CREATED IN
NINETEEN NINETY NINE TO BRIDGE
THE GAP BETWEEN THE SERVICES
THAT THE GENERAL. CHILD
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS PROVIDE
AND THE NEED TO THE MIGRANT
COMMUNITY. BEFORE THE CREATION
OF THE MY GRANNY P. PROGRAM THE
MINING COMMUNITY HAS LITTLE OR
NO ACCESS TO CHILD DEVELOPMENT
SERVICES. INMIGRANTE P. PROGRAM
PROVIDES. MIGRANT FAMILIES THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE THEIR
MIGRATORY LIFESTYLE BY
PROVIDING FREE OR LOW COST
CHILDCARE SERVICES ACTING
MIGRATED CALIFORNIA FOLLOWING
AGRICULTURAL WORK. OUR PROGRAM
IS NOT EVEN NOW AND IT'S NOT
TEMPORARY WE CONTINUE TO
PROVIDE SERVICES TO MIGRANT
FAMILIES ALL YEAR LONG. BECAUSE
THEY MIGRATE WHERE THEIR WORK.
MANY FAMILIES MIGRATE TO AREAS
OF THE STATE WHERE THEY DON'T
KNOW ANYONE. OUR PROGRAMS THAT
PROVIDE THEM WITH LOCAL
RESOURCES TO MEET THEIR CHILD
CARE NEEDS AS WELL AS OTHER
NEEDS SUCH AS FOOD CLOTHING AND
HOUSING. HAPPY IF YOU'RE ONLY A
MINISTER OF THE MIGRATING P.
PROGRAM IN THE ENTIRE STATE.
THE PROGRAM CONTRACT REQUIRES
THAT WE MAINTAIN THINK OPPOSITE
TO THE CONTROL VALLEY AFFECT
ENTRY POINTS TO THE POGRAM.
OUR MAIN OFFICES IN BAKERSFIELD
IN KERN COUNTY AND WE STAFF
OFFICERS IN THE COUNTY THE
FRESNO TULARE KINGS MEDICARE
AND RESPECT. ONE FAMILY
AVAILABLE THEY'RE ABLE TO
MIGRATE ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
FOLLOWING AGRICULTURAL WORK AND
THEIR CHILD CARE AND SUPPORT
SERVICES CONTINUE. OUR CASE
MANAGER THE FIFTH FAMILIES TO
ACCESS RESOURCES AND HEALTHCARE
OPTIONS ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA.
WE CURRENTLY ARE SERVING
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
FAMILIES ALL OVER THE STATE. SB
THREE NINE THREE RECOGNIZES THE
UNIQUE NEEDS OF OUR MINOR
COMMUNITY. OUR MARKET COMMUNITY
THAT WORKS DAY IN AND DAY OUT
TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
TO FRUIT VEGETABLES MEAT
PRODUCTS AND ALL OTHER ACT
MARDI SIX FEET THE RESIDENTS OF
CALIFORNIA. OUR GREAT NATION IN
THE WORLD. THE BILL PARKER
PROGRAM FUNDING STRUCTURE
NEEDED TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
MIGRANT FAMILIES CHILD CARE
SUPPORT SERVICES. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS IN SUPPORT OF SB THREE
NINE THREE AND IF THE. COURT OF
OUR MAJOR COMMUNITY THANK YOU.
THANK MISS MADONNA- DO WE HAVE
ANY TO PER SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
AS. I'VE SEEN NINE DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT
IN THE RTS STATION. OKAY
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINE. IF YOU WISH TO
SHOW SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE
FOLLOWED BY ZERO NOW FOR US.
FIRST WE HAVE THE LINE FOURTEEN
THIRTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIR MEMBERS CRYSTAL
IT OFF FROM BEHALF OF TULARE
COUNTY IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. FINE. FOR SIXTY
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
JAM PACKED WITH THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
FOUR ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FOUR FOUR ZERO YOUR LINE IS
OPEN FOR US. THANK YOU CAN IN
FACT USE ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE NO
FURTHER LINE'S CUTE MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU OPERATOR- WE DO NOT
HAVE THE PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESS FOR THE SPELL- DO WE
HAVE ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. SCENE NINE DO WE HAVE
ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
OPPOSITION AT RTS STATION. OKAY
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC OPPOSITION ON
THE PHONE LINE IN Q. AND THIS
IS JUST FOR PUBLIC OPPOSITION.
WE LIKE TO SHOW YOUR OPPOSITION
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW FOR US ONCE AGAIN IN
OPPOSITION ONE FOLLOWED BY.
ZERO NO LINES GIVING UP
ENFORCEMENT CHAIR THANK YOU
OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE AUTHOR. NO OKAY CENTER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. I
THINK AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
HER NOTEBOOK THANK YOU OKAY WE
HAVE A MOTION BY SOMETHING
WOMAN DAVIES IN A SECOND BY
SOMEONE ARAMBULA. THE MISSION
IS TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
EDUCATION COMMITTEE CALDERON
AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES. DAVIES
I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI BRIAN.
BRIAN I CHOI. CHOICE AYE STONE
AYE STONE AYE AVAILABLE TO US.
PHILIP DO II WARD. OKAY THE IN
THAT SEVEN TWO ZERO AND LEAVE
THAT ON CALL FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
AND I BELIEVE YOU HAVE ONE MORE
BILL SENATOR OKAY I DO THANK
YOU IRAQ SO SB FOUR SIX FOUR
MODERNIZES THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY FOR STATE FUNDED
NUTRITION BENEFITS TWENTY ONE
INELIGIBLE FOR CALL FIRST
SOLELY TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. PRIOR TO THE COVER
NINETEEN PANDEMIC APPROXIMATELY
ONE IN TEN CALIFORNIANS
EXPERIENCE FOOD INSECURITY. THE
PANDEMIC AND RESULTING ECONOMIC
CRISIS HAS EXACERBATED FOOD
INSECURITY ACROSS THE STATE BUT
PARTICULARLY AMONG LOW WAGE
IMMIGRANTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS DACA
RECIPIENTS TEMPERPROTECTED
STATUS HOLDERS AND CERTAIN B.
CELL HOLDERS ARE EXCLUDED FROM
FEDERAL CALFRESH. AND ARE STATE
FUNDED CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM THESE
EXCLUSIONS FORCE IMMIGRANT
HOUSEHOLDS TO MAKE IMPOSSIBLE
CHOICES BETWEEN BUYING
GROCERIES AND COVERING THE COST
OF RENT OR OTHER BASIC NEEDS.
THIS LIMITS OUR ABILITY TO
ACHIEVE ECONOMIC SECURITY AND
UPWARD MOBILITY AND CHRONIC
DISEASES SUCH AS HEART DISEASE
OBESITY DIABETES AND HIGH BLOOD
PRESSURE DISPROPORTIONATELY
AFFECT INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE FOOD
INSECURE. SB FOUR SIXTY FOUR
MODERNIZES THE CALIFORNIA FOOD
ASSISTANCE PROGRAM EXPANDING
ELIGIBILITY. FOR STATE FUNDED
NUTRITION BENEFITS TO ANYONE AS
AN ELIGIBLE FOR CALFRESH. DUE
SOLELY TO THE IMMIGRATION
STATUS IN DOING SO THE BILL
PROVIDES GREATER FOOD SECURITY
TO LOW INCOME IMMIGRANT WORKERS
HELPING LIFT THEM OUT OF
POVERTY AS CALFRESH IS
PREVENTED DO. LET'S MAKE
CALIFORNIA A CITY WHERE THERE
IS FOOD FOR ALL AND HERE TO
TESTIFY HAVE JARED CALL WITH
NOURISH CALIFORNIA AND DEREK
POLKA OF POLICY AND RESEARCH
MANAGER FOR A LOS ANGELES
REGIONAL FOOD BANK. THANK YOU
SENATOR OPERATOR COULD YOU
PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR YOUR
CALL. YOUR LINE IS OPEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THANK
YOU MADAM CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS YOUR CALL IN YOUR
ADVOCATE WITH NEAREST
CALIFORNIA WE ARE PROUD TO CO
SPONSOR THE BILL ALONG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER WANT TO START BY
THANKING SENATOR HER TADO FOR
HER LEADERSHIP ON SB FOUR SIX
FOUR AND THE FOOD FOR ALL
CAMPAIGN. THIS IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL IT WILL
REDUCE HUNGER AND POVERTY IN
CALIFORNIA BY ENSURING THAT THE
STATE STUDENTS AND PROGRAMS NO
LONGER DISCRIMINATE ON THE
BASIS OF IMMIGRATION STATUS.
WE'VE ALL SEEN HOW THE KOBE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC BECAUSE THE
TREMENDOUS SURGE INCLUDING
SECURITY ACROSS THE STATE. BUT
WE HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT EVEN
BEFORE THE CRISIS MORE THAN ONE
IN TEN CALIFORNIANS FACE HUNGER
AND WE HAD THE HIGHEST CHILD
POVERTY RATE IN THE NATION.
HE'S OUR LONGSTANDING PROBLEMS
THAT HAVE ONLY WORSENED OVER
THE PAST YEAR. AND WE ALSO KNOW
THAT POVERTY IS MUCH MORE
PREVALENT AMONG UNDOCUMENTED
CALIFORNIANS AND THOSE IN MIXED
STATUS FAMILY. CALIFORNIA
BUDGET AND POLICY CENTER
RECENTLY RELEASED AN ANALYSIS
SHOWING THAT AMONG CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES WERE ALL
MEMBERS WERE UNDOCUMENTED OVER
HALF LIVED IN POVERTY IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN. CALFRESH IS OUR SPEAK
MOST EFFECTIVE ANTI HUNGER
PROGRAM AND IT'S ALSO ONE OF
OUR MOST POWERFUL ANTI POVERTY
PROGRAMS IT LIPS OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED THOUSAND CALIFORNIA
CHILDREN OUT OF POVERTY EACH
YEAR. THE CURRENT CALPERS
QUALITY TREAT MANY CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT AT THE INVISIBLE THAT
POLICY DENIES CHILDREN AND HARD
WORKING FAMILIES THE POSITIVE
HEALTH AND ECONOMIC BENEFITS OF
CALFRESH IT EVEN DISPARITIES
BASED ON THE A PHOBIA AND
RACIAL DISCRIMINATION. SB FOUR
SIX FOUR WOULD PERMANENTLY
ADDRESS THE UNJUST IMMIGRANT
EXCLUSION IN THE STATE'S
NUTRITION TAKING THAT BY
EXPANDING ELIGIBILITY AND THE
CALIFORNIA COULD ASSISTANCE
PROGRAM ALL CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE INELIGIBLE FOR CALIBRATION
LEAD YOU TO THEIR IMMIGRATION
STATUS. IT'S BILL IS A BOLD
STEP FORWARD TOWARD TOWARD A
FUTURE WHERE ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE THE FOOD THEY NEED MAKING
UP A MORE EQUITABLE RESILIENT
AND THRIVING STATE. THANKS FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY AND I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU SIR
OPERATOR CAN YOU. OPEN THE LINE
FOR THE NEXT WITNESS. CERTAINLY
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON
OKAY POLICY RESEARCH MANAGER OF
LOS ANGELES REGIONAL FOOD BANK-
I'D LIKE TO START BY THINKING
CHAIR CALDERON OF THE REST OF
THE FUTURE WITH THE COMMITTEE
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK
WITH A MEETING OPERATE
OPPORTUNITY TO FEED ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS YEAH CORECIVIC EACH
SPEAKER SENATOR HER TADO BURKE
SB SIX FOUR SIX FOUR. OUR FLEET
BIG SERVE ALL OF L. A. COUNTY
OFFERING FREE FOOD TO THOSE IN
NEED THE PANDEMIC PRODUCT HUGE
INCREASE IN DEMAND GOING FROM
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
PER MONTH PRIOR TO THE PANDEMIC
TO OVER NINE HUNDRED THOUSAND
COMBAT WITH OVERWHELMING DEMAND
INCREASING DEMAND WOULD HAVE
CUT JOBS WORKING WITH THE L. L.
A. COUNTY A NEW DISTRIBUTION
DEPARTMENT NEW BUILDING IN THE
CITY OF INDUSTRY TO EXPAND OUR
STORAGE AND MAKE A BETTER
PREPARED FOR THE UPTICK IN THE
MAP. HOWEVER WE KNOW THAT ARE
YOU THINK WE'LL NEVER BE ABLE
TO REACH AND BEAT EVERYONE AND
AFTER THAT WE HAVE A CALFRESH
OUTREACH TEAM TO HELP PEOPLE
ENROLL IN THE CALFRESH PROGRAM
WE KNOW ù THAT
PROVIDED BY EMERGENCY FOOD
PROVIDER HOW FRESH PROVIDE
TWENTY SPEAKING HOW QUESTION
VERY POWERFUL TOOL IN THE FIGHT
TO END HUNGER. ACCOMPLISH
OUTREACH TEAM IN THE COUNTRY
SCHOOL ANOTHER KEY PARTNERS TO
SPEAK WITH PEOPLE WHO MIGHT
QUALIFY FOR CALFRESH THIS YEAR
WITH THE PROGRAM IS HELP TO
DETERMINE WHETHER THE MAY
QUALIFY AND IN HELPING GUIDE
THROUGH THE PROCESS- NAVIGATING
THROUGH ANY LANGUAGE BARRIERS A
LARGE PART OF THE CALFRESH
OUTREACH WORK- THE PAST FEW
YEARS HAS BEEN HELPING THE
COMEDIAN- STAND BE PUBLIC
CHARTER TO ALL AND HOW IT DOES
NOT APPLY TO THE CALPERS
PROGRAM. CALPERS SOUTH OKAY
APPLICATION ENROLLMENT PROCESS
ARE ESPECIALLY COMPLICATED FOR
THE FOR PEOPLE IN IMMIGRANT
HOUSEHOLDS IN MIXED STATUS
HOUSEHOLDS DO TO PARADING OF
INCOME AND EXPENSES THE MOST
DIFFICULT PART OF THE HEALING
TOPSHOP REACH AND THIS IS IN
PERSONAL EXPERIENCE AS A FORMER
COPPER SHOT REACH RECORD IS
SPEAKING WITH FAMILIES WHO HAVE
NO IMMIGRANTS ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLD MEMBERS BUT WHO ARE
INCOME ELIGIBLE ELIGIBLE AND
VERY MUCH IN NEAT WE CAN OFFER
INFORMATION ON FOOD PANTRIES
THAT. THEY CAN RECEIVE FREE
FOOD AT A MUCH OF THE OUR
REGION DONE BY FOOD. ADAM EXIST
FOOD. SO THEY ARE ALREADY
RECEIVING FOOD AND BUT ARE
STILL IN NEED OF ADDITIONAL
HELP. S. FOUR SIX FOUR ALLOW
THOSE EITHER ALGAE HOUSE DURING.
CALFRESH MUCH LIKE ANY OTHER
CAL. IN NEED. EVER MOVE
DISCRIMINATION BASED ON AND THE-
STATUS BY OUR- ANY ELIGIBLE
HOUSEHOLDS INDIVIDUALS WHO
APPLY. ALTERNATELY IT TREAT
IMMIGRANTS WITH DIGNITY AND
RESPECT WHEN SEEKING BASIC
SERVICES. I WILL CONTINUE TO
RECOVER AN IMPORTANT INCLUDE
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES THROUGHOUT THE
PANDEMIC AND ADDRESS THEIR
NEEDS. FORTUNATELY FALL FALLING
THROUGH THE CRACKS. THIS. BILL
CAN HELP ADDRESS THE- THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR THE CHAIR COMMITTEE
TIME. I'D BE TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU MISTER
POLKA I DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT PUBLIC
SUPPORT IN THE ROOM. CAN REALLY
ROSENBERGER THAT CHAU IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
ANY PUBLIC SUPPORT AT RTS
STATION. OKAY THANK YOU AN
OPERATOR TO REPEAT ONE IN THE
QUEUE FOR PUBLIC SUPPORT. ON
THE LINE. CERTAINLY THANK YOU
PLEASE PRESS ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO NOW FOR SUPPORT BUT AGAIN
ONE FOLLOWED BY ZERO FIRST WE
HAVE LINE FOR SEVEN SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. ANDREA RIVERA
WHAT THE CALIFORNIA PAN ETHNIC
HEALTH NETWORK AND STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
FIND. FORTY FOUR. NICOLE
WATERMAN ON BEHALF OF THE
CHILDREN'S PARTNERSHIP IN
SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIX FOUR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ONE THREE
NINE FOUR. KELLY BROOK ON
BEHALF OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE TWO EIGHT. HI
THIS IS SERRA DEALS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA WITH ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
SIX SEVEN. GOOD AFTERNOON KELLY
BEING WHAT HEALTH NET AND
CALIFORNIA HEALTH AND WELLNESS
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR THREE NINE. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
JUSTIN ROUNDS ON BEHALF OF PAT
TRANSACTION NETWORK ALSO IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE ONE EIGHT FIVE. GET
SOMEONE ON THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAM
ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU. NINE FOUR EIGHT
THREE. FOUR EIGHTY THREE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN. AND I'M BUT I
WILL BE HAPPY TO CALIFORNIA AS
COALITION IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR EIGHT TWO. CHAMBERS
KEVIN MUSBURGER BE AFTER THE
FIRST FIVE SOLUTION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BEFORE SIX FOUR. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR EIGHT FOUR. PICTURE
SPONSORED POLITECNICO QUESTIONS
AN ONLINE POVERTY AND SPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR EIGHT
FIVE- MICHAEL RAT AGAIN UP
AFTER THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
BOARD OF SUPERVISORS COURT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. THANKS
THREE ZERO SEVEN. MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN EVAN
ON BEHALF OF BURKE AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
EIGHT SIX. SAN MEASURE ON
BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
OFFICE OF EDUCATION SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR FOUR FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
MADELINE COOPER FROM THE OPEN
MARKET MARK ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
NINE FIVE. HELLO SOMETHING
ALIAS PRASAD WOULD CALIFORNIA'S
ASSOCIATION OKAY THANKS IN
SUPPORT OF ASKING QUESTIONS FOR
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
SIX THREE SIX. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON I CHAIR MEMBERS OF.
L. THANK YOU. NINE ONE NINE
SIX. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS MIGHT THE GUERRERO
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
NINE EIGHT. KAREN MEMBERS PRESS
LIKE GET OFF ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT SB FOUR
SIX FOUR THANK YOU. Q. NINE
FOUR NINE ONE. HELLO MY NAME
SIR TELL GARZA WITH THE URBAN
AND ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
INSTITUTE AT OCCIDENTAL COLLEGE
AND WE ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
US BEFORE SIX FOUR THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR NINE
THREE. RANCHO THE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CLIMATE AND
AGRICULTURE NETWORK IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR NINE ZERO.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRADE OUT HERE
MERCED RESIDENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. NINE FOUR NINE SIX.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS BENJAMIN
SHALL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER WE'RE
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR
SIX FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ONE FOUR SIX FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON THIS IS JENNIFER
PARKS THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION
OF SOCIAL WORKERS IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR
EIGHT NINE. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS
IS KEVIN DAVIDSON REPRESENTING
CAN I PACKAGE IT WOULD JUST GO
CALIFORNIA AND TRUMP SUPPORTER
FIFTY FOUR SIX FOUR. THANK YOU.
NINE FOUR EIGHT EIGHT. HI
EVERYONE THIS AFFECT ME MUST
ADDRESS THAT WITH THE NATIONAL
HEALTH FOUNDATION IN LOS
ANGELES IN STRONG SUPPORT SB
FOUR SIX FOUR. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR EIGHT SEVEN. HELLO THIS IS
MARIE SEVENTY MILITANTS
TRAINING A HUNGER COALITION AND
THE HUNGER ADAPTATION NETWORK
IN STRONG SUPPORT OF FOUR SIX
FOUR. THANK YOU. NINE FOUR NINE
FOUR. GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS
RACHEL MONACO CALLING FROM
SECOND HARVEST THE SILICON
VALLEY WE ARE STRONGLY SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIXTY FOUR THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT. HELLO THIS IS GREG SCOTT
WITH RAINBOW BEGINNINGS IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY WE ARE ALSO IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB FOUR SIXTY
FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU. NINE
FOUR SEVEN NINE. HI THIS IS THE
BEST LOCAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
WITHIN FARMING NETWORK AND
STRONG SUPPORTER AS WELL AS
THIRTEEN OF OUR MEMBERS TO ASK
ME TO WITH THEIR NAME ON THE
AGRICULTURAL INSTITUTE OF MARIN
THE COURT ALAMEDA COUNTY
COMMUNITY FOOD BANK CARBON
CYCLE AND COULD YOU THIRTY
COMMUNITY CLASS FIBER SHED
FRIENDS OF THE EARTH. BUT YOU
KNOW COALITION FOR HEALTHY
CALIFORNIA LUTHERAN OFFICE OF
PUBLIC POLICY MARIN FOOD POLICY
COUNCIL NATIONAL YOUNG FARMERS
COALITION YOUR HARD THING ABOUT
AGRICULTURE EDUCATION AND LAST
BUT NOT LEAST UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS WESTERN
STATE COUNCIL. THANK YOU THANK
YOU. NINE FOUR FOUR ZERO. IT
APPEARS ON BEHALF OF FIRST FIVE
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. NINE ONE ONE FOUR.
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAHLAVI ASK OF WITH THE
COUNTY WELFARE DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION IF THE COURT. THANK
YOU. NINE FIVE ZERO ZERO. GOOD
AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS TONY
ROMERO I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
LATINOS UNITED FOR THE AMERICA-
AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF FIFTY
FORTY FOUR THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE ZERO ONE. TRY THE
INDIRECT WAY ADDED ON BEHALF OF
THE CENTRAL VALLEY IMMIGRANT
INTEGRATION COLLABORATIVE
CALLING ON TRUMP BEFORE AND SB
FOUR SIX FOUR THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. LINE FOUR FIVE EIGHT. NINE
FOUR FIVE EIGHT YOUR LINE IS
OPEN. FIND. FIVE ZERO FOUR- BUT
IT WAS AUTHORS AND LOCAL PEOPLE
UP YOU KNOW COALITION FOR
HEALTHY CALIFORNIA AND I'M JUST
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF- SB FOUR
SIX FOUR. THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE ZERO EIGHT. GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TIED
CUNNINGHAM OF THE DISKETTE
ROWBOTTOM ON THIS COLLABORATIVE
OF LOS ANGELES ME ACTION
NETWORK WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT
OF SB FOUR SIX FOUR. THANK YOU
THANK YOU. WE HAVE NO FOR THE
LINES IN Q. MEDICARE THANK YOU
OPERATOR- WE DO NOT HAVE A
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSED ON
THIS BILL- DO WE HAVE ANY
OPPOSITE PUBLIC OPPOSITION IN
THE ROOM. THIRTY NINE. DO WE
HAVE ANY. PUBLIC OPPOSITION RTS
STATION. NO OKAY OPERATOR DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
OPPOSITION ON THE LINE IN Q.
AND FOR THOSE WHO WISH TO. CHAU
OPPOSITION PLACE YOURSELF IN
QUEUE WITH A ONE FOLLOWED BY
ZERO AGAIN IN OPPOSITION ONE
FOLLOWED BY. ZERO YOU HAVE LINE
FOR FIFTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU ADDED I THINK THAT I
THINK I WOULD BE GOING TO
COMPROMISSO PROMOTE THAT I'VE
NEVER MANAGER AND WE ARE IN A
STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB FOUR
SIXTY PARTS OF FOR ALL. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. AND HERE WE HAVE
NO FURTHER LINES INTO AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR I DO
WE HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR
SENATOR HER TADO FROM THE
COMMITTEE. NO. SOME WOMEN.
TWENTY SENATOR WITH AUTO. OKAY.
VOTED NO YES SO ON EUROPEAN
ALLY LOCAL S. B- ONE ALL DAY.
ALL FOR STATE HEALTHY FOOD
ACCESS POLICY. WHICH YOU CLAIM
THE FOR HUMAN BEINGS RIGHT TO
ACCESS TO FOOD WHICH I AGREE.
I'M STRUGGLING WITH IT IS- THE
BILL. IN THAT- THE SPIRIT IS
SELF CONTAINED AND AS THE- I
DON'T WANT TO EIGHT. HOWEVER
YOUR SB. SIX OH FOUR SIX FOUR.
IS- PROVIDING LEGAL ACCESS- TO-
FOOD TO EVERYONE REGARDLESS OF
IMMIGRATION STATUS AT THIS ONE
SPECIFICALLY. NOW MENTIONS THAT
THE REGARDLESS OF IMMIGRATION
STATUS- SOMEONE IMMIGRANT
MYSELF AS A FIRST GENERATION.
AND THEN I EIGHT KNOW THAT WHEN
WE INVITE THE RELATIVE SENT TO
THIS COUNTRY- FOR- THROUGH A
FAMILY CONNECTION IMMIGRATION
APPLICATION. IT DOESN'T REQUIRE
THAT YOU MUST HAVE A GUARANTOR.
THE INSIDER MUSTA GUARANTEE
THAT TIME VIçT THE PERSON-
WHO'S GONNA BE ALLOWED. TO FOR-
TEN MILLION IMMIGRATION WON'T
BE CALM THE PUBLIC CHARGING FOR
FIVE YEARS. SO WHAT ALL THOSE
FOR THOSE WHO ARE COMING.
THROUGH SUCH A LAKER CHANNEL.
WE REQUIRE THE PERSON MOST OF.
NOT BECOME THE PUBLIC CHARGE
FOR FIVE YEARS. AND OF FOR.
NUMEROUS REASONS SO IN THIS
COUNTRY. WE DO HAVE-
UNFORTUNATELY A LOT OF WORK.
EIGHTY NINE IS WITH THE NORTH
DOCUMENTATION. AND ARE YOU MAY
I'M SURE NO 100% EVERY DAY I'VE
DONE ON THE CHANNEL. NEWS
CHANNELS SO. THIS COUNTRIES ARE
STRUGGLING BUT THE DRILL IN THE
SOUTHERN BORDER- WITH THE OPEN
BORDER- MANY MANY PEOPLE ARE.
ATTEMPTING TO CROSS ALL BORDERS.
SO I'M SO AFRAID. THIS BILL IS
SO. ENCOURAGING. TO COMPOUND
THE MORE PROBLEM. BECAUSE WE
ARE SO GENEROUS OF FROM HUMANE
PURPOSES SELL LIQUOR. SB WON'T
ONE OH EIGHT. WE TRY TO HELP
BUT THE- WE'RE NOT GONNA ASK.
ANY IMMIGRATION STATUS YOU JUST
OAK CROSSOVER WILL FEATURE YOU
WERE SENT TO YOU EDGEWOOD
SCHEDULE HOSPITALIZED. NO
MEDICAL ATTENTION SO THIS IS SO
LOCAL COMPOUNDING THE PROBLEM
THAT OUR NATION IS OF CURRENTLY
FACING. SEOUL. THE IMPLICATIONS
YOUR PIN WILL CREATE HAVE YOU
THOUGHT ABOUT. I'M SORRY NOT A
LOT THE LAST PART YOU SAID-
WITHOUT A QUESTION YEAH BOTH
KEY REPEAT THE QUESTION PLEASE.
CHAU I'M AFRAID YOUR BILL WILL
HAVE A NEGATIVEIMPLICATIONS SO
TO IMMIGRATION. OBLONG IN THIS
COUNTRY PARTICULARLY IN THIS
AGE NASA FEW MONTHS AGO.
SEVERAL HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE
TRIED TO CROSS OUR BORDER. JUST
BECAUSE ALL OF ALL. THE BEER IS
A SIMILAR TO THIS SO REGARDLESS
OF IMMIGRATION STATUS SO ORDER
ORDER FEED YOU IS JUST TELL YOU
EDUCATE YOU. HOSPITALIZE YOU A
CERTAIN SUCH A SOUL YOUR P. R.
COMPOUND THE PROBLEM SO HAVE
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT THAT THE
NEGATIVE IMPACT THAT THIS YOUR
BILL WILL MAKE. FOR THE PROBLEM
THAT THAT THIS NATION IS SOFT
FACING. THE BANK TONIGHT LOOK
GREAT CRESCENTA YOU'RE RAISING
THE CONCERN AND IF I MAY I WANT
TO. SHARE WITH YOU I KNOW YOU
MENTIONED THAT- YOUR FIRST
GENERATION HERE AND AMERICA AND
I'M FIRST GENERATION HERE IN
AMERICA TOO MY PARENTS CAME
FROM THE STATE OF SAN LUIS
POTOSI AND THE STATE AND OFFER
MEXICO AND THEY LEFT BECAUSE-
THEY WERE ALSO FACING THE
DROPPED. AT THAT TIME THEY WERE
FACING. POVERTY THEY WERE
FACING LACK OF ACCESS TO FOOD
AND WHAT DO YOU DO. WHEN YOU'RE
IN THAT KIND OF SITUATION. HE
TRIED TO GO AND SEARCH FOR A
PLACE. THAT PROVIDE SOME SENSE
OF SECURITY FOR YOURSELF AND
FOR YOUR FAMILY AND- YOU KNOW
THE REALITY IS THAT THAT- WITH
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE'RE
FACING HERE TODAY AT AMERICA
AND REALLY OF THE WORLD- I AM A
CHANGES BOOKED ABOUT IT EARLIER.
WE COULD BE. YOU KNOW- MIGRANTS
HERSELF. WE COULD BE MOVING WE
COULD BE. IN THAT NEED AND
SHOULD WE BE DENIED ACCESS TO
FOOD BECAUSE WE'RE TRYING TO
ESCAPE AND PROVIDE A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY FOR OURSELVES AND-
TRYING TO SURVIVE. I MEAN
REALLY IT'S A IT'S A MORAL
QUESTION I'M FOR ME THOUGHT.
THE MORAL QUESTION AS- THIS IS
THE RIGHT THING TO DO. NO ONE
SHOULD BE DENIED FOR THAT YEAH
THAT'S THE REASON I STATED I
STRUGGLE WITH YOUR B. L. AND-
EVEN THOUGH THE CHAIN.
TENONTOSAURUS DAHLE HUNGER
PROBLEM UNFORTUNATELY. IRAN DO
YOU THINK AMERICA CAN- FEED THE
ENTIRE WORLD ANYONE HUNGRY CAN
COME OVER AND FEED YOU I KNOW
THEY ARE ENTITLED TO DATE THEY
SHOULD NOT. BE HUNGRY THEY
SHOULD BE SHELTERED AND THE
FED. TO THAT DOCTOR DOES
STORIES ON YOUR BASIC KERR. OUT
RIGHT TO FOOD. SB OUT ONE OH
EIGHT THE- ENCOMPASSES AT THAT
ONE I CAN AGREE UPON BUT THIS
PROGRAM IS A SUBJECT
SPECIFICALLY ENCOURAGING. MORE
ILLEGAL ENDURANCE A TO THIS
COUNTRY AND THAT THAT WOULD
COMPOUND THE OUR NATION'S A
PROBLEM THAT'S TO MY AS A NON
LEGAL CITIZEN OF THIS COUNTRY
I'M CONCERNED FOR MY COUNTRY. I
BUT YOU KNOW WHAT- I RESPECT
YOUR OPINION BUT YOU KNOW FOR
ME IT'S A MATTER OF A MORAL
QUESTION AND LIKE I SAID WE'RE
FREDDIE WERE FACING THE
GREATEST THREAT OF OUR LIFETIME
WHICH IS CLIMATE CHANGE AND THE
REALITY IS THAT WE'RE ALL GOING
TO BE IMPACTED BY FOR. YOU KNOW
FOR- OUR FOOD SCARCITY RIGHT
AND- AND I THINK THAT WE NEED
TO DO A BETTER JOB OF BEING.
COMPASSIONATE AND UNDERSTANDING
AND- YOU KNOW HELPING ONE
ANOTHER OUT DURING A CRISIS TO
SURVIVE AND- THIS BILL DOES ACT
ON IT IT A LOT IT ALLOWS. US TO
PROVIDE. AN OPPORTUNITY TO
INDIVIDUAL TO SURVIVE IT'S
ASKING IF IT'S GIVEN THE
OPPORTUNITY TO A CHILD TO A
MOTHER TO A FATHER. TO SOMEONE
LIKE MY PARENTS- WHO JUST
WANTED AN OPPORTUNITY AND
THAT'S I THINK THE MOST
IMMIGRANTS- WANT. AN
OPPORTUNITY THEY DON'T WANT TO
HAND OUT NOBODY SHOULD BE THERE
IN A PART OF THE SHOULD BE THE
STANDARD FOR. IT'S A BETTER
LIFE THIS IS THIS IS TO HELP
LIFT FAMILIES OUT OF POVERTY
AND- I HOPE IT CAN CONVINCE YOU
AT SOME POINT TO SUPPORT THIS
LEGISLATION I WAS THERE WHEN I
WAS GOING TO SCHOOL. DURING THE
SUMMERTIME I WAS HUNGRY I HAD
NO MONEY. SO I HAD TO GET A JOB
AS A DISHWASHER JUST TO EAT AT
THE RESTAURANT. IF I WASH THE
DISHES SO I'M SURE THEY WILL
FEED MISSILE. IN NEW YORK CITY
WITH DUST DUST AWAY I SURVIVE.
AND THE SAVED A FEW DOLLARS
DOLLAR SO AND FINISHED MY
MASTER'S DEGREE. AND DISOWN SO.
THERE IS SO- HUMANISTIC. OUR
SIDE OF OUR EMOTION ATTACHED
HERE BUT THE. THE DOG CRASHES
SO THAT THAT THIS NATION IS SO
CREATING ARE WEARE INVITING
DID THIS BILL IS SO STIMULATING
MORE ILLEGAL ALIENS IN THIS
COUNTRY THAT THAT THIS IS A BIG
PROBLEM. IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO
EVER COMES. ALL IF NOT SO YOUR
PORCH THUS FAR AND NOT THE
LOCAL CALFRESH WHEN YOU APPLY.
I DON'T THINK THAT THEY ASK FOR
YOUR IMMIGRATION STATUS THEY
CAN BE FED. AND ARE YOU ON ALL
SB ONE ON ONE- EIGHT. PM OR
TAKE CARE OF ALL THIS HARNESS A
SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED BILL FOR
FUND DOCUMENTED TO PEOPLE. SO
THAT IS A LOOK ENCOURAGING MORE
ON NO MATTER HOW OLD WELL WE
MEANS SO COME OVER WILL
FEATURE. THAT'S ENCOURAGING. SO
HOW OLD COUNTRY CAN FEED THE
WORLD I'M IN DESIST ARE NOT.
ABOVE MY HEAD IN ALL SO I DON'T
WANT TO CREATE THE MORE PROBLEM.
THEN MY ASSEMBLY SYMPATHY FOR
HUMAN RIGHTS SO I DON'T THINK
WE CAN. DEBATE US ALL BECAUSE
OF MY EXPERTISE. THANK YOU SOME
WOMEN S. SOMEONE IN A RAMBLING
THAN SOME WOMEN STONE. THANK
YOU SO MUCH- I'M QUITE PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS MEASURE TODAY.
FORTUNATELY FOR TOO MANY OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WHO HAVE SUFFERED
THROUGH SYSTEMIC RACISM AS
EXAMPLES BY OUR INABILITY TO
PASS COMPREHENSIVE IMMIGRATION
REFORM AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL
THERE ARE TOO MANY PEOPLE IN
YOUR COMMUNITY AND MINE WHO
WANTS TREATED WITH THE BASIC
HUMAN RIGHTS THAT THEY DESERVE.
BASIC HUMAN RIGHTS LIKE ACCESS
TO FOOD WHEN YOU COME FROM THE
BREAD BASKET OF THE WORLD AND
SO I'M QUITE. SUPPORTIVE OF
EVERYTHING THAT YOU'RE TRYING
TO DO AND BELIEVE THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR US TO LOVE OUR
NEIGHBORS ALL OF OUR NEIGHBORS
AND TO TREAT THEM EQUALLY AND
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
IMMIGRANTS WHO ARE WORKING ON
THE BREAD BASKET OF THE WORLD'S
TO PUT SUCH FOOD TO A BONE
DENTS ON OUR TABLES. ARE ABLE
TO FILL THEIR TABLES AS WELL
THIS MEASURE WILL MOVE US A
SMALL IRECTION. TOWARDS THAT
DIRECTION AND I'M AWFULLY
SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT YOU'RE DOING
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD CENTER THANK YOU. THANK
GOD I'M JUST SURPRISED HOW
HATEFUL SOME OF THE
CONVERSATION HERE HAS BEEN IF
PEOPLE IN CALIFORNIA. THEY NEED
TO BE FURTHER WE NEED TO USE
ALL OF THE MECHANISMS. AT OUR
DISPOSAL. TO PROVIDE THAT
ASSISTANCE. WE FEED THE WORLD
ANYWAY. WHY WOULDN'T PLEASE SO
I APPRECIATE YOUR EFFORT AND IN
THIS BILL. SOME OF THE LIKUD
THANK YOU CENTER THANK YOU
BRING THIS UP- AS A AS A FORMER
COUNTY SUPERVISOR YOU KNOW I
HAD NINE COMMUNITY CENTERS IN
MY DISTRICT. THEN I WAS ALWAYS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT HOW CAN WE
DO MORE YOU KNOW SO IN MY
COMMUNITY CENTERS WE ALWAYS
GAVE OFFERED WE HAD EMERGENCY.
FOOD WE HAD BROWN BAG YOU NAME
IT WE HAD RIGHT AND IT WAS IT
WAS ALL GOING TO. THE SAME
DEMOGRAPHICS OF BOOKS THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO HELP THE
SUPPORT. AT THE PART THAT I
HATED WAS THAT THERE WAS ALL
THIS LIKE GOVERNMENT PAPER THAT
THEY HAVE TO FILL OUT IT'S JUST
TOO MUCH. AND EVEN THOUGH THEY
HAD TO DO IT- I A ACCEPTED THAT
THE PART THAT I DIDN'T EXCEPT
THERE WAS OTHER FOLKS THAT.
WOULD STAND IN LINE SOMETIMES
THAT JUST COULD NOT RECEIVE.
GOOD FOR ME TO TURN MY BACK. ON
THEM- KATO IT IT IT'S HARD IT'S
HEARTFELT AND HURTS. AND I
APPLAUD YOU FOR WHAT YOU'RE
DOING OUR OUR STATE ALWAYS
LEADS WHENEVER WE HAVE A FIRE.
THERE ARE SO MANY DIFFERENT
COMMUNITIES A COME UP AND WILL
HELP SEND FOOD. YOU NAME IT NOT
JUST FOR HUMANS BURKE FOR THEIR
ANIMALS UNIT WE COME WE COME IN
SUPPORT AND THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO DO HERE SO I
APPLAUD YOU. AND I HOPE THAT
YOU COULD ADDIS PATENTEE TO
PASS A CO AUTHOR TWO THANK YOU
DIXON. SENATOR THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
FORWARD IT SUPPORT- THE INTENT
AND WHAT YOU'RE TRYING TO DO
WITH THIS BILL. AND WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS I APPRECIATE
THAT THE CONVERSATIONS IN THE
COMMENTS AND THE QUESTIONS I
REALLY APPRECIATE THEM ALL-
AND- AND I THINK THAT THAT THIS
IS AN OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION ABOUT FOOD. RIGHT
SOMETHING THAT IS JUST SO
IMPORTANT TO EACH AND EVERYONE
OF US. SOMETHING YOU KNOW FOOD.
IS IMPORTANT TO AT IT TO EVERY
HUMAN BEING. AND WE THINK ABOUT
FOOD WE THINK ABOUT IS JUST
VERY SIMPLE RIGHT BUT NO FOOD.
FOOD MEANS MUCH MORE THAN FOOD
FOOD MEANS A CULTURE IT MEANS
LOVE IT MEANS. DIFFERENT YOU
KNOW PEOPLE COMING TOGETHER-
AND I HOPE THAT AS THIS BILL
MOVES ALONG THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND THE
IMPORTANCE OF FOOD AND- AND
MAKING SURE THAT EVERYONE HAS
ADEQUATE ACCESS TO FOOD
BECAUSE- FOOD IS LIFE. AND-
WITHOUT FOOD. THERE IS NO LIFE
SO I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU I WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY MISTER SOME
WOMEN ARAMBULA OF THE SECOND.
MISTER BRYANT. THE MOTION IS
THE PAST TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE WALDRON AYE DAVIES
DAVIES NOW ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
BRIAN BRIAN I'D CHOI. JOINT
NOTES DOWN STONE HI REALLY PUT
IT WILL BE DOING I MORE. MORE
HI. OKAY AND THAT SIXTY TWO
MORE OKAY OKAY THANK YOU
SENATOR THANK YOU. OKAY SENATOR
LAMONT ARE YOU READY TO PRESENT
ON SB FIFTY. THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS SB FIFTY
MAKES SEVERAL IMPORTANT CHANGES
TO OUR CURRENT HEALTHCARE
SYSTEM PARTICULARLY BY OPENING
UP MORE OPTIONS FOR INFANT AND
TODDLER CARE AS A WORKING
MOTHER WITH AN INFANTILE
STRUGGLED WHICH HEALTHCARE
OPTIONS MANY OF OUR
CONSTITUENTS FACE THIS SAME
STRUGGLE. CURRENTLY OUR SYSTEM
IS ONLY SERVING 10% OF ELIGIBLE
INFANTS AND TODDLERS THERE IS
SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR INFANT AND
TODDLER CARE SB FIFTY WILL
ADDRESS INEFFICIENCIES IN THE
SYSTEM TO BETTER SERVE CHILDREN
FAMILIES AND PROVIDERS THIS
BILL DOES NOT REQUIRE PROVIDERS
TO MAKE ANY CHANGES BUT ALLOWS
HEALTH CARE PROVIDERS AND
PARENTS MORE FLEXIBILITY. FIRST
THIS BILL WILL OPEN UP THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
YOUNGER CHILDREN BY OPENING UP
THE STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM TO
MORE AGES WE CAN SERVE MORE
UNDERSERVED INFANTS AND
TODDLERS THIS BILL ALSO ALLOWS
FOR PROVIDERS TO TRANSFER
BETWEEN STATE PRESCHOOL AND
CHILD CARE CONTRACTS GIVING
MORE PROVIDERS MORE PROVIDERS
FOR GIVING PROVIDERS MORE
FLEXIBILITY TO SERVE THE NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN DO NOT LOSE CARE.
BUT THAT WHEN THEY HAVE A
BIRTHDAY. FINALLY THIS BILL
WILL MAKE IT EASIER FOR
FAMILIES TO ENROLL IN SEEN
ROLLED IN CHILD CARE. IT EASES
THE ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN ON
PARENTS AND PROVIDERS BY
ESTABLISHING TWENTY FOUR MONTHS
OF CONTINUOUS ELIGIBILITY AND
ALLOWING FOR STREAMLINED
ELIGIBILITY. IF A PARENT CAN
SHOW THAT THEY ARE ENROLLED IN
PROGRAMS LIKE MEDICARE L.
CALFRESH WEAKENED HEAD STARTS
THEY WILL BE PRESUMED ELIGIBLE
FOR SUBSIDIZED CHILD CARE. I
HAVE WITH ME TODAY YET
IDENTICAL APPARENT FROM SAN
JOSE AND MICHELLE SAID WELL-
PREVENT SKI FROM CONTANGO TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND TO ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. EXACTLY THANK YOU
SENATOR- WILL TAKE- OPERATOR
CAN YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE
FOR YET AHEAD I'LL GO. THEIR
LINE IS OPEN. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY WOMAN
SERVICES COMMITTEE MY NAME IS%
NOT A VALID ALL I WAS BORN IN
MEXICO AND REYES SAN JOSE
EDUCATION HAS ALWAYS BEEN AN
IMPORTANT ASPECT OF MY LIFE AS
A SINGLE MOTHER OF A THREE YEAR
OLD BOY FINDING AFFORDABLE
CHILD CARE CENTER HAVE BEEN MY
CHALLENGE FOR THE PAST THREE
YEARS UNTIL I FOUND SPACE IN A
CHILD CARE CENTER IN THE
BAMBERG TWO THOUSAND TWENTY.
THROUGHOUT MY SEARCH I HAD
TROUBLE FINDING SOMETHING THAT
I COULD AFFORD IT TOOK A VERY
LONG TIME TO FIND A PROGRAM
THAT MET MY NEEDS AS A WORKING
MOM IF I HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENROLL MY CHILD AS AN INFANT
TODDLER I WOULD HAVE FELT AT
PEACE KNOWING THAT MY SON WOULD
BE TAKING CARE OF IT FACILITY
WHERE HE WAS ALSO LEARNING AND
DEVELOPING SOCIAL SKILLS. THE
CONSISTENCY OF TAKING HIM TO A
CHILD CARE CENTER WHERE I KNOW
HE WOULD HAVE BEEN LOCKED TOP
EACH YEAR FOR MORE HAVE
BELIEVED ME FROM MUCH
UNNECESSARY STRESS LET ALONE
HELP SIGNIFICANT AND VALUABLE
OF AN EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE
THIS WOULD HAVE BEEN FOR MY SON
I SUCH AN EARLY AGE AND WHAT
THIS WOULD. DO TO HIS ACADEMIC
EXPECT IN THE FUTURE. EVEN
THOUGH I WOULD BE TO GET HIM
ENROLLED INTO A PRE. PART AT
HERE. IT ONLY INTO IN. TO COPE.
THANKFULLY AND HE WILL BE ABLE
TO START PERSON LEARNING.
HOWEVER MY EXPERIENCE WITH THE
ENROLLMENT PROCESS WAS
CHALLENGING BECAUSE OF THE
DOCUMENTS THAT NEEDED TO BE
VERIFIED. I THINK THAT'S WHAT
LED EIGHT THE BARRIERS OF
INVOLVING IN CHILD CARE. NOT
JUST FOR ME BUT FOR MANY
FAMILIES. I WOULD MAKE IT MUCH
EASIER FOR THOSE FAMILIES
ALREADY INVOLVED IN THE
FINANCIAL BENEFITS BY CALFRESH
MEDI CAL. THE GREATEST THING
ABOUT SB FIFTY IS THAT IT
ALLOWS ACCESS TO AFFORDABLE
HIGH QUALITY EARLY. LEARNING
AND CARE FOR LOW INCOME
FAMILIES. I A TEACHER BUT MY
OWN PERSONAL NOT ENOUGH TO
COVER THE COSTS OF HEALTHCARE.
AND STILL AFFORD TO LIVE IN ONE
OF THE MOST EXPENSIVE PLACES IN
CALIFORNIA. I'M MAKING ENDS
MEET WITH WHAT I CAN. I KNOW
THAT MANY OTHER PARENTS ACROSS
THE STATE HAVE TROUBLE FINDING
AFFORDABLE QUALITY CHILD.
SPECIALLY INTENT. TODDLER CAN.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
SHARE MY STORY THAT'S WHY I
SUPPORT SB FIFTY AND I URGE YOU
TO SUPPORT IT UP WELL. THANK
YOU- OUR NEXT WITNESS IS-
MICHELLE STILWELL KAMINSKI.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE STILL
PREVENTS YOU FROM GETTING GO
I'M PROUD TO CO SPONSOR SB
FIFTY I'LL BE BRIEF IN- CAN BE
HERE FOR TECHNICAL QUESTIONS
BUT WE ARE OF THE- THE LARGEST
PRESCHOOL AND CHILD CARE
PROVIDER IN THE BAY AREA
NONPROFIT AND THAT THIS IS A
BILL THAT WOULD ASSIST US IN
BEING ABLE TO BETTER SERVE
CHILDREN AND FAMILIES IN OUR
COMMUNITY ESPECIALLY SERVING
MORE INFANTS AND TODDLERS WHICH
IS WHERE WE KNOW THE GREATEST
NEED IS- IT ALSO PROVIDES THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR STATE PRESCHOOL
FUNDS BE USED FOR FAMILY CHILD
CARE. PROVIDERS THAT ARE IN
NETWORKS- WHICH WOULD PROVIDE
MORE OPTIONS FOR FAMILIES AS
WELL AS PROVIDING MORE
STABILITY FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS- AND FINALLY AS ARE
MENTIONED THE BILL WOULD
STREAMLINE AND IMPROVE-
ELIGIBILITY AND ENROLLMENT FOR
FAMILIES MAKING IT EASIER AND
LESS BURDENSOME FOR THEM TO
QUALIFY- AND GET ENROLLED INTO
THE CHILD CARE PROGRAMS THAT
THEY NEED. I URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT- IN
THE ROOM. OKAY C. NINETY WE
HAVE- ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT IN
RTS STATION. NO OKAY THANK YOU
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN LINE TO
SEE IF WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR FOR COMMENT IN
SUPPORT SB FIFTY PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO. THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. AND FIRST WE
WILL GO TO LINE FOUR HUNDRED
EIGHTY. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
PATTY HER ERA ON BEHALF OF
EARLY H. CALIFORNIA A PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB FIFTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. LINE A. FIVE HUNDRED
FIVE. GOOD EVENING SIR MEMBERS
FOR SAKE DOT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMY OF CHILD AND
ADOLESCENT PSYCHIATRY IN THE
PRESS. SB THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY. HI LYCHEE
SECRECY ON BEHALF OF RIVERSIDE
COUNTY SUPERINTENDENT OF
SCHOOLS IN STRONG SUPPORT. LINE.
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO. ONE
FIVE HUNDRED TWENTY TWO YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. STE I THINK THE
WRONG BILL I'M AND I'M ACTUALLY
TRYING. CLICK ON AT THE SEVEN
FORTY CHU IS THAT NOT RIGHT NOW
I KNOW THIS IS WHERE I'M AT. SB
FIFTY. OKAY- HOW DO I. AND
ALIVE. FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS WILLIAM BUTTON BURKE ON
BEHALF OF THE BLACK LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL IN SUPPORT. LINE. FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON COLLEEN PACKER ON
BEHALF LOS ANGELES UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
LINE ONE HUNDRED SIXTY NINE. HI
GOOD AFTERNOON CHEN MEMBERS OF
THE LOCAL BAPTIST WITH THE
LEAGUE OF WOMEN VOTERS OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
FIVE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE.
LINE FOUR HUNDRED THIRTY FIVE
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. LINE. FOUR
HUNDRED SEVENTY. A GOOD
AFTERNOON NEED ABILITY WITH
EVERY CHILD CALIFORNIA PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF SB FIFTY IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AND THERE
ARE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR- WE DO
NOT HAVE ANY PRIMARY OPPOSITION
WITNESSES DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. I WANT
TO BE CLEAR I'M NOT OPPOSED TO
WE HAVE CONCERNS- KIMBERLY
ROSENBERGER WITH SEIU- WE
THINK- THE AUTHOR IN THE INTENT
OF THIS BILL IS WONDERFUL WE DO
YOU HAVE A CHILD CARE CRISIS-
ESPECIALLY FOR INFANTS HOWEVER-
IT THERE THERE'S NOT PARITY
THERE WERE A LITTLE CONCERNED
WITH THE UNINTENDED UNINTENDED
A FACT THAT IT WILL HAVE. ON
OUR CHILD CARE PROVIDERS WHO
TRADITIONALLY DO THE ZERO TO
THREE AND- ARE ALREADY FACING A
LITTLE BIT OF INSTABILITY
CAUSED BY THE UNIVERSAL
TRANSITIONAL KINDERGARTEN
PROPOSAL THIS WAS SUPPOSED TO
HELP WITH THAT IS STREAMLINED
THINGS WITH WE DO APPRECIATE
BUT IT DOESN'T HAVE FULL
PARITY. THERE ISN'T PARITY WHEN
IT COMES TO INTER AND INTRA
TRANSFERS THERE ISN'T PARITY IN
THE STREAMLINING ACCESS FOR
SCHOOLS I HAVE 80% OR MORE FOR
YOUR REDUCE CHILDREN WOULD LIKE
TO SEE THAT FOR OUR FAMILY CARE
PROVIDERS. I WOULD LIKE THEM
THE SAME OPPORTUNITY AND THEN
WITH ALL THINGS THAT ARE ARE
SYSTEMICALLY CHANGING- AN
INFRASTRUCTURE LIKE THIS WE DO
THINK THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE A
SUNSET- WE ARE RECOMMENDING A
SUNSET THAT ALIGNS WITH GIVING
THEM A COUPLE CYCLES THROUGH
CONTRACTS SO WE WOULD LIKE TO
SEE AN EVALUATION AFTER THE
FIRST CYCLE AND THEN WITH THE
SECOND CYCLE WE CAN COME BACK
RETURN. SEE WHAT WORKS AND WHAT
DOESN'T AND ALLOW- YOU KNOW
STAKEHOLDERS TO HAVE IN PLACE
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
AS WELL AS THE SPONSORS BUT
WE'RE IN THE SECOND HOUSE
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF THINGS
CHANGING AND WE JUST FEEL- WE
NEED TO REALLY HAMMER OUT SOME
MORE DETAILS AROUND. HOW THE
IMPACT IS GOING. TO BE ON OUR
PROVIDERS BEEN KILLED. THANK
YOU. I DO WE HAVE ANY- PUBLIC
OPPOSITION RTS ROOM. NO OKAY
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC OPPOSITION ON
THE LINE. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB FIFTY PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THEN. ZERO
AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT AT THIS
TIME. THANK YOU OPERATOR- DO WE
HAVE ANY QUESTIONS FOR THE
AUTHOR FROM THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. AND IF SOMEONE TRIED.
THANK YOU SENATOR NAME ON- I
WILL BE SUPPORTING HIS SO-
MANAGER BECAUSE I AM A STRONG
BELIEVER OF EARLY LEARNING AND
I'M ALSO CONCERNED ABOUT THE-
AVAILABILITY OF A CHILD CARE
CENTERS- BUT THAT IN. THIS-
IMPLEMENTATION- THE SUMMARY.
SAYS SO IT SAYS THIS PROGRAM IS
EXPANDING THE RANGE OF WHAT
TYPE OF A CHILD CARE. AND EARLY
LEARNING SERVICES TO THE STATE.
OPRY'S QUARTER CONTRACTING
AGENCY- CAN YOU DEFINE IN
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS PROGRAM
WILL THIS BE- EXPANDED GOT TO
EXISTING PUBLIC SCHOOL RISK
WHAT. BUY YOU A STATEMENT
DOUBLE CONTRACTING AGENCY DOES
THAT MEAN THAT OUTSIDE THE
CONTRACTOR- WILL IT INCLUDE THE
NONPROFIT'S ALL FOR PROFIT SO
WHO WILL BE DAHLE CONTRACTING
AGENCIES. THAT'S MY FIRST
QUESTION AND THEN I ASSUME-
THAT ANYONE TWO TO FOUR YEARS
OLD DON'T ONE DAY OUT AND
ROLLED INTO STATE SPONSORED
THAT CHARMED ITSELF. Q.
PROGRAMS WILL BE FREE OF CHARGE
IS THAT CORRECT SO THE PROGRAM
THE IDEA IS THAT WE WOULD
EXPAND THIS TO SOME OF THE
LICENSED PROVIDERS- THAT
CURRENTLY EXIST AND SO WE HOPE
THAT THAT SOME OF THE PROVIDERS
FOR CHILD CARE NOW WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN CONTRACTING WITH
THAT WITH THE STATE AT TO
EXPAND THIS SERVICE AND SO YES-
THE PRESCHOOL THE STATE
PRESCHOOL PROGRAM IS FREE-
SUBSIDIZE AND THAT IS OUR HOPE
I MEAN I THINK WE ARE WORKING
TOWARDS. A MODEL OF MORE
AFFORDABILITY AND CERTAINLY
THIS BILL- IS FOCUSED ON THE
MORE UNDERSERVED- WHO REALLY
WANT TO MAKE SURE- ARE ABLE TO
ACCESS. A CHILD CARE AND STATE
PRESCHOOL. A NOT CREATE SO-
MORE CONCERN TO ME- AT LEAST-
IN MY- DISTRICT A- THE- CHILD
CARE OR- CENTERS ARE NOT
SUFFICIENT AND THERE'S ALWAYS A
LONG. WAITING LIST AND IF YOU
EXPAND- THE THAT THAT THE
PROGRAM AGE GROUP TO YOUR TOOL
FOR YEARS SO THAT'LL BE
OVERWHELMING AND EVEN LONGER-
WAITING PERIOD- TO BE ADMITTED.
SO HOW CAN WE SOLVE THAT
PROBLEM SO IT IS SAID THAT A
COUPLE THINGS I'M NOT SURE THAT
YOUR- ANALISIS EIGHT IS ONE
THAT I SHARE- I IS THAT WHAT
HAPPENS IS YOU HAVE A
COMBINATION OF THINGS HAPPENING
AND ACTUALLY IT WAS JUST SPOKEN
TO WE'VE ALSO EXPANDED. THE
TIKI PROGRAM RIGHT AND THAT'S
HAPPENING- THROUGH BUDGET
ACTIONS WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT THAT SO ALL OF THIS WORKS
TOGETHER- AND THE IDEA IS THAT.
IF YOU'RE AN AGENCY IF YOU'RE A
CENTER- IF YOU'RE HOME HAIR
CARE PROVIDER THAT CAN EXPAND
THEN YOU ARE A BIG ABLE TO GO
REMEMBER THAT THE RULES CHANGE
RIGHT SO FOR INFANT CARE THERE
ARE CERTAIN GUIDELINES THAT ARE
NEEDED FOR TODDLER CARE AND
THEN FOR PRESCHOOL AND ALL OF
THOSE GUIDELINES ACTUALLY AS
THE STUDENTS GET OLDER THE
ALLOW FOR MORE FLEXIBILITY. AND
THAT'S WHY YOU SEE A HIGHER-
STUDENT TO ADULT RATIO AT THE
OLDER AGE- AND SO ALL OF THESE
THINGS ARE PART OF ANY
CREATION- AND YOU WOULDN'T IF
YOU WOULD NOT BE IF YOU WOULD
NOT BE ABLE TO. MEET THE NEEDS
OF THE CONTRACT YOU WOULD
THEREFORE NOT APPLY- AS SOMEONE
WHO IS HONEST SEVEN WAIT LIST
THREE IN SACRAMENTO AND US FOR
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY I CAN
TELL YOU- THAT THIS BILL DOES
NOT MAKE THAT PROBLEM ANY
BIGGER THAT PROBLEM EXISTS
BECAUSE THE OVERALL THING THAT
WE NEED TO DO. IS WE NEED TO
INCREASE CHILD CARE SLOTS IN
ALL AGES RIGHT ESPECIALLY IF
THE INFANT SO IF YOU LOOK AT
THE YOU KNOW NOW I MAY BE
GIVING YOU TOO MUCH DETAIL BUT
YOU JUST ASK THE MOTHER OF AN
INFANT. ABOUT THIS SO AT THE
INFANT LIST IS ACTUALLY THE
LONGEST LIST IF THE SO AS THE
KIDS GET OLDER AT THAT LIST IS
SHORTER. SO I CA GIVE YOU MORE
DETAILS IF YOU'D LIKE BUT THE
THIS IS DOES NOT EX CREATE
LONGER WAIT LIST THIS ACTUALLY
EXPANDS THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE MORE KIDS THROUGH THE
STATE PRESCHOOL PROGRAM WHICH
WOULD POTENTIALLY BE SLIGHTLY
OLDER- KIDS AND ALSO I DO WANT
TO RECOGNIZE THE IN TERMS OF
THE DISCUSSION THAT'S HAPPENED
THIS BILL- SHOULD GET OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE TODAY. IS LIKELY
TO TAKE AMENDMENTS IN THE NEX
COMMITTEE. BUT ALSO. A SPEAKING
ABOUT THE. THE FISCAL FACILITY
IS UNLIMITED BUT THE THIS
PROGRAM WILL EXPAND THE NUMBER
OF ELIGIBLE CHILDREN TO BE
ENROLLED BY CHOICE NOT BY
REQUIREMENTS. SO IF THE
FACILITY HAS THE SPACE FOR MORE
BECAUSE REMEMBER THE RATIOS
CHANGE AND THE GUIDELINES
CHANGED THEN THEY'RE ABLE TO DO
MORE AND THAT IS NOT AN OPTION
THAT IS ON THE TABLE RIGHT NOW.
OKAY THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO COOK I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN DAVIES
AND THE SECOND BY FROM WORK.
THE QUESTION IS DO YOU PASS TO
THE ASSEMBLY EDUCATION
COMMITTEE CALDERON HI CALDERON
AYE DAVIES DAVIES I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BRIAN. BRIAN I CHOI
CHOI AYE STONE. STONE I
FILIPPIDIS LITTLE BIT ABOUT I
LORD LORD I. EIGHT TWO ZERO
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
SENATOR. OKAY SENATOR WELL ARE
YOU READY TO PRESENT ON SB FIVE
FOUR SIX. WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SIR. THANK YOU CHAIR MEMBERS
BEFORE YOU AS SB FIVE FORTY SIX
WHICH EXTENDS THE AYE FOSTER
PILOT PROGRAM IS PART OF THE
PUC'S BROADER LIFELINE PROGRAM
THIS BILL WILL ENSURE THAT
CRUCIAL TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES ARE CONTINUALLY
OFFERED TO FOSTER YOUTH L. A.
COUNTY HAS A LARGE POPULATION
OF FOSTER YOUTH AND ONE OUT OF
EVERY THREE FOSTER YOUTH-
RESIDE IN THE TWENTY FIRST
SENATE-DISTRICT AND I'M WELL
AWARE OF THE CHALLENGES THAT
THEY FACE. IF YOU LOOK AT THE
DATA ON FOSTER YOUTH IT'S QUITE
HEARTBREAKING- THEIR GRADUATION
RATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL IS HALF
OF THE NORMAL RATE ONLY 4%
GRADUATE FROM COLLEGE AND
THOUGH THEY DON'T HAVE HARD
FIGURES THE DEPARTMENT
CORRECTIONS BELIEVES THAT MAYBE
AS HIGH AS 20% OF THE PRISON
POPULATION ARE FORMER. FOSTER
YOUTH. SO THANKFULLY THE DATA
SHOWS THAT THE RESOURCES OF
HAVING A PHONE MAKES A
DIFFERENCE IN THESE USE LIFE BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO THE
MENTORS TO THEIR FAMILY HEALTH
SERVICES EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT WE SEEN THIS
LAST YEAR AND IT COULD BE THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN EARLIER AND
SUCCESS. NOW OBVIOUSLY HAVING A
PHONE CREATE STABILITY IN THEIR
LIFE WHICH IS MUCH NEEDED. SO
WITH ME TODAY TO TESTIFY I
GUESS OVER THE PHONE IS CERITA
****WHOSE CO FOUNDER AND CEO
OF THE AYE FOSTER PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU SENATOR OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
THREE TO FIVE SIX. THREE
O'CLOCK DEADLINE IT OPEN. GOOD
AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE AYE
FOSTERS AND OUR PARTNER SUPPORT
FOR SB FIVE FORTY SIX MY NAME
IS RITA **** I AM THE CEO AND
CO FOUNDER OF AYE FOSTER AND A
FORMER BOSS TO USE I FOSTER THE
NATIONAL NONPROFIT PROVIDING
OVER A HUNDRED AND TWENTY FIVE
MILLION IN RESOURCES TO ABOUT
TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND COST USED ANNUALLY
ACROSS ALL FIFTY STATES. AS
SENATOR WHAT MENTIONED ACCESS
TO RELIABLE COMMUNICATIONS IS A
TRUE LIFELINE FOR OUR USE. IN
JUST A YEAR AND A HALF THE AYE
FOSTER PHONES FOR COST YOU THE
LIFELINE PILOT HAS PROVIDED
COMMUNICATIONS FOR THIRTEEN
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY
TWO CALIFORNIA COST TO USE.
MEETING THE NEEDS OF 84% OF
PILOT ELIGIBLE USED. AS WELL AS
CONNECTING NEARLY TWO THOUSAND
FIVE TO USE IN CALIFORNIA WHO
ARE NOT ELIGIBLE- WITH FUNDING
FROM THE DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES AND PHILANTHROPY.
PILOT PARTICIPANTS HAVE BEEN
USING THEIR PHONES FOR
COMMUNICATIONS WITH FRIENDS
FAMILY AND THEIR SUPPORT
NETWORKS FOR SCHOOLWORK
EMPLOYMENT AND TELEHEALTH. 101%
OF PARTICIPANTS SURVEYED AND
THEIR FOSTER YOUTH SERVING
AGENCIES BELIEVE THIS PROGRAM
SHOULD BE CONTINUED AND SHOULD
BE NATIONWIDE. WHICH IS WHY WE
NEED YOUR SUPPORT FOR SB FIVE
FORTY SIX. WELL THE CPUC DOES
HAVE PURVIEW OVER THE PILOT
THESE VIEWS ARE WARDS OF THE
STATE AND IT IS YOUR
RESPONSIBILITY TO ENSURE THAT
THEIR TELECOMMUNICATIONS OF
RIGHTS AS COULD APPLIED IN THE
CALIFORNIA FOSTER CARE BILL OF
RIGHTS ARE REALIZED. THIS
PROGRAM IS THE ONLY PROGRAM
THAT THE BILL'S THEIR RIGHTS
INCLUSIVELY AND EQUITABLY. YOUR
SUPPORT IS REQUIRED TO ENSURE
THIS PROGRAM CONTINUES WITH NO
SERVICE GAPS WELL WE ARE
SPOILED WITH COMMISSIONER
SHOULD ALMOST PROPOSED DECISION
ON JUNE EIGHTH TWENTY TWENTY
ONE. WE DO NOT YET HAVE A
DEFINITIVE DECISION NOT COATED
BY PLANS FOR HOW THIS PILOT
WILL BECOME. A PERMANENT THE
LIFELINE PROGRAM. THIS DECISION
TO MAKE OUR PROGRAM PERMANENT
IS NOT WITHOUT LOGISTICAL
HURDLES INCLUDING REQUIRING THE
SWAP OUT OF EVERY SINGLE. PHONE
PRIOR TO THE END OF THIS YEAR.
TIME IS RUNNING AND WE CANNOT
AFFORD DELAYS ON JANUARY FIRST
FIFTEEN THOUSAND ONE HUNDRED
ELEVEN FOSTER USE PHONES WILL
CEASE TO FUNCTION. WELL ALL THE
PARTIES ARE WORKING ON DRAFTING
PLANS AND BUDGETS A DECISION IS
NOT YET EXPECTED UNTIL JULY
FIFTEENTH. WHEN THE COMMISSION
IS SCHEDULED TO VOTE LEAVING
ONLY FIVE AND A HALF MONTHS TO
ENSURE THAT FOSTER USED TO NOT
LOSE TELECOMMUNICATIONS
SERVICES. ANY DELAYS IN BOTH OF
FURTHER HEARINGS COULD
JEOPARDIZE THIS TIME FRAME.
FROM THE PERSPECTIVE OF FOSTER
CARE COMMUNITY AND AS EVIDENCED
BY THE RECENT CQC EVALUATION OF
THE PROGRAM THE I TALKED TO
POUNDS TO POCKET PILOT HAS BEEN
A SUCCESS WITH FIFTEEN THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED ELEVEN CALIFORNIA.
BOB DO YOU RECEIVING CRITICAL
COMMUNICATIONS THAT THEY NEED
BUT THERE IS A RISK THAT ARE
CALIFORNIA PASSED YOU'D LOSE
ALL OF THEIR COMMUNICATION
GAINES. LOSING SERVICE CAN HAVE
DIRE CONSEQUENCES. AS ONE NEW
PARTICIPANT SHARED I MIGHT HAVE
COMMITTED SUICIDE IF I WASN'T
ABLE TO REACH OUT TO MY SUPPORT
SYSTEM GOODBYE I FOSTER FROM.
FOR THIS REASON I FOSTER AND
OUR PARTNER ORGANIZATIONS
SUPPORT SB FIVE FORTY SIX AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISS **** DO WE HAVE
ANY. ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT
IN THE ROOM. KATHY NINE DO WE
HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AT
THE RTS STATION. L. OKAY
OPERATOR CAN YOU OPEN THE LINE
FOR PUBLIC SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
CAME OUT OF CHAIR FOR COMMENT
IN SUPPORT S. B. FIVE FOUR SIX
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO.
I COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. LINE
ONE HUNDRED FOURTEEN YEAR MY
COULD OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS POLICY
S. GROWTH WITH THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION
EXPORT. THANK YOU. BLINDER.
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR. FIND
FOUR HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR YOU'RE
MY COULD OPEN. WHAT. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME. THANK YOU I WOULD HAVE NO
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESSES-
DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. C. NINE
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION
AT RTS STATION. NO OKAY
OPERATOR DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION QUEUED UP ON THE
PHONE. FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE AND
THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN
ONE ZERO AND THAT THE F. B.
FIVE FOUR SIX. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENT AT THIS TIME. THANK YOU
OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
AND- IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN
SENATOR THAT IS NOT THE FIRST
TIME WE'VE TALKED ABOUT THIS
BILL AND I'M GOING TO RAISE
THIS. COMING AYE MATEY LAST
TIME WE SPOKE ABOUT I LOVE THIS
BILL. I THINK IT'S INCREDIBLE
YOU DEFINITELY HAVE MY SUPPORT.
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT CONCERNS
ME WITH THIS AND MANY OTHER
BILLS THAT WE HEAR BEFORE THIS
COMMITTEE HELD ON HIS. FIRST
DAY. IS ARBITRARY LINE THAT TO
BE ELIGIBLE AS A FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH BETWEEN TWENTY ONE TO
TWENTY SIX YOU HAD TO HAVE BEEN
IN FOSTER CARE AFTER AGE
THIRTEEN THE AVERAGE AGE OF
FOSTER. YOUTH IN CALIFORNIA
THEY KNOW HALF THE AVERAGE TIME
YOU'RE IN FOSTER CARE IS TWO
AND A HALF YEARS. THE AVERAGE
YOUTH THERE FOR THE AVERAGE
TIME WHEN QUALIFY FOR THIS. AND
OBVIOUSLY THIS KIND OF A LINE
IS A COST SAVING MECHANISM BUT
IN A- YEAR LIKE THIS I DON'T
KNOW THAT WE HAVE TO DRAW THIS
KIND OF A LINE- WE HAVE. TWO
HUNDRED SIXTY BILLION DOLLARS
COMING OUT OF THE STATE BUDGET
AND- BIFURCATING WHICH FOSTER
YOUTH ARE DESERVING. OF BEING
OUT OF FOR THIS PROGRAM WHICH
FORMER FOSTER YOUTH OR NOT. IS
SOMETHING I THINK. WE COULD WE
COULD DO A LITTLE BIT BETTER
BUT EITHER WAY THIS INCREDIBLE
YEAH. GUYS YOU KNOW I'M ALL OF
YOU IT IS EXTENDING THE CURRENT
PROGRAM I'D LOVE I'D LOVE TO
SIT DOWN TO TALK TO YOU AND- I
THINK WE'RE STILL GONNA HAVE A
COUPLE MORE YEARS. OF AT LEAST
A GOOD ROUTE- GOOD INCOME
COMING IN SO WE SHOULD LOOK AT
EXPANDING. EXPANDING BECAUSE
YOU'RE ABSOLUTELY RIGHT ON THAT
I LOVE THAT THE PROCEDURE
OPENNESS. THANK YOU ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. FROM THE
BILL OKAY SENATOR WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE. OKAY WE HAVE
A MOTION BY ASSEMBLYWOMAN
DAVIES AND THE SECOND BY SOME
GUNMEN ARAMBULA. THE MOTION IS
TO PASS TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES HI ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI BRIAN BRIAN HI
CHOI. CHU AYE AYES STONE STONE
I AVAILABLE TO US ON THE LIVE
IN DUBAI WARD. BOTH SEVEN IS
THERE ONLY BEEN ON CALL FOR
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THANK YOU SENATOR. I
CAN'T BELIEVE THAT WE ARE
WAITING FOR SENATOR SKINNER WHO
IS. PRESIDING OVER BUDGET OR IN
BUDGET COMMITTEE I THINK BUDGET
JUST GOT OUT OKAY CALL OVER
OKAY GREAT THANK YOU. THERE SHE-
PERFECT TIMING SENATOR. YES
PLEASE SENATOR. WELCOME THANK
YOU- WHENEVER YOU'RE READY
SENATOR CAN PRESENT ON US SB
SIXTY FIVE WONDERFUL THANK SO
MUCH- MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS-
SB SIXTY FIVE IS CALIFORNIA'S
MOM TO THIS BILL YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN FOLLOWING THAT CONGRESS
HAS ALSO BEEN ENACTING AMONG
MISS THIS BILL AND I APPRECIATE
THE- MOTION ALREADY SO ONLY
SAY. THAT IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
BUT CALIFORNIA IN THE US IN
GENERAL HAVE STILL HAVE HIGH
RATES OF MATERNAL MORTALITY AND
INFANT MORTALITY HIGHEST AMONG
BLACK WOMEN. THEN OUR NATIVE
INDIGENOUS WOMEN IN LATINO
WOMEN AND THAT'S OUTRAGEOUS
THIS BILLS ADDRESSED TO ADDRESS
THAT AND I'LL LEAVE IT ALONE IT
I'LL- TAKE YOUR VOTE YOUR
MOTION. AS A GOOD SIGN AND I
WILL ASK MY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT TO SPEAK IT IS DR SEAH
MALALA WHO IS THE A
PEDIATRICIAN WITH SF DEPARTMENT
OF PUBLIC HEALTH. AND CHANTE
DAVIS BULGE WHO IS A JEWELER
AND THE PRESIDENT OF THE SEAT
AND- PRESIDENT OF THE BLACK
WELLNESS AND PROSPERITY CENTER.
THANK YOU SENATOR OPERATOR CAN
YOU PLEASE OPEN THE LINE FOR
THE WITNESSES WITH DOCTOR AS
THE MLS SPEAKING FIRST. DR
ALLOWED LINE IS OPEN. HI CAN
YOU HEAR ME. YES. THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY I'M
DR SAM ALLOWANCE I'M A BLACK
PEDIATRICIAN MOTHER AND I'M
TESTIFYING ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO WHO'S IN STRONG
SUPPORTER OF SB SIXTY FIVE- I
WANT TO BRIEFLY SHARE A STORY
OF A PATIENT OF MINE ARE WE CAN
COLLECTIVELY. KEVIN HE WAS VERY
EXCITED TO BECOME A MOTHER SHE
STARTED SCHEDULING APPOINTMENTS
WITH ME THE ATTRITION WHEN SHE
WAS BARELY FIVE MONTHS PREGNANT
BEFORE THE BABY WAS EVEN OUT
BECAUSE SHE JUST REALLY WANTED
TO MAKE SURE SHE WAS DOING
EVERYTHING RIGHT FOR THIS BABY
AND I THOUGHT EARLY VISITS AND
LEARNED THAT SHE WAS WORRIED
ABOUT PAYING HER RENT AND HER
BOSS HAD BEEN CUTTING HER HOURS
EVER SINCE YOU FOUND OUT SHE
WAS PREGNANT AND HER- B. WROTE
A NOTE LIMITING HOW MUCH
TECHNIQUE OF MISSED AT WORK.
BUT BY THE TIME HE WAS SIX
MONTHS PREGNANT HE HAD MOVED
OUT OF HER APARTMENT BECAUSE
SHE DIDN'T WANT IT IS AN
ADDICTION ON HER RECORD AND SHE
WAS COUCH SURFING AND SO NOT
SURPRISINGLY SHE HAD HER BABY
TWO ONE HALF MONTHS EARLY AND
HER BABY. WAS FIRST FOR HIM SO
LITTLE. IT'LL FOR. MONTH OF HIS
LIFE. AND STORY UNFORTUNATELY
IS NOT UNUSUAL ESPECIALLY FOR
BLACK MOTHERS. CALIFORNIA CAN
ONLY PROSPER WHEN ALL OF OUR
CHILDREN HAVE A FAIR CHANCE TO
BE BORN HEALTHY. AND REACH
THEIR FULL POTENTIAL. IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY HOWEVER TOO
MANY PREGNANT PEOPLE. ARE SHUT
OUT OF THE RESOURCES AND
OPPORTUNITIES THAT THEY NEED TO
HAVE A HEALTHY PREGNANCY AND
BIRTH. RESOURCES LIKE HOUSING.
RESPECTFUL HEALTHCARE. NURSING
FOOD GOOD JOBS AND LIVABLE
WAGES. WHICH WE KNOW ARE
ESSENTIAL- THE CONSEQUENCES OF
NOT HAVING ACCESS TO THESE
RESOURCES ARE DEVASTATING FOR
ALL OF US. TODAY IN CALIFORNIA.
ONE IN EIGHT BLACK BABIES IS
BORN PREMATURE. A RATED PRE
MATURITY THAT'S WORSE THAN MANY
DEVELOPING COUNTRIES. AND IT'S
43% HOWELL IN OTHER GROUPS IN
CALIFORNIA. NATIVE AMERICAN
PEOPLE HAVE THE SECOND HIGHEST
RATE OF PRETERM BIRTH. AND
UNFORTUNATELY THE GROUPS ARE
ALSO FACED WITH THE BURDEN OF
HIGHER RATES OF MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND INFANT MORTALITY.
SO IT'S PREMATURE WHEN THEY'RE
BORN IN JUST A FEW WEEKS
PREMATURE THE IMPACT CAN LAST A
LIFETIME. BABIES THAT ARE BORN
PREMATURE MAY FACE RISK OF
HEALTH AND COGNITIVE PROBLEMS
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIFE. ALSO
WHEN YOU CONSIDER THE THOUGHT.
HERE IN LEON NEAL INTENSIVE
UNIT. AND PARENTS LOST HOURS OF
PRODUCTIVITY WHILE CARING FOR A
PREEMIE AND THE TRAUMA TO THE
FAMILY IT'S CLEAR HOW THESE
BURDENS. ARE ARE ARE THE
DISPARITIES ARE BURNING ALL OF
US. THE MORE PRETERM BABIES
THAT ARE BORN IN OUR STATE THE
LESS HEALTHY WE ARE AT THE
COMMUNITY. SB 65% OF REAL
OPPORTUNITY TO MAKE A POSITIVE.
CHANGE FOR CALIFORNIA PARENTS
AND BABIES. THESE INITIATIVES
IT CONTAINED WITHIN SB FIFTY
FIVE WILL MAKE A DIFFERENCE
WHAT THE WAY. TO LAST DR
ACCOUNTABILITY AND CASH HAVE
ALL BEEN SHOWN TO MAKE BRITAIN
SAFER FOR MOTHERS AND BABIES.
FOR INSTANCE THEY HAVE HAD A
THE INCOMES UP MANITOBA THAT'S-
TO THE ONE WE PROPOSED SB SIXTY
FIVE. FOR OVER TEN YEARS AND
WITH THIS ONE PREGNANCY INCOME
SUPPLEMENT THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO
REDUCE PRETERM BIRTH RATE. BY
SEVENTEEN POINT 5% AND FOR
THOSE OF YOU WHO ARE NOT. IN
THE ROOM IF THE MEDICATION CAN
IMPROVE A DISEASE RIGHT BY EVEN
5% WE'RE PRETTY EXCITED SO
SEVENTEEN POINT 5% REDUCTION IS
A REALLY BIG DEAL. REDUCING THE
STRESS ASSOCIATED WITH MAKING
RENTER FEEL LIKE FILLING THE
FRIDGE. AND ALSO ADDRESS THE
UNDERLYING STRESS THAT THE
FACTORS IN PRETERM BIRTH AND
OTHER ADVERSE HEALTH OUTCOMES
SO THIS APPROACH CAN BEGIN TO
ADDRESS OUR STATE'S RACIST
PAST. LIKE OUR HISTORY OF
REDLINING AND URBAN RENEWAL
THAT HAS LEFT BLACK AND
INDIGENOUS RESIDENTS.
PARTICULARLY UNDER RESOURCE IN
THE MIDST OF OUR STRONG
ECONOMY. THIS PROGRAM BUILDS ON
THE GROWING MOMENTUM TO
PROVIDE. INCOME AS A SOLUTION
TO POVERTY AND THE POLICY
TOWARD HAS GAINED EVEN MORE
TRACTION IN THE PAST YEAR DUE
TO THE COBIT NINETEEN PANDEMIC.
HERE IN SAN FRANCISCO WE
BELIEVE IN THE SOLUTION SO
STRONGLY THAT WE RECENT
RECENTLY LAUNCHED OUR OWN
PREGNANCY INCOME PILOT. IT'S
CALLED THE ABANDONED BIRTH
PROJECT AND THE COMMUNITY HAS
BEEN NOTHING SHORT OF
OVERWHELMING IN. TERMS OF THE
NUMBER OF APPLICATIONS WE'VE
GOTTEN. A PREGNANCY INCOMES.
WILL MAKE COURT INVOLVING
DURING A- STAGE OF LIFE. AND
THE PAYOFF WILL BE FELT BEYOND.
FAMILIES HAVE OPTED TO
LIQUIDITY ESPECIALLY AS WE
EMERGE FROM THAT CAN. HOW WILL
OUR SCHOOLS PRIVATE MORE
PARENTS ARE NO LONGER LIVING
HAND TO MOUTH. YOU CAN SPEND
QUALITY TIME WITH THEIR
CHILDREN AND VOLUNTEER AT THEIR
SCHOOLS. WHAT WHAT ARE STATE
LOOK LIKE IN THE FUTURE ONE
MORE FAMILIES ARE STABLY HOUSED
AND FED. AND THEIR CHILDREN
ACTUALLY HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO REACH THEIR FULLEST
POTENTIAL. WHEN WE WORK
TOGETHER TO ENSURE THAT OUR
CHILDREN. MOTHERS AND FAMILIES
CAN PLOW WE CREATE A BETTER
FUTURE FOR ALL OF US. AND SO I
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT SB SIXTY
FIVE. I THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU DR MILA- OPERATOR CAN
YOU OPEN THE LINE FIRST- THE
NEXT WITNESS CHANTE DIE DAVIES
FONG. OKAY DAVID BOX LINE IS
OPEN THANK YOU. HELLO THANK YOU
SO MUCH STOCKTON ALLOWANCE FOR
THAT POWERFUL TESTIMONY- I WANT
TO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK ON BEHALF
OF BLACK MOMS AND BABIES TODAY
AGAIN MY NAME IS SEAN CASEY
BABY FAULTS THAT PRESIDENT AND
CEO OF BLACK WELLNESS AND
PROSPERITY CENTER AND PRICE
NOW. BOB DONNAN PROSPERITY FOR-
THE RESEARCH DRIVEN SOCIAL
ENTERPRISE FOUNDED TO
EXPLICITLY ADDRESS THE ANATOMY
OF BLACK WOMEN AND BABIES I
EARNED MY MBA FROM JOHNS
HOPKINS UNIERSITY WHAT THE
PROFESSIONAL TEAM HEALTHCARE
AND I'M ALSO THE MOTHER OF
THREE. AND EXPERIENCE TO
PRETERM BIRTH MYSELF BUT BEFORE
THAT I WAS THE DAUGHTER OF AN
AMAZING WOMAN WHO DESPITE HER
BEST EFFORTS BUT NEVER ABLE TO
GET A HAT WE WERE OFTEN ON HOW
INDEPENDENT ON CASH. AID AND
FOOD STAMPS TO SURVIVE. IT IS
BECAUSE OF MY PER EXPERIENCE
WITH THE TRUMP. AND BEING THE
REST DAY OF THE SOCIAL IN. THAT
UNDER THE IMPORTANCE OF
SUPPORTING SB SIXTY FIVE AND IT
ABILITY TO STABILIZE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE. BLACK WOMEN AND
BABIES. WE KNOW THAT BLACK
WOMEN AND BABIES EXPERIENCE THE
HIGHEST BURDEN OF PRETERM BIRTH
INFANT MORTALITY AND LOW BIRTH
RATE. DR MALUS SHARED SOME DATA
BUT I ALSO WANT TO SHARE THAT
INSPIRED YOU KNOW FOR EXAMPLE
BLACK BABIES ARE MORE THAN
THREE TIMES MORE LIKELY TO DIE
BEFORE THEIR FIRST BIRTHDAY
THAT MIGHT BE. AND IT'S NOT
CHEN ALL WE KNOW WHAT THE
STOMACH. DATA ON THE
EXPERIENCES OF BLACK WOMEN
POINT TWO STARKLY UNEQUAL
TREATMENT. LEADING TO SEVERE
GAPS AND HEALTH AND ECONOMIC
OUTCOMES AND OPPORTUNITIES.
BLACK WOMEN ARE MORE LIKELY TO.
HOUSING INSTABILITY AND LESS
LIKELY TO HAVE THE SOCIAL
FINANCIAL AND EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
THEY NEED DURING PREGNANCY AND
BIRTH. SB SIXTY FIVE LAYS THE
GROUNDWORK FOR A CULTURALLY
CONCORD APPROACH LEVERAGING THE
POWER ABSTRACT AND SHARED
EXPERIENCES TO PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED SOCIAL SUPPORT THREE DO
LET. US ARE IN CENTRAL POINT
AND I DRAFTING THE SCRAP LOAD
THAT DRIVE BURKE DISPARITIES.
THANK CREE THINK WORK BENEFITS
AND PROVIDING A STABLE IDEAL
UNIVERSAL INCOME WILL BE HIGHLY
EFFECTIVE IN REACHING BLACK
WOMEN HELPING TO REDUCE AN
EQUITY. I ALSO WANT TO SAY THAT
I'M A FORMER- FORMER FOSTER
YOUTH AND I LIVED IN MORE OFTEN
HOMES IN THE COUNTY I REMEMBER
TRYING TO ACCESS THE PENINSULA
SERVICES AND BEING FULL WITH
MANY ACTIVE REQUIREMENT
BARRIERS. HI JACK HAD ACCESS TO
UNENCUMBERED FINANCIAL SUPPORT
MY JOURNEY TO WHERE I AM TODAY
WHAT HAPPENS OKAY. AND LAST
COMIC STRESS. I'M NOT CERTAIN I
DID NUMBER INSTANCES OF
FINANCING MENTAL AND MENTAL
HEALTH IN THE BILL. THIRTY CHAU
THAT PEOPLE KNEW STUFF WILL AND
WORKING THEY NEED LIKE HOW.
FOOD AND HEALTH CARE. AND
DESPITE THE DATA THAT CLEARLY
DEMONSTRATE INEQUITIES RARELY
DO WE FIND SOLUTIONS BUILT ON
APOLOGETICALLY AROUND THE NEEDS
OF BLACK WOMEN IN BABY. TODAY
THIS IS OUR OPPORTUNITY TO
RESPOND. YOU HAVE THE POWER TO
HEALTH INSURANCE BLACK WOMEN
AND GAY PEOPLE CALIFORNIA.
SOCIAL AND FINANCIAL SUPPORT
NEEDED TO BE GANG TO EXPERIENCE
BETTER OUTCOMES BLACK WELLNESS
AND PROSPERITY SKINNER EGGMAN
STRONG SUPPORT OF SB. SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. DO WE HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
SCENE NINE DO YOU HAVE ANY
ADDITIONAL PUBLIC SUPPORT THE
RTS STATION. NO OKAY OPERATOR
DO YOU HAVE ANY ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT ON THE LINE. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE
THEN ZERO. AN OUTLINE FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY YEAR MY COULD
OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS AND SENATORS
SKINNER XBOX HANDLED ON BEHALF
OF THE AMERICAN NURSES
ASSOCIATION HER CASE IN
CALIFORNIA AND TRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. THE LINE. FOUR
HUNDRED TWENTY FOUR. GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS NICOLE BORNEMANN ON
BEHALF OF THE CHILDREN'S
PARTNERSHIP AND SUPPORT. THANK
YOU. FIVE THREE HUNDRED NINETY
FOUR. KELLY BRUSH TESTIFYING ON
BEHALF OF YOUR CLIENTS FIRST ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PUBLIC HOSPITALS
AND HEALTH SYSTEMS IN SUPPORT
OF THE SECOND ON BEHALF OF THE
COUNTY HEALTH EXECUTIVES
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WITH
A SUPPORT IF AMENDED PETITION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
HUNDRED TWENTY SEVEN. CHAIRED
MEMBERS KATHY MOSSBERG ON
BEHALF OF THE FIRST FIVE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND ESSENTIAL ACCESS
HEALTH ALL IN SUPPORT AND SB
SIXTY FIVE. THANK YOU. LINE
FOUR HUNDRED FORTY. IT IS ONLY
HALF THE FIRST BITE CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU. THE LINE.
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY TWO. AND ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA PAN
ETHNIC HEALTH NETWORK SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY. YES LORI ON
BEHALF OF WESTERN CENTER ON LAW
AND POVERTY PROUD CO SPONSOR IN
STRONG SUPPORT. THANK YOU. LINE
FIVE HUNDRED FORTY FOUR. MADAM
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS ERIN
EVAN ON BEHALF OF NARAL PRO
CHOICE CALIFORNIA AND THE
CALIFORNIA NURSES MIDWIVES
ASSOCIATION TWO CO SPONSORS OF
THE MEASURE IN PROBLEM SUPPORT
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY ONE. GOOD
AFTERNOON DIANA DOUGLAS WITH
HEALTH ACCESS CALIFORNIA AND
POPCORN THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
LINE. ONE HUNDRED SEVENTY NINE.
YEAH KELLY MCMILLAN I'M CALLING
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
ESPECIALLY CARE COALITION IN
SUPPORT OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED SIXTY FOUR. HELLO THIS
IS JENNIFER POTS WITH THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. WHITE ONE HUNDRED
TWENTY FIVE. CAROLINA APPEARED
ON BEHALF OF ACLU CAL ACTION IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU. A
LINE ONE HUNDRED EIGHTY SEVEN.
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION THAT YOU
CAN TELL WHAT THE MARCH OF
DIMES FOR POWER BONSER COULD
BONTA SB SIXTY FIVE CALLING AND
STOP SUPPORT. THANK YOU. FIVE
THREE HUNDRED FIFTY FOUR. HI
THIS IS GREG PRODUCT- IN STRONG
SUPPORT FOR THE FRESNO CRADLE
TO CAREER AND THE CHILDREN
BERMAN OF FRESNO COUNTY THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LIVE. FIVE
HUNDRED FORTY SEVEN. K.
FOURTEEN ALONG ACTION PROJECT.
WE PROBABLY. THANK YOU. ONE
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY. HELLO GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME EXPECTATIONS
ALLEN I'M CALLING ON BEHALF OF
ADVANCEMENT PROJECT CALIFORNIA
STRONG SUPPORTER SB SIXTY FIVE
THANK YOU THANK YOU. LINE. FIVE
HUNDRED TWO. RANGE STATUS ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN COLLEGE
OF OBGYN STRYCHNINE LIKE TO
THANKS AND INNER AND SPONSORS
FOR WORK WITH US TO SOME
CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS WITH THE
ADOPTION BOTH THE MEN BECAUSE
PLEASED TO SUPPORT SB. SIXTY
FIVE THANK YOU THANK YOU ONE
MOMENT. WIFI. HUNDRED THIRTY
EIGHT. WORLD NEEDS. I HAVE NOT.
EMINEM ALIVE I APOLOGIZE AHEAD
THIS IS A TRUCE FROM SADIO TO
THE OWN BRAND THE WHOLE LOGAN
PHONE. AND WE ARE STRONG. THANK
YOU. RIGHT. ONE HUNDRED NINETY.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND MICHAEL
CARRERA A LOT THAT COUNTY OF
SUPERVISORS SPONSOR THANK YOU.
NINE FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY TWO.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS LYN
CHRISSY WITH MATERNAL AND CHILD
HEALTH ACCESS IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF SB SIXTY FIVE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY SEVEN. RIGHT NOW SON-
THANK GOODNESS I KNOW FIVE
DIFFERENT FITTING FORMATION AND
A STRONG SUPPORTER OF SB SIX
DECIDE. THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE
ONE MORE COMMENT COMING THROUGH
ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AND A LINE OF FIVE
HUNDRED SIXTY AND MY CAN OPENER.
HELLO I AM CALLING ON BEHALF OF
THE WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE AS
WELL AS THE CALIFORNIA HEALTHY
NAIL SALON COLLABORATIVE IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK
YOU. HEY MAN I'M SURE THERE ARE
NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE TIME.
THANK YOU- WE DO NOT HAVE- A
PRIMARY OPPOSITION WITNESS I DO
WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC OPPOSITION
IN THE ROOM. I'VE SEEN NONE. I
DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION AT RTS STATION. NOW
OKAY AND DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
OPERATOR FOUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO SB SIXTY FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO.
AND LINE THREE HUNDRED FIFTY OR
MY KIDS UP. LINE. THREE HUNDRED
FIFTY. AND THERE ARE NO FURTHER
COMMENT AT THE TIME THANK YOU
OPERATOR- DO WE HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE. AS SOMEONE CHOI.
US SENATOR SKINNER- THIS IS A-
PARTIALLY OUT OF THE GOOD
SUPPORT OF OUR POLITICIANS
THERE BUT THE READ THE AND THE
BILL ANALYSIS. SOME IMPROPER OF
PROCEDURES- THAT TOOK PLACE. IN
OTHER WORDS ARE SPECIFIC- HUNT
ON ONE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
MONTH THE PAYMENT. THIS SONG
WAS SUNG NOT EVEN HEARD. IN THE
SENATE THE HOUSE COMMITTEE IT
WAS A D. SO AMENDMENT WAS ADDED
TO. AFTER THE HEARING AT THE
SENATE THE HOUSE COMMITTEE. AND
THIS WASN'T JUST A RUSTED
THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE AND THE SENATE
WITHOUT THIS KNOWLEDGE AND ON I
DON'T KNOW HOW THIS CAN HAPPEN
IF WITH THIS IS SO OF PROPER.
IF THIS IS A- ALREADY KNOWN
DOESN'T IT HAVE TO GO BACK TO-
THE- THE SENATE HEALTH
COMMITTEE WITH YOUR AMENDMENTS.
THE SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE WAS
AWARE OF THE AMENDMENT AND
WHILE IT WAS NOT TAKEN IN THE
COMMITTEE- BECAUSE IT IS NOT A
FISCAL COMMITTEE. IT WAS SAID
TAKEN INDIA PROBES COMMITTEE.
SO ARE YOU SAYING THAT THE THIS
A- REQUIREMENT- OF A PAYING ONE
THOUSAND DOLLARS SO ONCE I DO
SO MY MOTHER WAS A- ADDED- AND-
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS- AT THE
SENATE HEALTH COMMITTEE. KNEW
ABOUT IT THE CHAIR WAS AWARE
YES. BUT- WHY AM I GETTING
THESE- DIFFERENT NON VERSION OF
ALL. CONCERNED THAT WAS NOT THE
CASE. THAT ANALYSIS IS- WHAT
YOU ARE READING FROM IS NOT THE
COMMITTEES ANALYSIS SO I AM NOT
SURE WHERE YOU HAVE- WHAT IN
FROM HOME I'M READING
REPUBLICAN BILL ANALYSIS.
PARDON EXCUSE ME PARTY.
REPUBLICAN PARTY ANALYSIS AND I
DON'T HAVE THAT BEFORE ME SO I
CAN ADDRESS WHAT IT
SPECIFICALLY SAYS. I THINK THIS
ONE ARE NOW NEEDS TO BE
REVIEWED BY REUTERS COMMITTEE.
I CANNOT I CANNOT TAKE YOUR
WORD SO IN THE BECAUSE I DON'T
START- SPECIFICALLY IT HAS BEEN
MENTIONED HERE. ASSEMBLY IS SSL
MEMBERS ARE SENATE RULES ALWAYS
HAS THE AUTHORITY TO TAKE BILLS
BACK IF THEY THINK IT'S IN
VIOLATION AND THEY DID NOT- SO
IF- CLEARLY- THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION. AND I
DON'T KNOW EVEN I HAVE A DATE
SO- IT IS A NECESSITY SENATE
BILL HUMAN SERVICES
SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR ON APRIL
TWENTIETH. COULD NOT BE- AND-
AN OLDER VERSION IF SOMEONE. I
HAVE ALL OF THIS IS THE ONLY
VERSION I HAVE I HAVE I HAVE A-
AT THAT. TO SEE- I'M NOT SURE I
DON'T HAVE THE VERSION BUT THAT
THAT YOU HAVE- I AM A MAN
ARAMBULA DID YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR- UP FIRST OFF
SENATOR I'M QUITE PLEASED THAT
YOU BRING THIS BILL BEFORE US
TODAY HAVING KNOWN FROM TEH
pDAVIES BOLTS FOR A WHILE SHE'S
A POWERFUL ADVOCATE. IN OUR
COMMUNITY STANDING UP FOR
WHAT'S OCCURRING TO MANY BLACK
WOMEN. NOT ONLY IN MY COMMUNITY
BUT THROUGHOUT THE STATE I
THINK THE MEASURE THAT'S BEFORE
US WILL GO A LONG WAY TOWARDS
ADDRESSING MANY OF THE SYSTEMIC
ISSUES THAT I'VE FACED ARE
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AND REALLY
APPRECIATIVE OF THIS BILL. I
WOULD JUST REMIND THIS
COMMITTEE OF FOR DISCUSSING
RULES THAT WE HAVE BOTH A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THIS
BILL I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO AN
OPPORTUNITY. TO BE ABLE TO VOTE
FOR IT LATER TODAY. THANK YOU
SEVEN MEMBERS. ANYBODY ELSE
HAVE A COMMENT ASSEMBLY MEMBER
I AM. THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
THANK YOU SENATE'S GONNA FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL. NONPROFIT
OF THE YEAR AND FIFTY WITH A
SIMPLE DISH WAS BLACK WOMEN FOR
WELLNESS FOR REASON. THIS KIND
OF WORK IS IMPORTANT IT'S LONG
OVERDUE- NOW IS THE RIGHT
MOMENT IT'S BEEN THE RIGHT
MOMENT FOR A LONG TIME I'M GLAD
IT BEFORE THIS COMMITTEE. I
LOOK FOR THE VOTING ON IT AS
WELL- THE DIFFERENCE OF OPINION
FROM RULES AS YOU'D MENTIONED
THAT'S BEEN SETTLED THEY'VE HAD
AN OPPORTUNITY TO THINK ABOUT
THIS AND RECALL IF THEY WANTED.
IT HASN'T IT'S MADE IT THIS FAR
NEEDS TO CONTINUE MOVING ALONG.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. I WOULD
AT ANY OTHER MEMBERS HAVE ANY
COMMENTS. OKAY- ASSEMBLY MENTOR
CHOI- I WOULD LIKE TO PUT THE
SENATOR CLOSE ON HER BILL RIGHT
NOW IF YOU. I DON'T HAVE ANY
OTHER COMMENTS THERE ARE.
TENSAI HERE TO DIFFERENT
VERSIONS I THINK I HAVE TO
FOLLOW UP WITH YOU CONSISTENT
COUPLE GAVE ME THIS UP- I'M
PROCEDURAL PROBLEM ON. THE
ISSUES SO HE HE HAS RACED. OKAY
GO AHEAD ALL I CAN AFFORD AND
IS THANK YOU SENATOR PER YOUR
PATIENTS GO HEAD AND- PLEASE
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON YOUR
BILL CERTAINLY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH- WE- MOST. NOT EVERYTHING
IN THE BILL BENEFITS THE LOWEST
INCOME A PREGNANT PEOPLE AND-
INFERENCE- THERE ARE PARTS OF
IT THAT BENEFIT MORE BUT WHAT
WE KNOW IS THAT IN TERMS OF
BLACK. MORTALITY IN AB MATERNAL
MORTALITY AND INFANT MORTALITY
IT IS CROSS ALL INCOME LEVELS
AND EDUCATION LEVELS. ONE ONLY
HAS TO US READ THE REPORTS OF
SERENA WILLIAMS BIRTH FOR
EXAMPLE BEYOND STAYS MANY MORE-
SO WHILE THIS BILL WILL NOT
ADDRESS. OR FIX ALL OF THOSE
DISPARITIES THE DATA COMPONENTS
ARE VERY IMPORTANT FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND THEM AND THEN
FINALLY I WOULD SAY THAT- THERE
MUCH OF THE TALK HAS BEEN SO
FAR ABOUT THE SUPPORT- DURING
PREGNANCY. HOWEVER WE ALSO KNOW
THAT THOSE FIRST WEEKS AND
MONTHS AFTER BIRTH ARE ALSO
VERY VERY IMPORTANT AND- MANY
MANY MOTHERS WHO EITHER. ARE
YOU KNOW WERE INJURED DURING
THE DELIVERY OR WHOSE BABIES
HAVE ISSUES HAVE NO SUPPORT.
AND I YOU KNOW I CAN UNDERSTAND
THIS INTELLECTUALLY AND WHEN I
CARRIED WHEN I INTRODUCED THIS
BILL I APPRECIATED IT ALL
INTELLECTUALLY HOWEVER I'VE
JUST EXPERIENCED MY FIRST GRAND
BABY WAS BORN JUST ON JUNE
NINTH. MY DAUGHTER HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TO LIVE RE WHICH HAS
RESULTED IN SOME INJURY THAT
SHE NOW HAS TO HEAL FROM. AND
HER BABY HAD SOME ISSUES. SHE
WAS IN A SITUATION BECAUSE OF
HER SUPPORT SYSTEM TO BE ABLE
SHE HAS TO LOOK HERE. AND WHAT
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN IF SHE DID
NOT HAVE THAT TO LOOK HERE I
CAN'T SAY. AND SO THAT THE BILL
ALSO WHICH WAS NOT MENTIONED
PROVIDES DULY KERR- IN OUR
MEDIC HEALTH PROGRAM AND-
THAT'S I THINK SO IMPORTANT SO
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR AND WE HAVE A
MOTION FROM A SOMEONE ARAMBULA
AND SECOND FROM ASSEMBLY
MEMBRANE. THE MOTION IS DEEP
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
CALDERON AYE CALDERON AYE
DAVIES DAVIES NO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA ALRIGHT BRIAN. BRIAN
HI CHOI. CHOI NOT VOTING STONE
STONE I WILL PUT IT ON
FILIPPIDIS I WARD. OKAY THE
VOTE FIVE TO ONE OF THE LEGAL
CALL THANK YOU YOU'RE WELCOME
OKAY WOULD YOU LIKE TO RESIDENT
ON THE FINAL BILL SB THREE FIVE
FOUR THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THANK YOU COMMITTEE FOR YOUR
PATIENCE I KNOW YOU'VE HAD A
LONG HEARING. SB THREE FIFTY
FOUR RECOGNIZES THAT CHILDREN
DO BETTER WITH FAMILY
CARETAKERS AND THERE ARE SOME
CIRCUMSTANCES WHERE WE HAVE IN
BECAUSE OF WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE CHILDREN ARE NOT ENDANGERED
THAT WE HAVE PUT UP SOME
OBSTACLES AT TIMES TO. A
RELATIVE OR A EXTENDED FAMILY
BEING ABLE TO CARE TAKE FOR A
CHILD AND WHAT THIS BILL DOES
IS WE WORKED VERY CLOSELY WITH
OUR WELFARE DIRECTORS TO
DEVELOP SOMETHING THAT THEY
WOULD HAVE CONFIDENCE IN THAT
COULD HELP PRIORITIZE.
RELATIVES AND EXTENDED FAMILY
CARETAKERS WERE EVER THAT WAS
POSSIBLE AND SO WITH THAT I'D
LIKE MY WITNESSES BONIOR
QUARRELS FROM STARTING OVER
INCORPORATED TO SPEAK AND KATHY
SANDERLING FROM THE COUNTY
WELFARE DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU SENATOR I EACH
WITNESS WILL HAVE TWO MINUTES
TO THAT TESTIFYING SUPPORT
OPERATOR COULD YOU PLEASE OPEN
THE LINE- OPENING UP THE LINES
ONE MOMENT PLEASE. AND BOTH
LINES ARE OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS TANYA
QUARRELS AND I'D LIKE TO THINK
THAT SHARING COMMITTEE. FOR
HEARING THIS BILL AND ALSO
THANK YOU TO SENATOR SKINNER
OFFERING THIS BILL. I'M A
PRACTICING ATTORNEY AND A CO
FOUNDER AND DIRECTOR OF
STARTING OVER. JOINING OVER WAS
THE NONPROFIT OF THE YEAR TWICE
IN THE YEAR TWENTY TWENTY. I'M
ALSO A THIRD GENERATION
CONVICTED FELON. I AM THE
DAUGHTER THAT SPENT FIVE YEARS
IN THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. I'M
THE MOTHER OF SIX THEY HAD
THREE OF MY SIX CHILDREN
ADOPTED OUT TO STRANGERS. I AM
A GRANDMOTHER THAT NEEDED TO
STEP UP FOR TWO OF MY THIRTEEN
GRANDCHILDREN TO GET THEM OUT
OF THE FOSTER CARE SYSTEM. IT
TOOK ME OVER TWO HUNDRED DAYS
TO CLEAR THE RFA PROCESS. IN
SPITE OF MY DEMONSTRATED
REHABILITATION. AND THE
PRIVILEGES THAT COME WITH BEING
ATTORNEY. AND MY DEMONSTRATED
ABILITY TO CARE FOR AND LOVE MY
GRANDCHILDREN IT TOOK ME OVER
TWO HUNDRED DAYS. I WAS
FORTUNATE BECAUSE I ENDED UP
BRINGING MY GRANDCHILDREN HOME.
I HAD A RELATIONSHIP WITH MY
GRANDCHILDREN BEFORE CPS
STEPPED IN AND TOOK THEM FROM
THEIR MOTHER- THE PATERNAL
GRANDMOTHER. AND I HAD
ESTABLISHED A RELATIONSHIP BUT
BECAUSE OF MY THIRTY PLUS YEAR
OLD CRIMINAL CONVICTION HISTORY
IT BECAME A HUGE BARRIER TO ME
BRINGING THEM HOME AND THEY
ACTUALLY HAD TO BE PLACED WITH
NON RELATIVES FOR ABOUT SEVEN
MONTHS DURING THE PROCESS. MY
GRANDSON WAS FOUR MONTHS OLD
WHEN THIS STARTED AND I WAS I
LATER RECEIVED UNLIKE OTHER
GRANDDAUGHTER WHO WAS TWO
MONTHS OLD AND SHE'S BEEN WITH
US FOR ABOUT TWO YEARS NOW. THE
PART THAT BECAME THE BIGGEST
BARRIER WASN'T HOW I'M LIVING
TODAY. BUT DRUG CONVICTIONS
FROM THIRTY YEARS AGO BUT I
CANNOT AND DO. AND THIS IS AN
ISSUE THAT'S SPECIFIC TO ME.
THURMOND STARTING OVER I WORK
WITH AND INTERACT WITH MOTHERS
EVERY DAY WHO FACE THESE
BARRIERS MANY OF HOME FIND
THESE BARRIERS TO BE
INSURMOUNTABLE. AND SO
UNDERSTANDING THAT OUR FIRST
PRIORITY IS THE CHILDREN I
BELIEVE THAT THESE ARE CHILDREN
THE CHILDREN WHO ARE GOING INTO
THE HILD WELFARE SYSTEM
DESERVE THE BENEFITS OF AN
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENT. AND
IT COMES TO RELATIVES OR NON
RELATIVES IN THE FAMILY MEMBERS
THAT HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE CHILD AND SO IN A BROAD
BLANKET. YOU'RE LIKE YOU KNOW
YOU HAVE CRIMINAL CONVICTIONS
THAT RESTRICT YOU FROM EVER.
BRINGING CHILDREN OUT OF THE
CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM. ISN'T
THAT A GOOD OUTCOME THAT WE
WANT AND I BELIEVE THAT WE ALL
WANT WHAT'S BEST FOR THE
CHILDREN BUT I BELIEVE THAT
THIS PARTICULAR BARRIER IS
CREATING MORE HARM BECAUSE
WE'RE BASING THE OUTCOME OF
CHILD PLACEMENT. ON THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM. THAT
THE DATA SHOWN HAVE THAT THIS
DISPARITY IMPACT UPON BLACK AND
BROWN PEOPLE IN OUR COMMUNITY
AND THEREFORE BELCHING BLACK
AND BROWN CHILDREN ARE AT A
DISADVANTAGE WHEN IT COMES TO
BEING PLACED WITH FAMILY
MEMBERS BECAUSE WE'RE RELYING.
ON CRIMINAL BACKGROUNDS TO THE
POINT THAT WE FOREGO EVERYTHING
ELSE. SO NOW I'M ABLE TO READ
TO MY GRANDCHILDREN LOVE MY
GRANDCHILDREN AND BE IN THEIR
LIFE. AND I BELIEVE THIS IS-
GOOD FOR OUR FAMILY IT'S GOOD
FOR CALIFORNIA AND MORE AND
MORE PEOPLE SHOULD BE AFFORDED
THEBENEFITS OF AN
INDIVIDUALIZED ASSESSMENT I ASK
AND URGE YOU TO VOTE YES ON SB.
SIXTY FOUR- SO THAT MORE OF US
WOULD HAVE THIS OPPORTUNITY AND
I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME AND FOR LISTENING
AGAIN MY NAME IS TANYA QUARRELS
I'M A NATIVE OF CALIFORNIA AND
I LIVE IN RIVERSIDE COUNTY. AND
I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU MS
CORALS OPERATOR CAN YOU PLEASE
OPEN THE LINE FOR NEXT WITNESS-
CATHERINE SANDERLING A DONALD
AND YOU HAVE TWO MINUTES. THANK
YOU. GREAT THANK YOU MADAM%
CHAIR AND MEMBERS HAPPY
THUNDERWING MAKE ALL BUT THE
QUOTE THAT COUNTY WELFARE
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION. DWTS
REALLY PLEASED TO BE ABLE TO CO
SPONSOR SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
WITH A HOST OF OTHER AMAZING
ORGANIZATIONS IN HONOR TO
TESTIFY WITH YOU TODAY. FIRST I
THINK THE COURT AND LIFT UP THE
COMMENT BY SENATOR SKINNER AND
MISS QUARRELS REGARDING
DISPROPORTIONATELY THAT EXIST
IN OUR CHILD WELFARE SYSTEM AS
ONE OF THE INEQUITIES IN OUR
UNDERLYING CRIMINALS THAT THAT
THAT THAT. THAT NEGATIVELY
AFFECT RELATIVE SPEAKING TO
CARE FOR CHILDREN ARE BROUGHT
INTO FOSTER CARE STEMMING
COUNTY CHILD WELFARE AGENCY
PERSPECTIVE THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT. BECAUSE IT WILL HELP
CHINESE PLACE MORE CHILDREN
WITH RELATIVE CAREGIVERS WHEN
THEY COME INTO CARE RESEARCH
SHOWS THAT CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE ARE MUCH BETTER WITH
RELATIVES IN GENERAL AND
RELATIVE TO THE FIRST PLACE
COUNTY TURNED OUT BY LAW AND
BEST PRACTICE. AS PART OF THE
RESEARCH FAMILY APPROVAL
PROCESS WHICH APPLIES TO ALL
POTENTIAL CARE GIVERS ANY
PERSON LIVING IN A REGULARLY
PRESENT IN THE HOME NOT BE
BACKGROUND CHECKED. ANYONE WITH
MORE THAN A MINOR TRAFFIC OR
MARIJUANA INTERACTION BUT THE
CAN EXEMPTION OR THE HOME
CANNOT BE APPROVED. EXEMPTIONS
ARE DONE ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS GRANTED AFTER NEXT CENTER
REVIEW OF THE CRIME AS WELL AS
THE PERSON IS TAKEN STEPS THAT
TIME TO SHOW THEY HAVE CHANGED
AND ARE ABLE TO PROVIDE A SAFE
AND LOVING ENVIRONMENT. NOT
EVERY EXEMPTION OR CLUSTERS
GRANTED AN APPROVAL OF THE
EXEMPTION AND SUBSEQUENT
APPROVAL AT THE RESORT FAMILY
DOES NOT GUARANTEE THAT A.
PARTICULAR CHILD WILL BE PLACED
IN THAT HOUSE. IN RECENT YEARS
HE- HAS SUPPORT INCOME. EFFORTS
TO THE- AND EXPAND. THE
AVAILABILITY OF EXEMPTS FOR
MINOR CRIMES. AND CRIMES THAT
OCCURRED THE PAST. HOW MANY
CRIMES REMAIN ON. THIS BILL
TAKES IT APART NEXT STEP GUIDED
BY A RECENT HARDCORE DECISION
STICK IT WHERE THE CURRENT CROP
OF UNCONSTITUTIONAL. WHEN IT
COMES TO RELATIVES AND NON
RELATED EXTENDED FAMILY MEMBERS
SHOULD BE CONSIDERED A
POTENTIAL CARE GIVERS FOR
SPECIFIC RELATED CHILD. IN THE
DECISION TELL THEM THEIR
KNOWLEDGE THAT THE COURT WILL
THAT SOMEONE CONVICTED OF A
CRIME. THAT OTHERWISE CONSIDER
NOT UNCOMFORTABLE UNDER LAW.
MUST BE GIVEN A CASE BY CASE
CHANCE TO REQUEST THEM ATTACHED
WOULD RECEIVE AN EXAM CENTER.
IF THE RELATIONSHIP OF THE
CHILD THAT THEY CAN'T GET OUT
OF A PARENT. SCALIA'S
CONSIDERING AN EXEMPTION UNDER
THIS NEW PROVISION WOULD
ESTABLISH THAT SUCH A
RELATIONSHIP THE BEST. INTEREST
OF THE CHILD THE RELATIVES AND
OTHERS WITH KNOWLEDGE OF THE
RELATIONSHIP. THIS WILL BE HELD
BY THE TYLER FAMILY TEAMING
PROPER CREDIT CARD WITH A CHILD
IS BROUGHT INTO CARE. WHICH
INCLUDES OTHER FAMILY MEMBERS
AS WELL AS OTHER SUPPORT AND
THE CHILD'S LIFE. IMPORTANTLY
THE EXEMPTION PROCESS ITSELF
REMAIN AN EXPENSIVE CASE BY
CASE. PROCESS AND IT WOULD NOT
BE AUTOMATIC. RIGHT COUNTY
SANTA. WHEN IT EVEN. PEARL OF
CARE FOR PER. CHILD'S EVEN IF
THEIR CRIME OCCUR LAW AGO AND
CLEARLY CHANGED I NEVER NOTHING
EXISTING RELATIONS. WITH ITS-
THE CARD IS A MADE CLEAR THAT
NEED TO CHECK OUR LIVES ALLOW
FOR THAT CASE CASE EXEMPTION
THE CONFEDERATE. WHEN HE
PARLAYED HAVE ALREADY EXIST
BETWEEN THE CHILD. AND THE
RELATIVE TO OTHER POTENTIAL
CARE GIVER SHE DID EATING IT
SUPPORT. CHANGE AND THAT THE
THREE FIFTY FOUR WHAT'S
ACTUATED AND THAT THAT
STATEWIDE MATTER. PRETTY THREE
CONFIGURED YOUR SUPPORT ON THE
BILL AND I'M HAPPY TO. ANSWER.
ANY QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU- I. DO WAY ANY AND-
PUBLIC SUPPORT IN THE ROOM.
THREE NINE TWO ANY ADDITIONAL
PUBLIC SUPPORT IN RTS STATION.
YEAH OKAY DO WE HAVE ANY
PETITION ADDITIONAL SUPPORT ON
THE LINE IF SO PLEASE STATE
YOUR NAME AFFILIATION AND
POSITION OPERATOR CAN OPEN THE
LINE. COMMENT IN SUPPORT OF S.
B. THREE FIVE FOUR PLEASE PRESS
ONE AND THEN ZERO THAT COMMAND
AGAIN ONE ZERO. BY FIVE HUNDRED
FIFTY NINE OR MY COULD OPEN.
YOU CARE MEMBERS PREFERRED TO
TALK ON BEHALF OF THE CENTER
FOR EMPLOYMENT OPPORTUNITIES
AND CITY AND COUNTY OF SAN
FRANCISCO IN SUPPORT THANK
YOUNG. THANK YOU. LINE FOUR
HUNDRED NINETY SEVEN. THANK YOU
MADAM CHAIR ANNUALLY GOING TO
BOMBYOU HAVE TO THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIA GLAD TO
SUPPORT A THREE FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. ONE FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE. NINE FIVE HUNDRED
SEVENTY FIVE YOU'RE MY COULD
OPEN. LINE ONE HUNDRED TWENTY
FIVE. CAROLINA APPROVED ON
BEHALF OF THE ACLU CAL ACTION
IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU. THE
BLIND. FOUR HUNDRED SEVENTEEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON THIS IS MICHAEL
UROLOGY WHICH CALIFORNIA TRIBAL
FAMILY COALITION AND WE WOULD
LIKE TO VOICE THEIR SUPPORT FOR
SB THREE FIFTY FOUR WE WOULD
ALSO AFFECT THAT. WOULD ALSO
REQUIRE THAT- THE LEGISLATION
WOULD BE AMENDED TO INCLUDE
TRIBAL HOME THANK THAT ARE
APPROVED BY TRIED. AND A LINE
OF. FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY FIVE. HI
MY NAME IS PETER TO GO-
CALIFORNIA RESIDENT AND A
MEMBER OF THE UNDERGROUND
SCHOLARS INITIATIVE AT
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
RIVERSIDE AND CO SPONSOR OF SB
THREE FIFTY FOUR AND I SUPPORT
STRONGLY SB FIFTY FOUR. THANK
YOU THANK YOU. LINE. FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY EIGHT. I'M ONLY
I'M WITH THE FAMILY
REUNIFICATION EQUITY AN
APARTMENT PROJECT AND I
STRONGLY SUPPORT SB FIFTY FOUR.
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE ONE MORE
COMMENT COMING THROUGH ITS LINE
OF FIVE HUNDRED SEVENTY FOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI THIS IS
DAVID NOBLE AND I'M WITH THE
ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S RIGHTS
WERE ONE OF THE CO SPONSORS. OF
THE BILL AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT IT. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THE
TIME THANK YOU OPERATOR- WE
DON'T HAVE ANY PRIMARY
OPPOSITION WITNESSES FOR THE
SPELL- IS THERE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION IN THE ROOM. C. NINE
DO WE HAVE ANY PUBLIC
OPPOSITION IN OUR STATION. NO
OKAY OPERATOR IS ANYBODY QUEUED
UP ON THE LINE- THAT WANTS TO
PUBLICLY OPPOSE THE BILL. THE
GENERAL OF THE COMMON
OPPOSITION SB THREE FIFTY FOUR
PLEASE PRESS ONE ZERO. AND WITH
THAT ANNOUNCEMENT MADAM CHAIR
NO CALLERS HAVE QUEUED UP.
THANK YOU. I DO HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS FOR THE AUTHOR FROM
THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND- FIGURE
THIS IS MY FIRST NAME MODEL
TALK A LITTLE BIT. SENATOR
SKINNER YOU KNOW WE KNOW THAT.
THE COMMUNITIES THAT ARE MOST
LIKELY TO GET ENTANGLED WITH
THE CRIMINAL LEGAL SYSTEM ON
THE SAME COMMUNITIES THAT ARE.
MOST LIKELY TO HAVE THEIR
CHILDREN TAKEN FROM THEM IN
THIS BILL LOOKS. AT THAT
INTERSECTION IN AIMS TO DO
SOMETHING ABOUT IT- I STRONGLY
COMMEND YOU FOR THIS IF YOU ARE
LOOKING FOR CALL OFFICE I WOULD
BE HAPPY TO JOIN YOU. IN THIS
FIGHT- YOU HAVE MY VOTE TODAY
THANK. CAPITA COST OF- HI
SENATORS CAN WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE ESCROW VOTE THANK YOU
THANK YOU. AND WE HAVE A MOTION
FROM SOME WOMEN CHOI IN THE
SECOND FROM THE FAMILY WOMAN
DAVIES. THE MOTION IS DAVE
PASSED TO THE ASSEMBLY
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE CALDERON
AYE CALDERON AYE DAVIES DAVIES
I ARAMBULA. BRYANT BRIAN I'D
CHOI. CHU AYE AYES STONE STONE
I AM FILIPPIDIS. BILLABLE TO
AYE LORD LORD HI. AB SEVENTY
ZERO THANK YOU SENATOR THANK
YOU SO MUCH BENJAMIN COMMITTEE
MEMBERS CRISTINA WE'RE GONNA
LET THE CALL. ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR CURRENT VOTE SIX TO
ZERO DAVIES DAVIES ICE. STONE I
FINAL VOTE ON THE CONSENT
CALENDAR EIGHT ZERO. FILE ITEM
LINE SB SEVEN THIRTY NINE
CURRENT VOTE FIVE TWO ZERO WARD
WARD I HAVE FINAL THAT'S SIX
TWO ZERO. FILE ITEM TO SB SIX
THIRTY NINE CURRENT VOTE SIX TO
ONE FINAL VOTE SIX TO ONE. S.
B. FILE ITEM THREE SB ONE OH
EIGHT CURRENT VOTE SIX TO ZERO
ARAMBULA. WARRANT I CURRENT
VOTE SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
FULLER SB THREE NINETY THREE
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN TO ZERO MORT
MORT I FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO
ZERO. FILE ITEM FIVE SB FOUR
SIXTY FOUR. FINAL VOTE SIX TO
TWO. FILE ITEM TEN SB FIFTY
FINAL VOTE EIGHT TWO ZERO. FILE
ITEM FOURTEEN SB SIXTY FIVE
CURRENT VOTE. FIVE TO ONE WARD
WARD II FINAL VOTE. SIX TO ONE.
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SB. THREE
FIFTY FOUR. CURRENT VOTE
SEVENTY ZERO ARAMBULA. CURRENT
VOTE. SEVEN ZERO. FILE ITEM
SIXTEEN SB FIVE FORTY SIX
CURRENT VOTE SEVEN ZERO WARD
MORT I FINAL VOTE. EIGHT ZERO.
K. THIS IS BEFORE THE ASSEMBLY
HUMAN SERVICE COMMITTEE IS
COMPLETE THE HEARING IS
ADJOURNED.